Hier kommen sie gerne rein,
na hallo frau doktor wissen sie woher britta äh ja er war eben grad noch hier ist mit,
ganz viel kontoauszüge den gang runter ähm aber warum besuchen sie ihn eigentlich erst wenn wenig spät für seine ps die zwei selbsthilfegruppe deswegen gehe ich direkt mal weiter,
okay ciao,
hallo herr bardt schön dass ihr wieder bei uns sind,
ich bin ein nach berlin bin ein nackedei der sich in einer lieder hülle dann am ende versteckt aber alles beim alten.
Tschüss.
Da bin ich jetzt zu spät kontoauszüge per post zu eine ganze kiste voll mit auch schwer,
diese briefe hier die passt auch nicht bei den in den briefkasten oder muss ich mir diese dinger bei der frost abholen weil ich mir denke dass wir was zu sein ich krieg jetzt haben wollte.
Hast du ein brillen putzt tuch damit ich mir die tränen aus der brille putzen kann.
Ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung küchenrolle tut's nicht oder.
Ah ne na ja.
Das habe ich befürchtet ne da bin ich noch nicht so weit obwohl ich mich mit dem thema brille weiterhin beschäftige und fortschritte mache ich habe erstmal ganz grundlegende erkenntnisse.
Ich bin immer noch bei dem intro.
Ja
dass das in drucker ja im prinzip jede sendung immer wieder.
Machen weil ich bin mir sicher irgendwas äußern wir immer was uns so leicht klappmesser rüberkommen lässt aber so sind wir halt in der freak show ich meine deswegen heißt die veranstaltungen auch so ne,
da sind wir nämlich fried show zwo vier zwo,
gerade holgi hat seine tausendste sendung bei wind voll da schauen wir mal,
kann sich nur noch um dreißig jahre alt.
Holger hat bei dem der geschichte podcast von ihm oder auch seine sendung.
Nein das ist sein sender wer,
du bist wirklich so raus aus dem spiel.
Aber vielleicht sind ja nur noch drei hörer die das auch nicht.
Mach erstmal ein mikrofon richtig ne ist nicht.
Hier so ganz nah dran.
Nicht so dass man im bad schubbern hört.
So jetzt darfst du ich geb dir noch ein bisschen gehen.
Ich weiß nicht ich bin immer noch beim nackten huckel so ein bisschen den nackedei in der liga leder hölle.
Ja genau und ich und ich verbringe zeit im supermarkt um irgendwelche billig lesebrille aufzusetzen weil da hat man ja seine ruhe,
und ich finde es erstaunlich dass du supermärkte also zumindest die die ich besuche was nicht vielleicht ist es ja auch nur im prenzlauer berg so prenzlauer berg.
Zielgruppen orientierte.
Na ja auf jeden fall gibt's da so regale mit lesebrille.
Ja ich finde.
Und das coole ist sie haben da sozusagen so alle dioptrien so neben meiner nah.
Einen halben schritten.
Und dann kann man da so ein bisschen testen.
Und wie weit bist du schon.
Ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir noch nicht so richtig so sicher also ich habe mit eins,
werde ich eigentlich so brauchbar korrigiert und wenn ich dann mehr nehmen,
dann muss ich halt näher ran oder darf ich näher ran je nachdem ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie ich das interpretieren soll also man kann sein telefon noch näher ranhalten wenn's zwei ist ist das dann für mich richtig oder,
nicht.
Also diese frage wird dir wahrscheinlich einen augenarzt beantworten können bei dem du einen richtigen test machst.
Test test ich muss erstmal selber testen ich will auch nicht ich will ja nicht in so einer situation sein dass ich dass ich von irgendjemand erzählt irgendwas erzählt bekomme ich wäre sozusagen auch mit eigenen erfahrungen daherkommen.
Das mögen auch ärzte wenn man vorher schon mal gegoogelt hat und sagte ich habe da schon eine idee was meine diagnose ist.
Ich habe da schon diverse blogs gelesen wissen sie auf twitter.
Da sagt man mir ich habe.
Der twitter arzt.
Sag mal ich höre mich so komisch hört man mich richtig.
Ja ich werd dich richtig was ist komisch.
Ich weiß nicht für mich komisch an.
Bald ist krank.
Nicht nicht schlimmer als normal.
Ich mag dich.
Es ist alles in ordnung vielleicht sollten wir uns mal kurz vorstellen also ich bin tim,
immer zuerst vergesse ich mich einfach wieder vergiss mich einfach,
hat schwierigkeiten das wasser zu halten also im mund.
Danke dass ihr wieder so eine einladung für reiner.
Immerhin was jetzt nicht so schlimm dass deine tastatur,
wieder im lande genau du hast witze erzählen denn es hat hoffentlich für offiziell erzählen,
was immer was erzählt.
Er kann was von den weiten von azure erzählen.
Ach da warst du deswegen hat man dich nicht ran gekriegt ja naja also ich mach mir weniger gedanken darüber,
wie das aussehen soll also es ist jetzt nicht so ein,
nicht ich gucke mir nicht nicht an wie ich aussehe mit einer,
sondern ich mache mir mehr gedanken darüber wie sollte ich eigentlich gucken,
also ich ist ja immer alles so weißt du wenn 's weg ist dann erinnert man sich ja auch nicht mehr wie es früher war also ich find das schon erstaunlich dass wenn man dann so eine brille aufsetzen auf einmal ist das das display so scharf dann denke ich mir jedes mal,
war das früher auch so scharf.
Also vielleicht ganz ganz früh aber kannst du dich nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Aber früher war ja auch kein regina display.
Aber du hast doch nur.
Ja was scharfes ja trotzdem.
Was soll das ipad mit tina und das ipad.
Ja aber das habe ich dann nicht im supermarkt dabei.
Peter.
Also den laptop also was ja mein laptop ist ja immer noch kein regina weil apple mit mir keins bauen will,
auf jeden fall ich hab das gefühl ich komm weiter als ich gewöhn mich sozusagen an die situation und ich werde mich demnächst wahrscheinlich meinen ärzten unterhalten nicht an der kasse.
An der supermarktkasse dich mit dem am regal.
Im regal wie kommst du mit so den rahmen klar also das finde ich am am irritieren an an brillen wenn da plötzlich so dinge im gesicht fällt sind.
Ich muss zugeben dass ich bevorzugt rahmen lose brillen anprobieren wenn sie sich die möglichkeit ergibt auch wenn es jetzt für den test erstmal unerheblich.
Ja da muss man schon achten dass wenn die brille dass wenn man die auf hat dass die das glas sozusagen auch genauso,
ums auge ist nicht dass halt der rahmen so mitten im sichtfeld ist also es kommt immer drauf an manche setzen ja besser manche setzen schlechter und so,
und manche kann man zu nah ran schieben die kleben denn an den wimpern mehr oder weniger das stört auch also man muss schon die richtige brille ausgehen aber ist das jetzt das thema hier.
Tim vielleicht solltet ihr zusammen mal shoppen gehen.
Meine hier ist so eine simple schwarze plaster supermarkt brille ja so für,
drei brillen zuhause eine zum basteln löten wenn ich richtig nah gucken muss ich glaube das sind drei dioptrien
kann es sein das ist aber da musst du wirklich das auch nah vors gesicht halten was du da machst dann diese jetzt anderthalb die es so für desto benz auch so ein bisschen weiter weg ist oder laptop auch eigentlich so
und dann hab ich noch äh dazwischen eine brille ich glaub die hat dann zwei dioptrien nämlich man die ist praktisch wenn man so seinen telefon vor der nase hält aber die brauche ich zur zeit eigentlich.
Also du machst das tatsächlich auch so dass es sozusagen die gewünschte abstand in dem moment ist dein letzten endes die entscheidung für die jeweilige brille und du hast dann mehrere ist nicht so dass irgendeine falsche sondern es sind nur immer für die richtigen abstände richtig oder falsch.
Wobei du denn das.
Weil es ja leider keine wie sagt man telefonieren sind die sich einstellen ja was war das wort für einstellen doch.
Gleitsicht brillen.
Ne aber so wie bei bei der bei der objektiven die halt so ja so fokus genau das geht aber nicht also braucht man halt verschiedene.
Ich stehe hier gerade vor wie so eine autofokus brille aussehen würde.
Na da gibt's schon interessante sachen wo so flüssigkeiten drin sind die dann unter spannung gesetzt werden die dann ihre form also so bei linsen auch und so da gibt's schon tricks aber das ist wahrscheinlich noch wahrscheinlich.
Kommt die spannung her.
Aus dem gestell was er sich wie macht das diese google brille mit ihren kameras und displays und so.
Vielleicht sollten wir da mal wieder zurück zu der weisheit unseres schätz kommt was ihr mal echt machen solltet ist zum zahnarzt gehen,
und vor allem was halt auch drin ist also was auf,
selten der fall ist dass beide augen dieselbe denselben see wertverlust haben also dann braucht man sich halt nicht wundern dass mal die mal die und.
Es ist nicht mal die mal diese kommt auf den abstand.
Das äh wir hatten bei uns in der arbeitsgruppe die machen ja auch so primär aber die hatten,
'ne studierte oft hallo das ist kein arzt,
darf die gleichen untersuchungen machen wie ein arzt,
wird aber dafür nicht so richtig anerkannt also es gibt noch so ein zwischen den zwischen augenarzt und einfach nur optiker die auch teilweise niedergelassene praxen haben,
die darf dann halt nur keine diagnose stellen zum beispiel was so ein bisschen.
Wann kommt der werbeblock für die treppen lifte.
Die kommen nächstes jahr.
Ja das ist schon.
Also ich meine oft teil mou logi e ist die augenheilkunde.
Genau und du kannst halt augenarzt sein oder einfach nur auf theologe.
Hier steht das oft synonym für augenarzt.
Kann ja also augen ärzte sind auch gleichzeitig oft timo loggen es gibt aber oft ja loggen sie sind keine ärzte,
auf theologen also die haben halt die haben halt ja ne die haben halt kein medizin studiert das ist der unterschied die haben nur augen kunde im weitesten sinne ein bachelor da drin.
Die haben einfach in ihrem leben viel geguckt und wissen bescheid.
Ne also ist schon ist ein studium und du machst ja auch dein bachelor und kannst glaube ich auch master machen und du kannst sogar ein doktor in of the monologe machen es sind aber keine ärzte das ist so wie ich einen doktor in medizin wissenschaften machen kann aber kein arzt bin,
das heißt ich darf nicht diagnosen stellen aber.
Ist das nicht dasselbe wie mit dem.
Medizin wissenschaftlerin sein.
Ja und die sind augen wissenschaftler.
Das heißt du darfst eigentlich reparieren aber du weißt da darf darüber bescheid.
Okay.
Okay aber wer lässt sich denn als oft mal monologe dann so niedersachsen ein bisschen sinnlos wenn er dann nicht behandeln darf.
Na
Homöopathie.
Viele sachen die ja im schlimmsten falls können sie homöopathie aufschreiben,
aber viele gerade so so der klassische patient mit alters weitsicht oder irgendwie,
schwierigen unklaren see verhältnis,
der könnte halt zu einem of the loggen gehen der könnte zu einem augenoptiker gehen der muss ja nicht unbedingt zu einem augenarzt.
So ein schau berater.
Der kann halt mal gucken und sagt dann ok hier gehen sie zum arzt und damit brauchen sie einfach nur eine brille in der sehstärke viel spaß,
so sehr vereinfacht das ist halt eigentlich so die idee augen ärzte so ein bisschen zu entlasten das problem ist dass das hier halt nicht so richtig gut,
umgesetzt werden kann niederlassung zulassung kriegen,
nur ärzte und dafür keine diagnosen stellen obwohl er,
im weitesten sinne die gleichen untersuchungen macht augenarzt muss es gleich nochmal machen.
Verstehe wer wird gelernt,
hier lernt man ja immer was,
so und alle die dabei sind ja ich gehe ja auch zum,
gar nicht der punkt ich habe einfach eine sehr eigenwilligen art,
ich kann mich nicht also kennt ihr dieses problem also ist das so eine nord krankheit vielleicht oder so eine eigenschaft dass das das das man nicht einfach unvorbereitet sich jetzt auf irgendwelche experten einlassen möchte ohne,
zumindest nicht ansatzweise auch schon mal,
so ein grund bett führt das dann potenziell zu sammeln wissen haben also ich gehe ja zu ärzten und ich frage die dann immer sachen.
Das mögen die.
Da kommt darauf an was du fragst.
Wenn die das nicht mögen dann mag ich die nicht also für mich ist das so ein so ein so ein kriterium ob ein arzt oder,
wer auch immer die koryphäe in dem jeweiligen das gar nicht nur auf ärzte beschränkt generell um experten so keine ahnung also weil wenn man wenn man wenn man zu einem,
wenn man zum laden geht der einen folien aufs auto aufträgt dann macht man sich doch auch vorher schon mal schlau was es da so für systeme gibt
und welche welche methoden da so empfohlen werden und und und und welche techniken da gemacht werden und was war das vielleicht auch irgendwie alles normalerweise so kostet und was für zeiträume da sondern dann gehst du da hin und dann redest du mit denen,
und dann kannst du das ja überhaupt erstmal einordnen was dir erzählt wird.
Aber bist du ein termin hast da kannst du dich locker ein halbes jahr informieren.
Na wer das ding ist ich glaub beim arzt.
Beim folien laden.
Was da zum augenoptiker also beim arzt sehr gehe ich in der regel nicht mit vorher ich informiere mich mal was ich haben könnte hin weil aber wirst du irre wenn du dir irgendeine scheiße zusammen googlest und ich habe seitdem immer noch zuhause
aber du bist ja halt auch so von hast nix bis morgen bist du tot alles dabei also ich will bei solchen sachen die.
Man jetzt gar nicht weiß warum man sich gerade scheiße für das natürlich zu die fuß aber wenn du wegen eines ganz konkreten bestimmten problem so schon klar ist in welchem bereich sich das bewegt.
Das kannst du bei medizin selten sagen.
Selten heißt nicht,
generell weiß ich gern in etwa worauf ich mich einlasse,
ich stelle halt auch fragen und es hilft halt,
oft wenn man vorher auch schon so gewisse erfahrung hat und jetzt einfach irgendwie zum optiker zu reden und er wird mir irgendwelche drin zahlen um die ohren,
das bringt mich nicht weiter weil weil da immer so ein zeitlicher stress ist die haben ja mal keine zeit,
so und dann stehst du dann so aus muss alles ganz schnell gehen oder so kann ich jetzt noch eine frage fragen und so weiter und wenn ich das halt schon vorher so halbwegs sortiert hab so dann kann ich so die fachbegriffe kriegt dann irgendwie schon mal so klar dann kann ich sagen so ich habe schon dreimal in der frische darüber gequatscht,
jetzt bin ich auch so weit.
Und dann sagt der arzt leo habe ich gehört war echt spannend.
Ja da.
Ich muss ihnen da nochmal was erklären.
Ich glaube ich gehe halt eher ähm oder ich suche mir vorher ärzte aus oder versucht ärzte empfohlen zu bekommen wo ich weiß die sind irgendwie cool drauf und dass man fragen kann oder sie halt auch ein bisschen mehr ähm,
erzählen ich weiß nicht ob das was ich erzählt habe ich war ja bei der sportmedizin bei der charité weiß gar nicht mehr für welche zwei sachen,
und die sind halt,
mega cool man tut sich da halt auch und die dir erklären dir halt auch alles und sportmediziner finde ich es,
irgendwie ein sehr interessanter schlag mediziner die machen wir auch die geilsten komplimente,
ich weiß nicht so die
die erklären die dann halt auch alles so warum sie jetzt irgendwas drin sehen und warum du sie keinen diagnostische also kein bild geben das verfahren gerade für die diagnostik brauchen weil sie an den beiden rumhängen und sagen ja nee,
lass mal da brauchen wir jetzt nicht extra dich nochmal in die röhre dafür einzuschieben also ich weiß nicht ich versuche dann eher über gute ärzte die man von freunden in polen bekommt,
mein glück,
weil ich meine ich bring mir auch nichts zu googeln eben diskurs da und es war so von oh könnte gerissen sein alles ist schlecht und du musst sofort operiert werden bis zu,
war was völlig anderes sein.
Ja aber du hast ja zumindest schon mal auf der wikipedia mal ministers durchgelesen wie du weißt wo es ist wie groß es ist was da normalerweise mit schiefgehen kann was.
So jetzt erinnern wir uns noch ganz kurz mal was habe ich studiert.
Alles wahrscheinlich.
Medizin und formate na da wusste ich auch schon noch wieder.
Ich wollte ja nur ein beispiel geben dafür dass also das wäre so die art vorbereitung also wenn du jetzt nicht medizin informativ studiert wissen wer das ja vielleicht sozusagen ganz.
Nee mach ich aber nicht also nicht bei ärzten in der tat nicht also weil meine tante auch selber ärztin ist und die hat 'n tierischen hals wenn ihr solche klugscheißer um die ecke kommen und das ist.
Ja gar nicht so sehr ums klugscheißen es geht mir auch um ich will ja auch deren sprache sprechen,
und die sollen sich ja auch bei mir trauen dürfen ihre sprache zu sprechen weil wenn die so rum eiern und mich immer so anschaue mit diesem ich brauch doch gar nicht erst anfang dir das zu erklären du verstehst das doch eh nicht,
ja dann dann werd ich wild,
ich will ja was was zugetraut bekommen also muss ich ja signale geben muss ja sozusagen unterschwellig kommunizieren,
doch mach es gibt alles und so und wenn man dann so ein paar lösen die fragen stellt dann kriegt man auch bei den anderen bei manchen leuten dann auch kriegt man in so einen anderen modus so in einem saal.
Braucht man aber so ein paar termine bis die ärzte ein auch so ein bisschen kennen also mit meinem zahnarzt und den hocke hat der digital auch dann da bin ich schon sehr oft
du eigentlich und der erzählt auch alles und ich kann alles fragen und der ist auch sehr ausgiebig in seine antworten,
wenn ich sonst hier bei irgendwelchen leuten bin das ist nicht fünf minuten da bist du froh werden überhaupt irgendwie,
zeit mit dem hast da ist nichts mit fragen und und lange erzählen.
Dann wollen wir einen anderen arzt.
Na schwierig.
Und termine gibt's.
Online nur nur noch da.
Ja aber das geht dann wiederum ganz gut weil es gibt immer irgendjemanden der äh grade seinen termin,
aufgegeben hat und ich klick mich dann einfach bei doktor sozusagen so den passenden facharzt da habe ich irgendwie ganz gute turnaround zeiten,
meine nächsten tag irgendwie watt wenn irgendwelche wehwehchen ansteht irgendwann wird's natürlich vielleicht dann auch sagen wir mal wenn was ist,
ne aber sowas was ich so standard untersuchung ist welcher langsam alt und so da muss man ja irgendwie sich
von oben bis unten und von hinten nach vorne einmal komplett durchchecken lassen dass man nicht das hat das hat doch das und wissen sie und überhaupt das und das auch das haben sie doch nicht gemacht dass sie noch leben,
so und das kann man irgendwie darüber ganz gut abfackeln weil es ja letzten endes egal wo du da irgendwie deine abstriche hinterlässt irgendwie dich anders an piksen lässt,
aber mir geht's jetzt gar nicht mehr nur primär um ärzte oder so und jetzt den ganzen brillen problematik hat er dann auch wieder so dieses,
okay da gibt's noch die optiker und ja vielleicht mehr zeit aber sie wollen dann immer irgendwie da stört mich so ein bisschen dieses für mich noch sehr unklare verhältnis zwischen was kriegt man jetzt empfohlen versus was verdient man an mir,
so alle erzählen wir mal wieder wie teuer irgendwie diese brillen sind.
Brennt.
Gar kein gefühl dafür dass ich will gleich irgendwie so ein beratungsgespräch reingehen.
Gläser sind teuer das ist der punkt.
Kleine korrektur dass die das studium heißt optometrie und die ja absolventen sind optometristen nicht oft timo loben also dann ist tatsächlich doch.
Technologie der augenarzt hier wurde noch otto pisst vorgeschlagen.
Aber das ist ein ausbildungsberuf also.
Kraft in der augenheilkunde.
Genau das ist halt da weiß ich nicht wie viel der machen darf an der sporthochschule gibt's halt zum beispiel einen studiengang augenoptik und optometrie und das sind dann das ist dann die berufsgruppe die ich meinte.
Ja der otto piste kümmert sich nämlich um die strabs logi e die lehre der schüler erkrankung sehr schönes wort und die neuro oft hammer logi oft helmut,
genau wenn's irgendwie neurotisch wird sehr schön,
bezeichnung für den augenarzt populisten.
Ja
Da gucken sie bestimmt auch wenn er hier reingewachsen kommst also ja ich wollte ja schon immer mal zum kulissen.
Ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Sie haben die folie aber ganz schön raus,
naja auf jeden fall äh ich lasse mich da irgendwie ran und das wird schon.
Es ist.
Trau dich dann.
Ich traue mich die ganze zeit ich beschäftige mich intensiv mit diesem thema.
Meine trau dich zum arzt zu gehen.
Oder zum optiker.
Optiker haben auch mehr zeit.
Ja aber muss ich erstmal wissen ob ich zum arzt oder zum optiker gehen.
Probiert's erstmal beim optiker die können.
Ich war schon mal beim optiker der hat mir halt gesagt so dass ich von ja.
Dann.
Geht zum augenarzt.
Kann ja auch gut gucken also weiter.
Ja also es gibt halt zum zum einen diese über hundert prozent sehkraft das heißt deine augen können sich halt gut auf unterschiedliche,
gegebenheiten anpassen und du hast du siehst halt gut aber das hat der nichts damit zu tun wo dein punkt geschäften sehen ist und wann deine augen so müde sind dass ihr das nicht mehr ausgleichen können,
da hilft deine brille.
Hauptsache ich sehe noch gut aus,
dabei ist das allerwichtigste,
so worüber wollten wir denn heute eigentlich sprechen ich war äh ich war ja vorhin demonstrieren.
Potsdamer platz oder wo.
Nee,
und an der marshall brücke also ich bin ein bisschen rum geguckt und dachte mir so fahre ich mal mit meinem einhundert prozent solar bedanken moped zur einer klima an die an die klima,
die klima pro pro klima aktions demo,
war ja hier irgendwie diese extension rebellion gerade versucht berlin platz machen,
ja das war ganz nett irgendwie also es war richtige kleine happy veranstaltung die da statt,
unterhaltsam alle tanzen so ganz nett mit musik unter der brücke schön so bietet alles ganz kuschelig also es hat so ein bisschen so,
mit herzchen formen machen während man so rum tanz und so da stelle ich ja mental eigentlich ja aus,
aber mein gott wenn es hilft dann kann man halt auch zu john lennon tanzen die bullen stand ein bisschen gelangweilt so rum und zwar halt alles so hatte so ein bisschen was von,
geilstes dorf.
Ich dachte ich hab was gehört von sitz blockaden wurden weg getragen und so.
Ja das gab's auch da es war mir so am bühnen dann bei der großen straße so aber ja damit sie nicht ganz interessiert und haben dann auch irgendwie gemerkt das dauert alles viel zu lange,
ab und zu fett da man zug vorbei und hut und dann gibt's immer großes geologie sehr klar ähm die deutsche bahn freut sich natürlich total so ja aber bei der straßen schön dicht fahren alle mehr,
mal gucken aber äh ich fand das ganz gut und vor allem hab ich das erste mal diesen mike check live,
miterlebt leider konnte ich das nicht aufzeichnen das kommt ja aus der wall street bewegung da ist meines meiner erkenntnis nach geboren worden,
nämlich was ja dieses problem da sitzt man irgendwie alle auf dieser brücke rum und jetzt möchtest du gerne dass die alle irgendwie was erfahren,
das weiß ich gibt um green mit mit der polizei oder irgendeine andere aktion soll gleich starten also möchtest du gerne das irgendwas,
herum gereicht wird an informationen jetzt hat man üblicherweise aber nicht immer gerade eine pn und mikrofon am start,
und das funktioniert dann so dass dann die person die was zu sagen hat die ruft dann ganz laut so laut sie kann in dem moment einfach in die umgebung der person herein mike check.
Was dann wiederum von den anderen oder zumindest einem den leuten die in dem moment als erstes reagieren beantwortet wird mit mike check und dann sagt sie nochmal mike check,
und dann haben das natürlich noch mehr leute gehört und entsprechend mehr leute antworten dann wieder ein zweites mal mike check und dann,
trägt diese person in dem fall war es mittel vor was ist denn jetzt,
es wird gleich und alle wiederholt,
am ende der brücke am ende der brücke eine aktion geben,
ein und das funktioniert super einfach wirklich total begeistert sofort und es war so klar verständlich für alle irre,
ja und so einfach also das top top.
Aber es ist an der zweiten stelle bleibt es dann hängen oder wenn es du bist mein wenn die demonstration groß genug ist muss ja auch das mit mehreren stufen dann machen oder.
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen das skaliert jetzt auf eine million leute aber das war sagen wir mal für die paar hundert leute die da auf der brücke waren also das hat jeder auf dieser januar witz brücke also auf der brücke,
unter dem unter der überführung problemlos mitbekommen und verstand,
also es war so so laut und klar ich würde sagen da haben so locker fünfzig bis hundert leute darauf geantwortet und das lief auch zackig und nicht so durcheinander,
ein gefühl dafür bekommen wie viel text man so vorgibt also,
sätze sagt aber auch wiederum nicht zu kurz damit es irgendwie auch inhaltlich erfasst werden kann das das fand ich sehr sehr geil sehr geile aktion da kann man auch,
vielleicht auch an anderen orten mal was lustig.
So wie beim nächsten hörer treffen auf dem kongress.
Ja der herbst kommt wirklich gleich.
Das ist eine gute idee.
Ich musste nur mit allen vorher so ein bisschen üben also.
Ja das war ganz gut das sehr geile idee kongresses glaube ich ein ganz ganz ganz gutes ein warmen dafür also muss man natürlich darüber zu erzählen haben.
Microphone ne.
Mikrofon genau und,
mich hat das irgendwie mich erinnert das jetzt gerade wieder an,
was wäre wenn ich trotzdem daran manchmal erinnern an ja sachen auch an sachen wo man dann gar nicht weiß warum sie eigentlich daran ey dann,
überlegen ob das hier relevant.
Ach als ob man in der nähe vom thema abkommen würde.
Ja naja.
Ich glaube gehört zu haben dass das tatsächlich eine art lukas vom gehirn ist dass informationen irgendwie verknüpft abgelegt werden obwohl die eigentlich nicht verknüpft sind.
Ja es ist wahrscheinlich geschafft überlegt noch gerade was was die richtige verbindung ist also worauf ich mich bezieher ist die gruppe äh ist ja noch gleich aus new york so 'ne künstlergruppe im heißt,
das ist das was ja vermutlich irgendwann schon mal in eurem leben ein video von denen gesehen
weil die sind schon sehr lange unterwegs und die bringen immer sehr geile aktion und ich habe es bestimmt ja auch irgendwann mal in afrika erzählt aber jetzt ist es trotzdem nochmal und sie haben vor ewigen zeiten ein
ding gemacht haben also 'ne menge coole sachen gemacht aber das ist auch eine der ersten aktion glaube ich ist die,
und das war so aus der zeit also ipads und so gerade in mode kam also nicht ganz neuwahlen sondern schon so die phase wo alle irgendwie ein hatten,
aber noch vor smartphone und so weiter,
und dann haben die in den central park eingeladen haben gesagt so hier samstag was weiß ich vierzehn uhr,
auf einer webseite haben sie das sozusagen angekündigt werden wir da sein und hier ist eine datei,
lade diese datei herunter höre sie dir nicht an,
auf dein ipad oder player oder was auch immer ja,
komm an diesen ort um diese uhrzeit sei bereit auf zukunft play zu.
Und klar heute könnte man mit streaming und so weiter das wieviel eleganter machen aber das war halt damals sozusagen das was irgendwie ging war dann aber eben auch nicht von internet abhängig zumindest nicht in dem moment,
und dann kam da wohl auch eine ganze menge leute gibt's auch ein video von,
was müssen paar hundert leute gewesen sein zweihundert leute vielleicht vielleicht was auch noch habe ich jetzt ein bisschen vielleicht schon mal den link raus und dann gibt es bestimmt auch noch ein video davon und so,
und was ihr den leuten aber nicht vorher gesagt haben ist dass ihr webserver
die links auf dieser website auf diese medien datei am laufenden meter ausgetauscht hat uns nicht nur eine einzige datei gab sondern es gab tatsächlich drei oder vier oder fünf sogar vielleicht also mehrere auf jeden fall,
was daneben zur folge hatten dass eben quasi drei vier,
mehr oder weniger gleich starke gruppen dadurch gebildet wurden die dann da hin kam und alle halt andere instruktionen erfuhren,
oder wo sieht man halt so begrüßt also alle hatten so kopfhörer auf,
und saßen natürlich erstmal im central park irgendwie so auf der wiese herum.
Und haben dann alle gestartet ich weiß ganz genau ob eine uhrzeit war oder ich glaube es kann sogar einer megafon rum und hat kurz irgendwie gesagt so jetzt oder wieso,
auf jeden fall war das ganz gut synchronisiert und dann,
wenn man sich das anhört was die dann erzählt bekommen habe was ganz lustig so da hallo willkommen irgendwie so und jetzt steht bitte alle mal auf und fangt an in alle richtungen zu winken,
dann hast du das video davon weißt du auf einmal so mit dem park so die hälfte der leute steht alle parallel auf und fängt an zu winken
und alle anderen sowas bitte wie was passiert hier weil ja nix gehört haben alle nur kopfhörer drin hatten ne sehr geil,
und dann haben die sich da halt in gruppen aufgeteilt wundern irgendwie dann dann dann taucht irgendwie so vier oder fünf verkleidete personen auf die dann immer die gruppen angeführt haben der kapitän und mit der große bär hast ja finde es gerade ob ich rolle aber so in verkleidung halt,
irgendwelche personen auf wo dann diese gruppen dieser person hinterher liefern und bestimmte dinge gemacht haben der kapitän dann alles rudern lassen was,
aus dem nichts daraus sich hier oben und dann irgendwie so ein ruderboot simuliert und andere dinge und so es war grandios ich krieg das nicht mehr komplett auswendig zusammen.
Warum fällt mir das jetzt ein weil das eben so eine
so eine so eine methode ist eine vorher komplett un koordinierte gruppe in dem moment auf etwas zu koordinieren zu synchronisieren und das ganze irgendwie auf so eine akustische art und weise,
man könnte ja auch genauso gut sagen heute haben sowieso alles smartphone dabei,
warum macht irgendwie extension rebell ja nicht gleich so ein stream,
wie wir das hier machen und koordiniert ihre aktion quasi über kopfhörer,
wir laufen jetzt alle da lagen was guckst du mich so an ist das keine gute idee.
Na ja mit dem streaming und im internet in deutschland entschuldige bitte.
Ja okay verstehe das verhindert natürlich die revolution das ist sorry wir können das klima nicht retten kein netz.
Deswegen finde ich die idee wie sie so einen zentralen park gemacht haben mit einer datei eigentlich viel eleganter weil wie du gesagt hast du bist unabhängig.
Vorher geplant werden also es.
Genau das muss halt vorher geplant werden.
Ist halt schwieriger zu planen so kannst du halt irgendwie ein mc berufen und dann.
Auch nicht diese diese die einfach nur jo als pushen kirchen schickt.
Ja und was es hilft.
Rein theoretisch also wenn man vorher mit bestimmten personen abgesprochen hat das jetzt was passieren soll kann man halt an die gruppe einfach nur ein josh schicken,
und dann können die quasi den zeitpunkt wann jetzt losgegangen werden soll oder.
Ja gut aber du kannst ja nicht dynamisch reagieren weil wir müssen ja alle schon vorher irgendwie was verstanden haben und so aber wenn du da irgendwie so 'ne app hättest und dann kannst du die leute auch automatisch und
aufteilen je nach geo position und dann wie ihr geht alle nach links hier geht alle nach rechts er macht jetzt hier so ein tunnel frei.
Mein ziel es geht in appstore.
Warum nicht ist der radio.
Ne es geht eher so ja.
Die koordination des protestes apple hat ja sogar in hongkong und wie die app zugelassen wieder und china richtig auf wäre auf jeden fall mal interessant das auszuprobieren.
Der revolution.
Ja also ich meine solche solche audio es gab da schon verschiedene projekte und fand,
mehrere auch ganz interessant also was was ich hier so naheliegende sachen so 'ne audio nochmal das projekt die dann so ja erlebe eine höhere geschichte in deiner stadt und so also.
Na ist doch in berlin der klassiker glaube ich die mauer geschichte vom werde mal mauer geschichte oder zweite weltkrieg die verfolgung der juden ich glaube es gibt zu beiden 'ne höre geschichte oder eine hört hier in berlin.
Ja sowas gibt es so aber das halt irgendwie alles nicht,
weiß ich nicht ist alles nicht so nicht so real time genug ja aber wenn du sozusagen in so eine dynamische gruppe dich einklinken könntest mit so 'ner app und sagst ich nehme jetzt ich bin jetzt in diesem stadtteil ich bin's bereit,
an so einer geführten aktion teilzunehmen vorausgesetzt man hat das vertrauen das ist jetzt nicht peinlich illegal oder was weiß ich wird ja es muss jetzt nicht immer gleich aus besetzung sein oder so dass man,
sich was lustiges einfallen lässt einfach so so in diesem entertainment bereich sowie mit diesem,
verhalten irgendwelche lustigen aktionen machen auch so als also als nord so als gesellschaft zu nord also auf dem potsdamer platz so eine aktion meist eben zu bringen,
ja wo du ganz viele touristen und leute hast dir irgendwie zugucken und die leute wissen selber auch gar nicht was sie gleich tun werden,
was ja auch zu einer unglaublichen lustlosigkeit führt ja also,
haben sie auch alle total beendet bei diesem petra explodiert das jetzt gerade so albern kram machen weil das ja selber in dem moment noch gar nicht gewusst haben was jetzt gleich passieren wird also war nur wieso generell darauf eingestellt muss,
man kann den links jetzt zu dem,
ich finde da sollte man experimentiert wird mit audio,
experiment.
Während du denn während du den link suchst dass wir hatten ja gerade ganz ganz kurz das thema hongkong angeschnitten und das apple anscheinend eher zumindest die map freigegeben hat,
hat,
macht sich gerade so ein bisschen feinde weil die sich wohl
gezwungen gesehen haben aktiv gegen die demonstranten zu stellen weil irgendwie es waren turnier irgendwie in china oder hongkong ein riesengroßes wurde weltweit gestreamt und einer der teilnehmer hat wohl
sich positiv gegenüber den demonstranten geäußert und daraufhin hat irgendwie fünf prozent stock verloren und direkt reaktion,
ja der wird disqualifiziert und ein jahr gesperrt und sein preisgeld muss er abgeben und pipapo,
das war ganz interessant.
Mir ist immer so wenn die politik auf die,
so wie auch die amis tobi gesagt haben sie müssen alle geschäftsbeziehung zu venezuela einstellen das kann ganz venezuela keine produkte mehr nutzen,
stellt euch mal vor demnächst irgendwann zum beispiel zum präsidenten was zurzeit auch der aktuelle sein könnte
streiten sich mit dem deutschen weil keine ahnung wie gas aus russland oder was auch immer für ein scheiß und dann sagen die ja ihr dürft keine geschäftsbeziehung mehr mit,
ist ja muss ja nicht deutschland sein mit folgendem land haben und dann schwupp gehen alle telefone nicht mehr also die zukunft ist spannend.
Wenn man das hast du jetzt auch ohne app stores schuld ne iran boykott et cetera das ist ja im prinzip genau dieselben verpflichtung aber es ist halt im in digitalen dann gleich viel krasser ne weil du verlierst halt dann im zweifelsfall wirklich.
Na wenn's dann tan gehen deine geräte plötzlich nicht mehr der das auch ja.
Ja und dein geld oder was auch immer also der manni flow ist weg software nicht mehr leute alle entlassen das ist totaler hat.
Die schönste desktop i die man sich für geld kaufen kann da einfach nur 'ne tatsache.
Achso das das ist schon die schönste diskutieren wer sich kaufen kann.
Na ja das kann ich schon mal werden oder.
Es kann naja sagen wir mal so,
man könnte sich ja diese szenarien auch schon vorher vorstellen aber ich dachte mir so okay wann ist der punkt gekommen und mit trump ist halt so dass der sie alles zur und zeit zieht,
ja also damit also so groß ist da die abhängigkeit auch nicht als dass man das nicht auch wieder alles ressourcen kann genau solche ereignisse werden natürlich jetzt auch dazu führen
das entsprechende abnahme prozesse auch eingeleitet werden obwohl sie sehr viel mehr davon gehabt hätten wenn sie einfach nochmal ein paar jahre die füße still gehalten
und es nie wirklich zum einsatz bringen sondern eigentlich immer nur so als droht szenario im raum.
Was dazu passt heute so die nachricht dass die bundeswehr sich ein spezielles android von samsung entwickeln.
Also in korea.
Das ist das südkorea.
Ja also ist eine sache mit der mit der mit der revolution hängt von netz ab.
Ähm gut bevor wir vielleicht auch das banken thema kommen,
wollte ich.
Vorher einmal blutdruck messen und danach bitte.
Mir ging 's super letztes mal ich weiß gar nicht was ihr habt ich könnte mich richtig.
Manchmal wünsche ich mir so ein live tracker für teams herzfrequenz hier auf dem auf dem meter eben auf dem.
Kann das alles nachschlagen ich habe das alles auf meiner uhr.
Kann dann kann dann pott lauf auch andere tracks außer audio also so puls temperatur das andere daten mit so vermitteln oder muss immer auto sein.
Ja das wird einfach in die potter simple das köpfchen für podcast mit eingeführt und dann gibt's halt die spur für herzfrequenz für tim aber nur bitte.
Ja
Kann man dann objektiv auch nochmal beurteilen.
Ich kann ich kann nachschauen wenn du wenn du wenn jemand in time code raussucht da haben wir eine stunde ist kapitel irgendwie müssen wir noch.
Also das war 's heute zu hören war da hat sie bestimmt kein normalen puls.
Oder um es mit dem.
Um auch ich meine ja wir wissen ja alle wie es ist wenn wir jetzt gleich auf das thema kommen ihr wollt.
Oder ob es mit den worten von nikolas zu sagen ja wenn man von vornherein weißt das thema in die decke gehen wird,
dann merkt man das richtig in seine stimme schon am anfang hat er gesagt.
Das ist immer so gut kennt die leute mich besser als ich mich selber kenne,
tja na dann werden wir noch bei dem thema wenn ihr das schon so spannend findet,
was habt ihr denn so für erfahrungen gesammelt mit den banken in der letzten woche habt ihr nicht macht er doch bestimmt auch online kram.
Ja bis auf die dkb geht's jetzt eigentlich.
Für mich hat sich irgendwie nichts geändert ich weiß das.
Du machst aber keinen hast keine,
was soll denn alles über,
das war das falsch was hättest du nicht sagen dürfen.
Ich hab nicht so viel überweisung das ist alles noch semi händisch machen kann ich habe keine ich habe keine app an meiner meine bankkonten geldverkehr oder so weiter.
Du würdest auch online.
Ja also im prinzip das und da habe ich keine änderungen festgestellt,
ne
Also ich bin dabei unter anderem bei figur und da muss ich jetzt aber nicht überweisung mache krieg ich nochmal einen code per sms gesendet das war vorher nicht.
Bei überweisung.
Zusätzlich zu einer tan,
ja okay.
Es gab keine tante meiner überweisung.
Das würde mich jetzt auch wundern dennis,
wann hast du das letzte mal ein.
So vor dem text was erzählt er meint die machen das jetzt so das heißt dann lass es vorher nicht so gemacht haben.
Oder das ist jetzt nur verpflichtend ist weil es vorher noch andere möglichkeiten gibt.
Feuer freiwillig meinst du.
Besseren vorher überwiesen musstest du nie was eingeben.
Vorher beim werde ich mich eingeloggt habe habe ich so einen code bekommen jetzt muss ich es pro ja ich glaube das ist der unterschied jetzt kriegt pro überweisung kriege ich so einen code,
wenn wir jetzt aber auch wenn ihr mal hier verunsichert ich bin.
Ey du verunsichert mich auch dass man nicht für eine überweisungen tan eingeben muss also dass man das meistens nicht muss wenn man von dem eigenen konto auf ein anderes eigenes konto wie tirol auf tagesgeld.
Die haben das über ihre app gemacht.
Ich meine jetzt schon web die app ist irgendwie die ganze vergessen auf empfohlen da hast du ein dreißig kilometer langes passwort,
tipps das da stundenlang ab damit das ding offenes die app auf dem phone und der rest sollten wir dann irgendwie mit dem da irgendwie und so weiter äh erledigen,
dann aber nach zwei wochen meint die app das passwort ist jetzt mal abgelaufen du musst jetzt nochmal neu eingeben,
alter haben sie einen knall gebe ich jedes mal irgendwie so mega langes passwort da ein und jetzt sollen die mir nicht erzählen soll ein kurzes nehmen dafür.
Ich habe auf twitter mal drum gebeten dass wir die leute mal so ein bisschen so ihre erfahrungen schicken sollen und ich habe ein paar ganz lustige sachen bekomme ich würde mal ein paar davon vorlesen,
unter anderem zu dieser problematik genau dort der sommer berichtet so nutzer auswirkung habe ich das genannt thomas schreibt,
ich teile iris eure frustration rund um die zwei nachdem schon oft beklagten einrichtungs- konfigurationen wahnsinn sieht es bei mir aktuell so aus sechs,
klammern drei ausrufezeichen
sechs unterschiedliche p zwei apps auf dem handy installiert pro bank und pro konto darf man sich also jetzt merken pin die plastikkarte bin der obligatorischen kreditkarte pin für online-banking kennwort für mobile banking-app noch eine pin extra für mobile banking,
danke ihr macht also achtzehn bis dreißig elemente die bemerken muss bei einigen viel versuchen wird das konto gesperrt was mir natürlich passiert ist wenn man schnell mal das eine mit dem anderen konto.
Scheiße.
Ja so ist das ja ne besonders ärgerlich regelmäßige prüfung des kontostand es verlangt jedes mal die anwendung mit zwei faktor authentic action,
auch dann wenn man nun mal,
kurz schauen aber nichts überweisen möchte dabei steht in der p zwei explizit drin das starke authentizität für kontostand abfragen nicht verwendet werden soll,
das weiß ich ganz genau schreibt er aber die banken gehen hier eindeutig zu weit ja die ps die zwei sagt das vertrauliche daten wie das einsehen der details einer buchung eine zwei faktor identifizierung zwei erfordert
aber eben nicht die anmeldung selbst statt ihren online-auftritt so zu modifizieren das,
erst bei anzeige der brust details die identifizierung durchgeführt werden muss haben die banken den einfachsten weg genommen und es dem kunden lieber schwerer gemacht,
ergebnis man prüft sein konto einfach nicht mehr und onlineshopping
nur noch mit paypal daraus ergibt sich eine ganz neue gefahr konto abräumen mit klassischer lastschrift es leichter denn je kein mensch prüft mir regelmäßig seine konnten bevor es nicht autorisiert ist das auffallen sind die täter links in der karibik untergetaucht,
durchaus realistisches szenario früher als ich noch ein bisschen mehr so einen hänger war ist mir auch das eine oder andere.
Aber dieses lastschrift verfahren ist er ist auch war eigentlich schon immer scheiße und wird eigentlich im zeitalter von digital über beschissener eigentlich will ich doch jedes mal wenn einer irgendwas von meinem konto abziehen will soll auf meinem telefon ist
geling machen dann steht da hier da folgende person folgende dollars abziehen dann steht da jetzt oder no oder baby vielleicht oder kannte und dann sage ich ja alles klar,
wenn man das möchte wenn man.
Dafür wäre so eine getan dann auch sehr angemessen zumal ja auf banking ebene zwischen einer erstplatz lastschrift in einer folge lastschrift auch unterschieden wird,
da hast du ganz recht also das problem hätte nie so sein müssen kann natürlich sein die leute wollen dann irgendwie ja die miete und so weiter und sind dann so blöd das zuzulassen aber ich meine lieber da mal keine ahnung,
das ist halt auch das problem dass es oft dann wahrscheinlich mit leuten zu tun hast du überhaupt nicht wissen was phase ist naja,
weiteres problem was ich.
Eigentlich ein bisschen komisch weil banken waren wahrscheinlich auch eine der ersten firmen nach den versichern überhaupt computer eingesetzt haben oder also ich müsste das ja computer mäßig die vollprofis sein.
Und es sind immer noch die gleichen systeme die da laufen.
Ja wirklich,
so dann stellt sich das problem das eigene lösungen zunichte gemacht werden hier schreibt,
daniel meine erfahrung zu pilze zwei als selbstständige einzelunternehmer im softwareentwicklung umfeld versuche ich so wenig zeit wie möglich in bürotätigkeit zu stecken kontoauszüge holen rechnung als bezahlt markieren kunden erinnern et cetera überblick und so weiter,
meine bank hat vor einigen jahren ganz toll damit geworben dass ihr auch so auf am machen ich kontaktiere die also wegen authentizität et cetera pustekuchen,
doku nach einem jahr einfach nicht mehr online alleine ich mobile apps als ziel nun gut dann halt oldschool mit krebs hatte mir da wirklich was nettes zusammen gestrickt,
dann kam die umstellung für mich wird das ganze zurück in die steinzeit null automatisierung ist mehr möglich ein steuerberater netterweise einem,
csv ansonsten muss ich den prototyp wechseln und die datev als rechenzentrum einrichten lassen beides mit mehr kosten verbunden,
mehr sicherheit wenn das foto tan app auf dem gleichen devices liegt nein,
für mich wird das die ganze arbeit der lobby von der bank und der date na ich glaube die das ist glaub ich 'ne fehler name.
Das was hier lobbyist ich glaube sie haben sich einfach vollkommen verschätzt mit diesem ganzen sehr geil fand ich dann auch noch hier die problematik dass wenn leute auf reisen sind,
bitte auf weltreise schreibt teurer meine bank hat umgestellt ich kann das tanz verfahren nur per brief aktivieren das geht aber nicht da ich keine adresse habe,
die adresse kann ich nur per fax oder brief ändern zum beispiel auf die adresse bei der eltern lassen sehr unpraktisch wenn man nicht mehr in den achtzigern ist und noch am anderen ende der welt,
ich benutze die kreditkarte zum glück nur für kostenlose bargeld abheben verweise jetzt jede woche ein paar hundert euro von meinem eigentlichen konto auf die karte und hoffe dass sie immer gedeckt ist,
ja das auch geil also diese annahme man sei auch immer auf wie oft eine bestimmte art und weise verfügbar oder an seinem briefkasten,
überhaupt so dieses ganze briefkasten der.
Man aber zu sein rechtlich.
Ja dennis da es.
Ja sorry aber die banken müssen sich ja auch auf gewisse sachen verlassen können und es gibt nur mal.
Dann könnten sie aber auch flexibel sein und du kannst hinterlegen so hey sorry ich bin jetzt einfach mal nicht da alles was wichtig ist schickt 's halt hierhin und ich meine hallo e-mail.
Das da muss man sich ja selber kümmern über.
Es gab überhaupt gar kein es gab aber auch gar keinen zwang das talent verfahren zu ändern,
das schreibt diese psd zwei überhaupt nicht vor das haben die bloß alles immer im rahmen der großen endrunde wollten was es war so dinge ändern sich,
und manche banken haben halt sehr entschlossen,
alles was wir schon die ganze zeit immer durchbringen wollten auf einmal und bleiben.
Ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen es läuft so die banken die haben ja sowieso alles wir haben gar keine ahnung machen ja nicht selber dann kommen so 'ne consulting an die sehen oh da gibt's irgendwie neue verordnung da können wir richtig
geil scheiße viel geld verdienen und dann haben wir den banken alles aufgewacht und das alles sein muss und wichtig ist und haben den das alles schön verkauft und implementiert und deswegen,
auch in billig billig und schnell schnell für viel geld.
Ja aber sie haben ihre prozesse nicht durchdacht hier schreib.
Sie sind ja auch schon längst wieder weg.
Ja pass auf ihr schreibt mir jonas,
santander bank meine kreditkarte bei der santana bank verlangt wie zu erwarten eine zusätzliche identifizierung natürlich mit einer zusätzlichen app nachdem er sich im online-banking eingeloggt hat wird man aus sicherheitsgründen direkt nochmal ausgelaugt um sich erneut wieder einzuloggen.
Die zusätzliche santana app verlangt nach dem unkomplizierten scannen eines qr-codes noch nach einem code,
also italien werden uns diese zettel mit nummern wo die tanz vor ausgelaugt sind,
eine italien liste habe ich aber jedoch nie bekommen die abwehr weist du darauf dass man den support kontaktieren soll und einen alternativen start gut per sms anfordern können,
nach geschlagenen fünfundvierzig minuten warteschlange in der hotline bescheid von warteschleife musik mit einer sequenz lecker vor dreißig sekunden nimmt ein support mitarbeiter meine,
verlangt nach meinen daten und will mir innerhalb von vier werktagen eine italienische zukommen lassen auf den einwand dass eine sms doch schneller wäre und in der
ab als alternative registrierung methode vorgeschlagen wurde entgegnet er,
das war eine handynummer im system hinterlegt ist und für ihn einsehbar
diese jedoch nur für das very fight bei visa verfahren gültig sein meine sms an mich zu versenden bräuchte eine italien von mir um dieses erlebnis,
sei noch erwähnt dass die reguläre santander ab auf einem geretteten android wunderbar funktioniert,
will sicher ab hat jedoch ein rudi text schon fremdwort integrierten verweigert solange dienst bis der andre paket name des manager.
Das ist halt so ne das ist alles ein bisschen alles ein bisschen schwierig,
irgend 'ne bank hat dann komplett aufgehört überhaupt noch tanz zu,
lustig dass also manche sich ihren prozess komplett dings haben,
cool ist auch irgendwie die volks eisen raiffeisenbank altenburger land die haben dann irgendwie so ja suchen sie im app store nach der app,
oben irgendwie den tanja radtour zu haben nur heißt die dann halt aber anders die app und den link haben sie auch nicht dazu gepostet.
Und dann ist auch oft noch dann ist auch die firma die da angegeben wird als als gesagt vertreiben der app ist dann eben nicht auf die bank sondern irgend so ein party klischee boote die das halt programmiert hat und du findest du dann nicht.
Oder du traust dich dann einfach nicht.
Sowieso nicht zurecht.
Ja und vor allem wie er da auch noch hinweis ist so wenn ihr das dann auffällt dann bist ja richtig gut daran wenn du dann eine,
app unter dem namen den die bank auf ihrer webseite stehen hast sozusagen tatsächlich integrierst so dann.
Ich habe mich gerade mal bei video eingelegt um zu gucken was so phase ist gerade geht erst mal alles aber kommt gleich so eine warnung wegen mastercard probleme mein aber sie hätten die behoben aber ich bin doch jetzt meine karte kurz mal aktivieren und wieder aktivieren,
ich würde das überhaupt noch bei der karte ändert sich dadurch gar nicht sondern bei denen irgendwas warum machen die das dann nicht warum muss ich das machen.
Wahrscheinlich wegen irgendwelchen rechtlichen schritten oder so oder keine ahnung oder aktivität bei einem dienstleister auf den sie keinen direkten einfluss haben um den zu trägern.
Tschüss.
Schlimm schlimm schlimm alles.
Ja aber mach's wie sei wie peter den peter schreibt ich besitze berufsbedingt mehrere handys und kreditkarten ich reise auch zu viel,
meine bank,
konnte mir nicht sagen auf welche meiner jeweiligen handys in welchem land welcher zone zu welchem zeitpunkt zitaten zuschicken wollten sie erlauben genau eine telefonnummer wenn das telefon keine verbindung bekommt ist der handel ausgeschlossen,
da die lösung zu meinen bedürfnissen nicht passen habe ich,
alle in der eu registrierten kreditkarten kündigen müssen bei vielen onlinehändler kaufe ich einfach auf rechnung weitere online käufe funktionieren einwandfrei mit meinem neuen paypal guthaben konto da kann ich selber bestimmen über die so mit dem onlinehandel riskiert wird nämlich das guthaben
anstatt bank gebühren wechsel kurse kreditkarten gebühren kreditkarten transaktionskosten paypal transaktionskosten und händler zu bezahlen zahle ich jetzt maximal noch paypal und händler und hab dabei geld gespart am wochenende war ich dementsprechend ganz normal,
einkaufen und tanken gewesen hab dabei mit bargeld bezahlt,
seitdem ich mich über jeden eu bedingten cookie banner geärgert habe war ich in der eu nie so dankbar jetzt schon ich bin der fachmann architekt und gar nicht so technologie feindliche wie man sich denken würde die welt kann doch so einfach sein.
Aber das ist doch äh ich weiß nicht ob man das noch so sagen darf eine milchbrötchenrechnung
dass es für ihn nicht teuer wird stimmt ja so nicht weil wenn er jetzt paypal benutzt die paypal kosten werden auch über den händler also irgendwer zahlt paypal und am ende zahlt er das über den preis also das kommt schon hinten bei mir da an ja merkt 's noch nicht,
also so einfach ist es nicht.
Ich hab's absichtlich ja aber was hat diesen ganzen hessen mit den ganzen banken und.
Ne aber er meinte das benutzt einfach paypal und es kostet ihnen kostet die nichts das stimmt halt am ende nicht.
Das soll nicht gesagt das kostet nur noch paypal und händler aber nicht mehr alle anderen sachen die da noch aufgezählt hat.
Aber das zahlt er auch also.
Ist auf jeden fall so ein ding ich habe das auch schon getwittert pepper ist ja auf jeden fall gut bei weggekommen bei dieser ganzen nummer wald.
Ich wollte mich auch nicht wundern wenn ihr nicht nur dabei gut weil wegkommen sondern auch noch dahinter stecken also,
ja verschwörungstheorie wird jetzt nicht so hochschrauben aber da gibt es schon immer leute sich das angucken was da so an psd zwo kommt und sie denken sich dann ja es war voll der kack aber für uns ist eigentlich ganz gut und lehnt sich dann entspannt nach hinten.
Irgendjemand hat ja die leitlinien geschrieben die dann umgesetzt werden mussten von einem.
Genau es kommt so ein paar berichte aus so behalten jeans das war jetzt sozusagen nur so die nutzer perspektive.
Hallo ich arbeite am schalter einer kleinen bank,
wir haben sechs zwei stellen und etwa dreißig mitarbeiter total in teilzeit unser atmen hat noch nicht mal ein smartphone wenn wir ein problem mit der e v haben ruft er grundsätzlich erstmal beim rechenzentrum,
was ein anderer dienstleister ist über die zwei das ist ein paar namen einfach mal raus über zwei wurden wir mit einer e-mail informiert
der mehrwert den link zu einem artikel bundesweiten intranet sowas liest sich natürlich keiner durch,
die zeit hat keiner wer die umstellung erfolgte bei uns am mittwoch den elften neunten plötzlich rufen
riefen kunden an und reklamieren dass wir jeden pupsen getan brauchen ich glaube mich gleich über unsere homepage und meine homepage ging ein und konnte das problem nachvollziehen in so einer kleinen bank sind die wege kurz ich ging gleich zum vorstand und macht ihn darauf aufmerksam,
die antwort des bunkers da ist brüssel schuld dass die eu vorgaben und außerdem würde jeder kunde informiert die info erfolgte mittels eines,
unsere kunden finden noch nicht mal ihre kontoauszüge online postfach das ist auch echt schwierig teilweise aber solche pdfs lesen und verstehen bestimmt alle ja bis freitag den dreizehnten neunten hat sie hat sich auch in unserer bank herumgesprochen dass
nur alle neunzig tage eine tat nötig ist und es wurde umgestellt jetzt schon wie die schuld auf das rechenzentrum die hätte der die vorgaben.
Liebe leute so 'ne kleine bank sind müssen die seltener tannen machen.
Nein alle müssen nur nach drei monaten nach neunzig tagen also mit anderen worten,
zum stichpunkt stich zeitpunkt hätte keine bank,
jemals eine tan haben müssen sich alle noch drei monate zeit lassen können und dann mal abfragen und dann,
wieder drei monate nichts du musst ein nur vier mal im jahr getan abfragen.
Und wo wo soll das helfen alle drei monate gegen welchen konto claude der nach drei monaten immer noch nicht aufgefallen ist oder was.
Du
Ja lange schweigen das sagt alles weiß auch nicht oder.
Du kannst ja,
irgendwie ist immer noch runterschrauben aber wenn man das jetzt alles so einführt so und jetzt sich dann einfach diese karenz zeit einfach auch komplett zerstört
es ist ja nicht so das jetzt alles brennt und oh gott wir müssen jetzt überall mal ganz schnell tanz abfragen.
Ja aber das war mit der dsv.
G
Dsgvo war das ja auch so alle lesen sich nichts durch und klatschen alles damit voll obwohl 's gar nicht überall notwendig gewesen wäre das immer das gleiche.
Ja nicht alles was hinkt ein vergleich.
Das passt schon sehr gut.
Na gut ich meine da war ja auch zwei jahre zeit.
Ja und auch haben alles mit irgend so einem so meldung voll geballert sie dürfen jetzt nicht weil deswegen und deswegen und deswegen und übertreiben es halt gleich total dann dauert eine weile bis ich das irgendwie zettel.
Weil man den halt mit hohen strafen gedroht haben und dann macht man lieber.
Sorry.
Ja
So es wird noch schlimmer david schreibt,
kurz zu mir ich bin bei einer it-beratung wir waren eine umsetzung bei mehreren banken beteiligt ich selbst bei zwei größeren häusern diskutiere viele der themen die ihr gestreift hat sein ende zwanzig sechzehn,
mitte zwanzig siebzehn die banken haben sich sicherlich nicht mit rum bekleckert und der regulatorischen auch nicht die ps die zwei regelt nur zahlungsverkehrs konnten also hir o alles andere tagesgeld depo kreditkarten sind ungeregelten das macht die situation komplexer als vorher alles gleich ungeregelten.
Alles gleich ungeregelten.
Ja zugriff erhalten erstmal nur zertifizierte dritt anbieter,
das zertifikat ist die europäische erweiterung von,
alle anderen anbieter und kunden werden erst einmal ausgespart beziehungsweise nicht von der psd zwei geregelt die abi für dritt anbieter muss qualitativ,
qualitativ mit dem besten zugang für kunden mithalten können für banken ist es also,
geschrieben besser ja aufwendige schnittstellen nicht habe zu ihr einzusetzen,
tipp am rande eine bank hat darauf hingewiesen dass ihre mobile ab umsätze speichert und somit eigentlich hundert prozent verfügbarkeit hat die eva hat festgestellt die gleiche verfügbarkeit müsste dann also auch die ab ja,
hundert prozent die neunzig tage ausnahme für die customer aus indikation,
gilt nur für umsätze der letzten drei monate sobald sensible daten angezeigt werden sollen muss die sc nachgeholt werden das ist aber sowohl in der umsetzung als auch in der kundenkommunikation für komplexer als kunden immer,
als kunden immer beim look in tanz eingeben,
eine ganz interessante ausnahme hat jetzt auch noch nicht so geschnallt also neunzig tage ausnahme ist sozusagen nur für umsätze die letzten drei monate.
Was sowieso sehr verbreitet ist wenn du jetzt das erste mal online-banking eingerichtet bei einer bank dann bekommst du ja auch oft auch nur die letzten drei monate also bei so einer typischen sparkasse.
Ich glaube bei der postbank gibt's auch noch letzten neunzig tage mehr kriegst du da gar nicht.
Ja das war das war schon öfter so der mag diese zeitlimit auch irgendwie herkommt wo auch immer.
Hör ich das zwischen den zeilen gerade richtig dass es eigentlich auch gar nicht um den endkunden geht sondern noch um andere partys die da auf die kontos zugreifen und da die daten abfragen.
Na das ist ja der sinn der ganzen ps die zwei ist ja quasi so eine so eine zweite anbieter schicht zu dienstleister den markt zu öffnen darum geht's ja eigentlich.
Na aber dienstleister für wen nicht für mich oder.
Na ja so was wie sofort und so weiter und im prinzip stellen sie sich so eine welt vor wo,
du nicht mehr selber auf dein konto zugreift sondern wird ein online dienst greift für dich auf die konten und dann auf mehrere konnten zu und was diese ganzen wir machen deine,
nein deine steuern wir lesen deine rechnung und bezahlen sie vielleicht auch,
also ganze neue fintech wahnsinn der da,
angelaufen kommen teilweise macht es auch sinn wenn du so eine online steuer software hast,
und nicht wie ich so 'ne app irgendwie auf dem rechner das alles online machst dann willst du das ja auch mit deinen kunden mit deinen kunden verbinden willst ja dass jede buchung da reinkommt so mache ich das ja im prinzip ja auch nur halt,
so wenn es online hast möchte natürlich sagen ja hier habe ich dann kommt ob ich dann konnte dann konto das versucht diese psd zwei zu regeln das dieser zugang a,
gewährt werden muss von den banken du darfst das nicht verhindern und im idealfall gibt's dafür auch ein standard.
Das funktioniert aber alles noch nicht so richtig wenn wir gleich noch sehen,
hier noch die information der tanz dynamisch mit der transaktion verknüpft werden müssen fallen,
sowohl getan als auch op also was wir so gerne mögen ne,
oder lang laufende app tons aus für neunzig tage kein zertifizierten dritten eins ausgestellt,
muss halt gegebenenfalls eine toms rausgibt nochmal nach neunzig tagen wieder erneuern ja,
tada die bafin hat ganz andere zugriff wege,
batch und xxl oder csv und manchmal auch excel und die berlin grob die diese standard da gemacht hat regelt erstmal nur das regulatorisches sie oben für chirurg konnten und das problem mit namen etcetera ist das am anderen ende,
nicht notwendigerweise du sondern der satz dieser satz dieser kann dieser satz kein satz,
ja und auch kreditkarten-zahlungen brauchen demnächst diese nummer auswendig die wurde nur ausgesetzt weil es,
probleme bei diversen händlern und zahlungsabwicklung gab und bei den onlinehandel,
abwürgen wollte da hatte ich eine letzte sendung berichtet das ausgerechnet da das soll sozusagen,
nicht ist soll aber alles noch viel besser wird.
Fehlt mir jetzt,
nochmal,
nochmal nachschlagen auf jeden fall ist es da im hintergrund irgendwie einiges im argen und sind teilweise ganz schön am kämpfen das irgendwie hin.
Weißt du wie lange die übergangsfristen.
Von von was auf was jetzt.
Von bekanntgeben der neuen leitlinien bis schultag jetzt muss alles eingesetzt werden.
Wie ich aus dieser mail herausgehört habe ging das zum ende sechzehn los also er meinte er.
Aber war schon abzusehen dass es also.
Seit vier jahre.
Okay gut für vier jahre hätte ich die bessere usability erwartet.
Wo wir hätten sicherlich so einiges aber die die kern ding das kern ding worüber worüber ich mich ja auch beklauen wir uns alle ja letztes mal beklagt haben ist ja einfach dieses,
man hat,
einfach bist jetzt den leuten so aufgedrückt und keiner denkt hier wirklich an die kunden dann geht's jetzt sozusagen nur dadrum dass irgendwie alle ihre komischen app modelle durchkriegen und und keiner hat das in der letzten konsequenz,
durchdacht so diese ganzen verkettung und ich habe mich ja auch selber irgendwie aus meinem,
eignen konnte ich hatte dann irgendwie war das konsole bank ja genau ich mein neues telefon installiert,
zieht dann quasi alle apps um jetzt kann aber eine app ja feststellen dass sie nicht mehr auf demselben physikalischen telefon ist wie vorher,
woraufhin die app meinte ja ist ein neues telefon muss mich erstmal wieder neu automatisieren.
Das ist aber wichtig und richtig weil das liegt an dieser glaube die kandidaten alter reinschieben aber nicht wieder rausholen das macht schon sinn,
deswegen ist das auch ein backup nicht dabei.
Dann macht es gerne sinn so wo wo muss ich dann diese diese app wieder automatisieren im online-banking.
Die postbank.
Da lege ich mich dann ein lob ich mich dann ein und was brauche ich dann dafür brauche ich die tan.
Keine tannen dafür.
Der app die gerade gesagt hat ich soll mich da einloggen ja aber nicht bereit ist meine tante dafür zu geben mich da einzuloggen,
das heißt ich war komplett lockt out nur weil ich auf ein neues telefon gezogen bin.
Also das alte ging das alte telefon ging nicht mehr.
Seit telefon habe ich platt gemacht mein gott ich rufe doch nicht alle meine apps innerhalb der ersten zehn minuten auch um zu gucken ob.
Und selbst wenn man verliert ja auch mal sein telefon und holt sich dann ein neues und dann hast du alter.
Ja es hat auch kaputt sein können was auch immer so und dann und dann kannst du dich nicht einloggen aber es erst was das ding sagt ist ja lockt dich erstmal ein.
Das war jetzt nur noch die kirsche gewesen wenn sich das andere automatisch die registriert und sagt nee ich kann nicht mehr weil du hast dich ja auf einem.
Der nicht testen.
Ich habe in den letzten zwei wochen habe ich jetzt schon zwei kunden gekündigt dritte kündigung schreiben die gerade drucker ich.
Du wirst aber scheitert kack banken.
Ja genau ich gehe jetzt wirklich ich habe so keinen bock mehr auf diesen scheißdreck,
das ist einfach alles das macht mich also alles total wahnsinnig,
natürlich hat sich dann auch so ein bisschen das problem dass das dann so ein bisschen zu wenig banken das dann sozusagen so ein bisschen unterversorgt war also.
Mit banken dort banken an der wand.
Ja ich muss ich muss halt bestimmte dinge auseinanderhalten können und ich hatte mich auch letzte mal beklagt dass,
unter anderem ist auch einfach so unfassbar kompliziert und schwierig ist unterkunft,
ja wir hatten das ja kurz ja auch diskutiert damit der nett bank die sagt hol drei unter kunden kein problem da muss er für jedes ding dann nochmal ein formular hinschicken und so weiter und überhaupt der ganze,
plätze bekloppte vorgang und jetzt rose im online-banking und jetzt im support an jetzt loggen sie sich ein da haben wir diese app und jene app und dann haben wir noch eine app und irgendwann weißt du echt vorne und hinten nicht mehr wo du überhaupt noch,
hin soll's und mit wem ihr reden willst und dann hängst du stundenlang in irgendwelchen hotlines dann könnt ihr da auch nicht helfen und kurz bevor sie dann doch vielleicht helfen können reißen die verbindung ab dann rufst du nochmal und jetzt nochmal drei stunden hotline und bist einfach
bekloppten alles was du willst es denn um dein geld geben damit sie damit irgendwie arbeiten können so und dann.
In der letzten sendung haben dann leute mehrfach auf ein,
startup hingewiesen wo ich mir dachte es wäre ja kenne ich schon irgendwie schon mal mit rumgequält weiß ich nicht ob ich das jetzt haben muss bis man dann danach aufgefallen ist dass ich das verwechselt habe weil ich dachte die ganze zeit sie reden von boom,
das war so eine ist auch immer noch so eine kreditkarte company mit der da halt mal ebenso apple pay machen kannst das habe ich vor vier jahren benutzt um in england schon mal mit apple pay aber bezahlen zu können,
und,
weil da war es ja schon freigeschaltet aber in deutschland noch nicht und da muss ich dann halt nur unter der adresse wo ich da gewohnt habe kurz irgendwie einmal das einrichten und fertig da hatte ich irgendwie apple pay und dann konnte ich da irgendwie geld einzahlen in dieses konto und das halt dann quasi digital,
aber das,
stellt sich raus von bund war überhaupt nicht die rede sein worauf leute mich darauf hingewiesen haben ist der das schon mal gehört,
b könnte man auch sagen also.
Dass ich mich mal irgendwo entgegengekommen.
Und das ist so ein fettig aus holland,
und ich so in meiner verzweiflung so okay jetzt halt auch nochmal an weil irgendwie.
Das kann ja nur besser werden.
Na ja gut ich war auch schon bei in sechsundzwanzig.
Sorry.
Da ist so das mit dem kann ja nur besser werden auch so eine sache also ich hätte jetzt nie irgendwelche katastrophe mit sechsundzwanzig ist auch voll davon aber macht immer seine eigene erfahrung,
aber auch das war so von der app her und so weiter alles so ein bisschen so,
alles tausendmal bestätigen und pipapo und dann richtig face eine dann geht es nur um die dreißig tage und da muss ich wieder einrichten also die ist auch gelungen ein permanent irgendwie zu nerven
und die sind auch in den ganzen psd zwei umstellung wohl auch diejenigen wo streckenweise überhaupt nichts funktioniert hat und wo ich da braucht.
Ein sechsundzwanzig oder bank ok.
Sechsundzwanzig punkte erstmal aus,
na ja auf jeden fall äh dachte ich mir so okay was kann schon passieren schaust es dir halt mal an,
und die kommen irgendwie ganz hipp rüber da wird man ja auch schon mal.
Bank of okay.
Ja ja aber ums gleich mal vorweg zunehmen also ich bin jetzt weiter von entfernt,
das jetzt hier zu empfehlen aber das war ehrlich gesagt,
prozedur nicht in meinem leben je erlebt habe also es war wirklich bemerkenswert da haben sich leute gedanken,
du kannst ja jetzt irgendwie zwei verschiedene oder drei ist glaube ich drei verschiedene modi wie du da,
teilnehmen kannst es gibt quasi so ein privates konto es gibt geschäftskunden und es gibt da noch so eine travel card was,
im wesentlichen einfach nur so du hast da irgendwie eine kreditkarte und das so wie so geld drauf und dann kannst du das ausgeben damit irgendwie unterwegs eine kreditkarte hast da verdienen die quasi an diesen kreditkarten umsatz und du hast irgendwie apple pen alles ist gut,
du willst ja eigentlich auch ein richtiges konto mit e-mail haben und so,
dachte ich mir so okay alles klar gucke ich erstmal hier manchmal dieses privat konto so nicht ganz billig und wie privat konto kost irgendwie acht euro geschäft konnte mit zehn euro im monat also das ist schon teurer als viele andere sachen die ich gesehen habe,
aber so von den features her fand ich das irgendwie mal alles ganz interessant weil du kriegst da nämlich einfach mal so.
Fünfundzwanzig unter konnten wenn du möchtest oh vertrag,
und da wurde ich dann irgendwie da wurde ich dann irgendwie aufmerksam und dachte mir so okay,
ich schaue ich mal wie das so ist diese app runter saß ja hier hallo ich will konto,
ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht an jeden einzelnen schritt aber im wesentlichen war es so deine telefonnummer dann halt das übliche telefonnummer bestätigung s hin und her dann,
so ja was hättest du gerne ja hier nochmal premium konto also das privat konto,
so und dann muss er dann irgendwie erstmal deine identitäten aufweisen da war ich jetzt wieder so auf einiges eingestellt von post-ideen bis irgendwie jetzt telefoniert wieder in so einem hansel mit seinem schmutzigen unterhalb der irgendwo in seiner kreuzberger wohnung sitzt und für
den halben mindestlohn irgendwelche leute authentizität wo man eine halbe stunde wieso sein sein sein personalausweis in die kamera wackeln muss und so.
Post event hört irgendwas eingestellt.
Wird eingestellt das ist glaube ich.
Ist noch was anderes.
Ja ja naja naja die app so ja wo bist du ja deutschland ja dann hier folgende ausweise sind und wie gültig,
okay personalausweis nämlich so okay,
leg mal hin mach mal ein foto von der vorderseite kamera geht an und so kleiner rahmen klickt foto gemacht kann man das lesen ja,
jetzt mal die rückseite legt wieder foto gemacht also alles geführt von der app oder so kann man das lesen ja,
okay jetzt halt mal kurz irgendwie dein gesicht in die kamera so vor der kamera angeschaltet so kurz reingeguckt so jetzt kommt mal nach links nach links geguckt,
ja so jetzt sag mal die drei zahlen die hier auf dem bildschirm sind,
überhaupt erst geschnallt was hier gerade abgeht dass er mich irgendwie gerade so rekorde also ja eins fünfzehn dreiundzwanzig ja danke momentchen warten also dreißig sekunden später ja alles prima,
hier ist ein konto hier ist eine iban hier ist eine kreditkartennummer hier ist ein apple p.
Und hier sind deine fünfundzwanzig anderen konnten ding ding ding ding.
Ne die musst du die kannst du dir dann selber dazu klicken aber die hätte ich ab dem moment sozusagen sofort einrichten,
was und wie ivan genommen geld hin überwiesen.
Euro.
Bilder ja so pling irgendwie halbe stunde später weil über die kohle irgendwie da,
und,
das war einfach das also da war ich wirklich so ein bisschen sonne und vor allem die app benutzt sich ordentlich ist,
keine irgendwie ist so ja okay muss man sich irgendwie drei mal angucken bis man die logik komplett verstanden hat
insbesondere wie man inzwischen mehrere content und her schaltet dann kannst du sagen so jetzt brauche ich aber nochmal ein separates unter konto sagte plus,
ja wie soll es denn heißen ja das und das zack return ja hier ist eine iban und fertig fucking konto ohne scheiß,
und stress und irgendwie auch alles gleich so dabei.
Aber ich denke schon so ein bisschen so okay dann habe ich das ganze nochmal mit dem geschäft konto gemacht weil er hat ja auch grad noch so bedarf,
zehn euro leider lassen paar features dabei die man nicht so brauchen ist auch teurer und dann kosten irgendwie auch überweisung was und so egal braucht dich,
und somit unter konto das das war irgendwie so 'ne ansage weil es immer so das hauptproblem willst muss irgendwie diversifizieren mit mit mit mit konnten und und vor allem also es wird ja noch es wird ja noch,
jetzt genau was ist für mich noch wichtig na dass die scheiße dass sie scheiße in manni manni läuft das ist für mich wichtig und dann wurde es wirklich richtig magisch,
ist da deine iban rein die du jetzt gerade eben bekommen hast,
was getan und dann so wenn jemand konto oder musst du jetzt irgendwie mal bestätigen bling kommt irgendwie die app hoch und so hallo,
manni manni mit liken und so weiter diese app von irgendwie michael hallo möchte gerne auf dein konto zugreifen ist das okay so oder so ja ja ist fertig,
ping läuft irgendwie überweisen abholen alles keine tan dramen geht einfach,
weil ihn ab hier haben und nicht so ein a b i was so im dritten keller hinter der fünften tür wo ein schild drauf steht vor sich bisher leopard rumliegt sondern so.
Doch das video von.
Welches video von vorhin achso ja das können wir das können wir gleich das was kann man da machen dass wir das noch kurz zu ende bringen diese,
experience war auf jeden fall super also keine ahnung ob die irgendwie kleine kätzchen von der von der klippe stoßen und irgendwie andere böse sachen machen und so,
ist irgendwie auf jeden fall war ich erstmal so ein bisschen schockiert wie seit ich das funktioniert hat und was das für so einen sein ab prozess war und was hast du auch für so ein onboarding prozess ist das schon irgendwie echt,
ja ja ein schatz wird dann auch angemerkt genau man kriegt 'ne niederländische iban,
womit du dann öfter auch mal so das problem hast dass dann also andere konnten dann so,
locker drinhaben mit auslands überweisung und so weiter ich auch sagen muss leute.
Europa.
Ja als einheitlicher euro bank raum das ja es darf nicht diskriminiert werden gegenüber anderen konnten und trotzdem gibt es immer noch so komische blogger,
also ich wollte irgendwie von meinem privat konto überweisen ja das ist aber eine auslands überweisung die muss ja erstmal freischalten so ja dann schaltet doch frei du dumme nuss.
Du brauchst erstmal.
Dachte ich ja auch nein das können sie nur telefonisch bei uns machen sie erreichen uns zu bürozeiten von tralala echt wirklich leute was wollt ihr mir.
Und lass mich raten weil gerade freitagabend.
Ja klar war gerade irgendwie dritter oktober und irgendwie feiertag und.
Ja gut aber dann geht's am nächsten tag wieder mal so am freitag muss man erstmal bis montag warten dann.
Die sind auf jeden fall die nächsten.
Ach so das ist das was gerade im drucker.
Ne das ist das ist so der potenzielle viele haben mich noch nicht ganz ganz entschieden ob ich die schon auch noch kicker,
warte jetzt erstmal ab wie dieser ganze wahnsinn sich so entwickelt aber das das könnte könnte ganz interessant sein.
Ja erzähl vor allem mal von einem business konto das würde mich auch interessieren dann also wenn ich hier schon sehen automatisch die umsatzsteuer zurückbringen.
Ja gut das ist natürlich so ein feature was ich nicht brauche.
Du vielleicht nicht ich schon.
Weiß ja was ich ein umsatzsteuer zu zahlen hab und ich zahle das ja auch.
Ne das hat er damit nichts zu tun aber es ist halt einfach geil diese ordentliche trennung in konnten zu haben.
Ja unter kontrolle aber das muss ja nicht automatisch machen lassen.
Natürlich hallo das ist aber sehr geil.
Ja aber woher woher soll dein konto das wissen was was da oben was da der umsatzsteuer anteil das wissen die leute das können die nicht wissen.
Reicht der pike mal daumen.
Dann sollen sie mir alles mit neunzehn prozent runterziehen ist mir auch egal.
Ja gut wenn du auf der basis arbeiten möchtest kannst du das ja gerne machen also.
Also ich muss also ich mache das halt auch gerade in dem ich mir das auf andere konnten nicht nicht mehr umsatzsteuer mehrwertsteuern ich umsatzsteuer doch hier genau umsatzsteuer mach ich auf ein anderes konto wo ich nämlich wieder die tannen braucht,
für jedes mal ab geld ab.
Wenn man da zu viel geld hat muss man geld bezahlen ja.
Beeilen konnten so.
Das ist ja derzeit dass.
Gar nicht bestätigen dass es nicht so.
Also über hundert bei fast allen.
Was kannst du bestätigen das was nicht so ist.
Das macht mich vereinbaren geld dafür zeit wenn man da so viel geld da rumliegen.
Ja aber auch zu kostenlosen privatkunden.
Kein song contest.
Ne auch bei privat konnten das teilweise es ist grade ganz viele stellen das um also habt ihr habt eine bank nachrichten vielleicht mal im blick.
Mit neuen mit neuen verträgen ist es dann anders weil die kriegen halt einfach keine das ganze.
Geld mehr für ihr geld wegen der zinsen die bei null.
Die müssen teilweise geld dafür bezahlen dass sie so viel geld haben und das negative zinsen etcetera das kein spaß deswegen geht ja jetzt auch alles so auf transaktionen gebühren und so weiter die versuchen wir halt die ganze zeit solche banken,
ich bin froh dass ich noch so einen alten bank vertrag habe wo ich halt tatsächlich transaktionskosten frei bin,
aber das ist halt nicht so ohne weiteres zu bekommen du kriegst halt nur für relativ hohe monats gebühren christopher so konnten heutzutage wo du dann vielleicht so fünfhundert oder tausend je nachdem muss man dann verhandeln
nach volumen transaktion frei hast oder beziehungsweise inklusive hast und danach kommt dann halt so die die kosten bei bunker ist es halt so dass du dann eben,
bei dem geschäft konto,
falls sondern halt zehn cent für gesendet ist und empfang ist es lohnt sich also jetzt wirklich nur für konnten wo du eben entweder nicht so viele transaktionen hast dass es dir ein bisschen egal sein kann,
oder die transaktionen sich ohnehin in einem geld bereich bewegen wo sich das nicht so richtig kratzt ne,
und dementsprechend ist es schwierig,
ganze sicher wann man eigentlich jetzt wirklich dieses geschäft konto für dich jetzt braucht,
natürlich so wenn du das dann,
als privat angibst und du machst dann trotzdem wieder selbstständigen business dann kannst du natürlich auch schnell dein konto wieder gesperrt bekommen und dann erfährst du quasi dann.
Ja das machen ja viele irgendwie nicht dass sie ihr selbstständig sein halt über ein privates konto ab frühstücken und sind dann immer ganz.
Machen viele nicht oder machen.
Ne viele haben ihr privat konto was sie als äh.
Ja klar weil das natürlich auch fließenden übergang des von privat zu selbstständig.
Ja aber ich meine die bank kannst dir kündigen das.
Ja theoretisch also wenn der vertrag das ausgeschlossen hat so das tun tun sie dann halt oft heute auch genau das ist halt das das ding ne.
Ist das nicht auch ein problem wenn ihr den privatkunden einfacher gezündet wird.
Das ist für dich auf jeden fall ein problem für die blanken interessiert das nicht weil.
Ne für die banken nicht aber wenn du wenn du dein privat konto als firmen freelancer konto selbstständigen konto mit nutzen.
Weiß ich ehrlich nicht.
Du wirklich komplett gewendet sondern die sperren da nur die summe die du schuldig bist also wenn du irgendwo was schuldig bislang nicht zahlen konntest und sie müssen also die können nicht deine mieten das geld für die miete sperren und so sagen das geht nicht.
Und das erklärt dann die bank welche.
Irgendwie so ja.
Also das weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich hatte auch mal dass das finanzamt da so ein bisschen was nicht bezahlt habe und dann.
Ja die sind da schnell.
Ja genau dann,
spende dein konto mit der summe aber die normalen sachen die gehen schon du kannst noch nichts mehr abheben aber deine miete kann wird glaube ich bezahlt,
also es ist nicht so ganz hardcore.
Ich finde es einfach nicht sauber wenn du freelancer oder gestellt du bist halt ein geschäft treibende also du willst es halt nicht so fließend haben dass du deine privaten ausgaben zusammen was mit deinem geschäftsauto haben.
Ja oder wenn halt so selbstständig bist und und wirklich nur drei rechnungen im jahr schreibst dafür irgendwie ein konto zu öffnen das nicht so macht ja mehr arbeit als als als.
Ja vielleicht ich würde immer vom betrag auch abhängig machen weil wenn die banken noch mal explizit schreiben hey das ist ein privates konto und wenn ich sag mal so wenn du unter zehn kameras ist es wahrscheinlich egal,
aber ich glaube dass da auch eine grenze gibt wo sie dann genauer hingucken und dann sagen so tschüss ist nicht.
Da hatte ich bisher glück glaube ich.
Das erste was ich gemacht habe damit ich da eine ordentliche trennung hab.
Ja aber ich lasse es früher selbstständig das war was es auch keine.
Finanzamt moderner schnickschnack.
Steuern zahlen.
Den ist das ja egal ob ich das über privat oder geschäft konto mache oder also.
Ja den ist das egal kannst du noch ja mehrere konnten sagen von welchem konto sie was abziehen sollten was schon ein bisschen geiles features ja egal dann möchtest du noch was zu banken und buchhaltung erzählen.
Ja ich hab die ganze zeit das,
befürchtung dass ich eine ganz wichtige app noch noch eine ganz wichtige mail vergessen habe aber solange können wir ja mal kurz in die kiste zwei zentrum schalten.
Na herr doktor brave solch eine kleine überweisung sein,
dann bauen sie mal schon mal auf ne ich habe gerade noch den rundfunk hier als erstes geld institut weltweit hat die enkel felder volks genossen bank ein home banking system entwickelt dass im computer fachkreisen als das sicherste in der branche gilt,
endlich können bankkunden die am computer ihre geld geschäfte erledigen hundertprozentig darauf vertrauen dass ihre persönlichen daten vor fremden zugriff geschützt sind,
die neue software saldo connect vier punkt x macht's möglich bei mir ist die tourist wolfgang mixen,
der die homepage in kunden betreut,
wo lagen denn bisher die risiken des online geld verkehrs ja,
sicherheitslücken bestand darin dass die protokolle p des elf und p
über netzwerke nicht ohne die moderatoren im standard vierundsechzig mit sieben bitcoin übertragen wurden das war besonders unseren älteren kunden von vornherein so,
verständlich gerade senioren neigen ja eher zum althergebrachte wie etwa der schiff regierung eines capis schlüsselpersonen über.
Und hier setzt unsere neue benutzer,
form was wird sich im zuge dieser neuentwicklung beim online-banking ändern nun in den ersten schritten etwa bei einer normalen überweisung ändert sich wenig gut wie bisher muss der kunde sein die netzwerk einrichten,
pop server konfigurieren und mit acht unterschiedlichen passwörter initialen vieren die container kennung eingeben die benutzer fix aktualisieren und den wert des öffentlichen.
Vierunddreißig zeichen paare aha in den präferenz ordner eintragen,
das klingt schon verhältnismäßig sicher und ich obendrein komfortabel der zahlen umbruch erfolgt halb automatisch allerdings muss die schrift funktion vor der eingabe des schlüssel wieder deaktiviert,
sonst kriegen sie probleme beide signatur der schlüssel kennworte nun haben sie in diesem verfahren letzte sicherheitsmängel beseitigen können,
was bedeutet das für den teilnehmer am online-banking verfahren der etwa eine normale überweisung ausführen möchte nun ne der moschee am vormittag persönlich erscheinen und sich ausweisen und uns mitteilen dass er am nachmittag ein online-banking vorgang,
ja allerdings nicht am mittwoch da haben wir hier zu ne,
zudem wird dir am frühen nachmittag zu hause angerufen und bekommt mündlich ein lager plan der stelle übermittelt wo die schlüssel die kette vergraben ist,
dazu hat unser unternehmen teile des hachmann felder gehören gepachtet und in kleine parzellen eingeteilt.
Nun geht er mit so einem kleinen spaten los holt die diskrete und kommt wieder zu uns und tauscht die diskrete zusammen mit seinem wohnungsschlüssel gegen einen versiegelte umschlag,
der ein sehr geheimes passwort enthält mit dem geht er dann an schalter zwölf zu unserer frau,
die den verschlossenen umschlag vor den augen des kunden verzehrt also wenn man sagen die schlucht den runter da kommt er schon mal gar keiner mehr dran und erst dann erhält der kunde sein wohnungsschlüssel zurück,
und hat so die möglichkeit sein computer nebst drucke und monitor,
unsere filiale zu verbringen und dort aufzubauen und dann seine überweisung selbstständig und unter strengen datenschutz durchzuführen ja nun ich überwacht das dann natürlich noch sicherheitshalber natürlich,
und mit diesem blick auf die neuesten sicherheitsstandards des online-banking zurück ins funkhaus so herr doktor wollen wir mal gucken die beiden alimente wie immer,
ach und dann wieder eine rechnung für videos aus holland das können wir dann gleich mit überweisen.
Ja wir danken für diesen bericht aus dem pkw zwei umstellung studio und das war natürlich ein großartiges fällt ist zehn jahre alt aber es hat irgendwie an seine aktualität wenig verloren.
Na dazugewonnen wahrscheinlich eher,
na vor zehn jahren war es noch isi.
Muss man sagen es ist immer so ein kleines bisschen blick in die vergangenheit alles was so an mir vorbei gegangen ist.
Ja ist zehn jahre alt ist und wie ist es ein blick in die.
Das ist das steht da nicht zweitausend.
Ja wie blume dreitausend.
Ich dachte das wäre für zweitausendneun aber.
Stand auch da zweitausendneun kann natürlich sein dass jetzt erst dann hochgeladen.
Muss ich mal gucken ich weiß gar nicht sein dass es noch älter ist,
also capi und so weiter das klingt aber eher nach zweitausend ich guck gerade mal hier stinke fett gibt's seit,
äh ersten episoden wurde neunziger jahren von ndr zwei ausgestrahlt aneinander ne,
der zweitausenddrei nicht mehr fortgesetzt.
Ich habe heute zum ersten mal davon gehört und.
Als noch älter,
ja irgendwann ist ja immer das erste mal ne so für alte scheiße sind wir ja hier alle alt genug.
Also ich finde es auch sehr toll.
Klassiker gut aber das können wir ja mal weg von dem banken.
Und zum kaffee.
Ja ich habe ein produkt was ich euch gerne vorstellen möchte in meinem meter ebene online-shop.
Du trinkst.
Ich habe jetzt gerade nicht vorstellen was ist eigentlich gerade trinken.
Tschüss.
Aber wir können uns auch gerne bei hafermilch unterhalten.
Ich finde das die marke die mir überhaupt nicht schmeckt.
Also marisa ist definitiv one.
Michael ist in der letzten sendung wo ich hier war der meinte dürfte es wäre also das ist das beste.
Na ha familie ist lecker.
Ne aber das ist halt genau die richtige ist für den kaffee weil da auch irgendwie ein bisschen mehr.
Ja also paris da also es gibt von allen herstellern die hafermilch machen,
oder von vielen gibt's auch 'ne paris der variante mit höheren fettgehalt und so weiter wenn irgendwie öl und so weiter rapsöl keine ahnung was ja alles reinmachen und das schon halt korrekt und so weiter und,
ich habe so verschiedene durchprobiert und meiner meinung nach schmeckt halt paris da ist einfach du bist,
every und geschmack kann man sich streiten aber bei mir.
Auch gut als zahnersatz zum kochen verwenden.
Es gibt ja so nennt sich das an das nennt sich dann.
Cream.
Die kitchen oder.
Ja aber die die paris da gehen auch.
Genau es gibt auch welche die noch noch sandiger ist so die kann man dann.
Ja
Schlagsahne habe ich sie nicht ausgedient so aber naja aber wieso was was hast du jetzt gegen.
Ich finde ich ich finde geschmacklich zum kotzen.
Welche die normalen als normaler.
Die audi ich weiß nicht du hast talent hat fürs camp eingepackt und ich war die leidtragende.
Die normale halbarm hafermilch.
Nee wir hatten auch die paris da von denen glauben.
Eine.
Die pariser ist super aber dennis probiert jetzt mal die hafermilch schoko und ich finde das ist noch geiler als die ganzen kuhmilch.
Ich hatte halt einmal aus der metro das mitgenommen was es so gab das war einmal eine eigenmarke von der metro glaub ich einmal die.
Dieses dings da was du auch hattest.
Irgendwie all allnatura das finde ich so geil.
Ist doch.
Ne alter turin ich ich weiß nicht was das bio irgendwas bio hafer oder irgendwas stand da drauf.
Ja ich glaube das war die eigenmarke glaube ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Wie kann man trinken aber ich find die.
Variante ist geil wie kann man sich da mit der anderen hafermilch noch so irgendwie weniger schokoladig machen.
Ich finde die weiß gar nicht es gibt von einigen marken die hafer in vanille auch und die ist auch relativ lecker im cafe wenn man bock hat auf so ein bisschen aroma.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert aber hast du mir schon mal erzählt.
Mit dem schoko geht's auch ganz.
Also doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich finde den geschmack von der in dem.
Es ist ja nochmal spezial einsatzgebiet.
Genau und ich nehme halt auch irgendwie den kaffee das ist.
Aber du hattest eben gerade die,
vor verzögerung die alle pro kaffees die kleinen,
ja da die kaffees die sind so diese schweineteuer gibt's leider nur einen kleinen packung aber die sind so unglaublich lecker,
und man kriegt sie nicht so genau und ja wenn's die dann mal gibt werden sie auf vorrat gekauft.
Na ja aber ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht weil er mich reden das hast du ja macht,
ich wollte euch ein produkt vorstellen weil ich habe ja mal diesen kampf wie macht man so seinen kaffee,
man will ja gut kaffee haben wir haben was guter kaffee.
Was sehr individuelles.
Das ist was sehr individuell ist aber ich wusste ich glaube ich alle so ein bisschen einig sind das ding mit dem hohen druck und so ist schon ganz geile sache es gibt ja diese klassischen kaffee breiter und sowas besitze ich natürlich auch so 'ne typische normale.
Ja man nennt das espresso kanne also was halt unten das wasser dann kommt irgendwie der kaffee im einsatz
dann stellst du das auf den herd dann wird das wasser heiß und irgendwann dehnt sich halt soweit aus das dann durch diesen kaffee nach oben drückt sondern ist da oben so ein kleines büchlein und dann postet das der kaffee wieder runter und dann über einen zeitraum von so sechzig sekunden
brutzelt halt so der ganze kaffee von unten nach oben bist dann irgendwann am ende so macht und dann weißt du so jetzt vorbei.
Das ist ja das was du da gerade stehen ist das macht das so ah was macht die anders weil ich hab auch so eine meines unten jetzt auch äh auch alu sowie oben und ist so wie du geschrieben hast aber das was jetzt noch kommt das feature bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Dann denkt man sich ja immer so na ja vielleicht bist du ja auch eine richtige kaffeemaschine haben und dann wenn ich irgendwie alle zwei jahre hier so einen kaffee laden
irgendwie nochmal den ganzen sehr man erzählen was er jetzt toll ist und bei der maschine und dies und jenes und wasser alles so tolles rennen ist es so durch denkst du auch so ja wieder hunderte von euro dann brauchst du diesen apparat reinigen,
na das nervt mich irgendwie so sind die unterschiedlich schwierig zu reinigen und vollautomaten weil man ja sowieso nicht haben
also willst du was irgendwie was arkansas haben dann denkst du aber auch so ja okay wenn es so wenig nur abnimmt warum und dazu überhaupt noch eine maschine
ja dann kommen die alle mit zu verschiedenen drücken und ja und hier ist aber dann da nicht mehr alo sondern auch wie alles besser gebaut und irgendwann
weißt du dann auch nicht mehr oben und unten und so prozess hat letztes mal auch und dann viel mehr irgendwie ein anderes produkt auf einmal in unter die augen,
was ich noch nicht kannte und das ist nämlich die reality rica und die reality brick a ist eigentlich ein ganz normaler espresso kann ne.
Aber genau die habe ich doch.
Nein hast du nicht.
Du hast die reality mokka.
Ich weiß ja was auf meinem kartons stehen.
Du hast eine brücke warum fragst du mich dann wieder aufgebaut ist.
Du hast vorhin erzählt wie das funktioniert und habe ich gesagt genauso funktioniert ein und du hast gesagt da ist aber jetzt die hat ein feature extra und deswegen warte ich ja noch was jetzt.
Na die hat nicht oben ein loch sondern hier oben ein druck ventil das ist das besondere.
Achso dann hast du vorher nicht erwähnt habe ich die aufgepasst ja das ist ein gewicht drauf was halt.
Das ist kein gewicht ist naja das gewicht aber es ist ein so ein ventil was auf jeden fall
wenn das wasser ein bisschen heiß ist es nicht gleich rauskommt sondern es verbleibt halt länger unten bis dann irgendwann der druck so einen gewissen zwilling point erreicht hat und schnell wert nach,
das ist auf englisch eins,
und wenn's diesen schwert erreicht hat dann spritze das halt alles so mit einem stoß raus das heißt das gerät atmet dann sozusagen den ganzen kaffee von unten nach oben auf einmal und siehe da,
das ding hat dann deutlich mehr kremer ist eigentlich auch sehr viel anfälliger für die wassermenge also du hast dann
oben in diesem oberen teil ist ein strich und du solltest du liest nicht mehr wasser reinmachen als genau das das heißt man füllt oben erstmal bis zum strich und kippt das an unten rein weil wenn du mehr machst dann schmettert dir das alles über und das
es irgendwie überhaupt gar keinen spaß aber wenn du in dem bereich drin bleibst dann kriegst du da irgendwie so korrekte drei oder vier espresso tassen je nachdem was du deine dimension ist,
und ja und das fand ich erwähnenswert und deswegen sage ich ja brick a,
bin ich bin begeistert.
Weil wir keinen kaffee bei dir bekommen dennis wenn du so eine tolle maschine hast.
Weil ich keinen kaffee,
ich trinke ja nur frischen kaffee dann musste man dann schon mitbringt.
Alles klar machen wir das nächste mal.
Tja.
Wo wir schon beim teleshopping sind ich hab auch eine produkte im.
Teleshopping war das gerade teleshopping.
Es war eine produkte empfehlen.
Aber wir haben keinen richtigen keinen richtigen single dafür ne.
Der wird rainer bestimmt mal mit irgendwas um die ecke kommen ja.
Ich glaube ich habe genau die gleiche aber der boden halt auch noch in alle schon etwas modernere version,
ich kann mich auch erinnern wie vor jahren weil die hat wohl vier bar oder so wie vor jahren im club vier basdorf voll viel kann doch gar nicht sein über dieses kleine gewicht und dann haben wir das ausgerechnet mit dem kleinen loch was ja doch wirklich sehr
kleines und das gewicht reicht genau aus um da vier bar zu erzeugen durch das loch inhalts müssen natürlich gleich durchrechnen.
Loggen immer durch.
Aber was sie im club auch schaffen als warnung an alle anderen leute die ihr wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so bekloppt sind wir irgendeine oder mehrere personen im club,
die das immer eine spülmaschine packen und danach ist die britta natürlich
durch weil die reinigungs äh sachen aus der spülmaschine die natürlich total zerstören also diese beschichtung die da drauf ist und dann ist das alu rau und dann schmeckt der kaffee glaube ich danach nicht mehr,
also ist dir lackiert oder irgendwie sowas oder geglättet oder ich weiß nicht was es ist aber behandelt auf jeden fall so jetzt.
Was hat das teleshopping.
Das teleshopping sagt rucksäcke ähm.
Aber das ist ja das teleshopping sollte vielleicht in einem kontext gebracht werden rucksäcke.
Im sinne von reisen.
Ja genau ich war letztes jahr hab ich mir glaube ich bei einem kickstarter von pick design die,
für einen preis der eigentlich nicht zu rechtfertigen ist aber ich hab ihn.
Wie heißt klicks auf kickstarter.
Pik design heißt die firma,
und die haben travel rucksäcke die machen eigentlich ursprünglich kamera zubehör also kamera taschen rucksäcke sos ling becks ein schulter messenger karriere,
wir haben auch so ein kamera klicksystem und die machen regelmäßig kickstarter,
womit man dann halt deren produkte zu einem etwas akzeptabel preis bekommt und ich war halt auf der suche nach einem im reisebüro,
und ich muss sagen ich bin jetzt von den anderthalb jahren in benutzung hell auf begeistert,
der ist groß genug,
ähm um halt wirklich so mal paar für paar tage oder eine woche damit zu verreisen passt ins handgepäck,
sehr viele schön durchdachte features also man kann 'ne dafür pack von von design.
Die fünfundvierzig liter variante hast du aber.
Travel dafür.
Ach nee nicht die.
Ne warte mal du hast den.
Pack man findet relativ einfach über google.
Warte mal ich schmeiße den link in den lack mit rein.
Und ich hab oft gerade so bei größeren rucksäcken das problem dass dadurch dass ich so schmal gebaut bin die schulter,
also die die die träger legen zu weit nach außen auf und der ist halt wirklich so schön,
vorstellbar man kann halt vom,
einmal einfach drauf zugreifen.
Der ist ja noch teurer bei amazon.
Ja also.
Auf der seite von denen kostet er nur zone.
Ja es ist es ist teuer aber ich muss sagen ich liebe ihn sehr und wenn man das geld hat könnte man.
Kostet der.
Ja mit mittags und shipping.
Oh sorry.
Der alte witz.
Könnte man mal angucken ich hatte auch auf dem kongress
es passt halt ich hatte jetzt auch auf dem camp das passt halt einfach so krass viel rein ich kann eine poster rolle für kongresse in die seitentasche packen und das so ein bisschen festzustellen und damit dann mit poster rolle durch die gegend
was er immer so ein kleiner penis.
Aber kann das ding komplett aufmachen im reißverschluss.
Vorne und hinten also du hast im prinzip vorne noch eine weitere trennwand wie kannst du aber auch aufmachen,
und könntest dann sowohl von vorne als auch von hinten und du hast an der seite öffnung das heißt wenn du dein netzteil zum beispiel oder eine trinkflasche in ihrer seite packen willst,
machst du einfach seitentasche aufgreift reinmacht wieder zu.
Jetzt muss aber noch dazu sagen dass die ganzen innentaschen nicht alle dabei sind sondern nochmal extra kosten.
Die interessen sind also du kannst halt nochmal so der initiierte pack säcke packt taschen dazu kaufen ich hab beim kickstarter so einmal ja ich guck mich auf den preis und gibt einmal alles.
Aber dafür sind sie halt beim kickstarter auch um einiges günstiger gewesen und die sind wirklich also das ist so ein rucksack wo ich auch kurzzeitig überlegt hätte ihn zu kaufen ja echt ganz interessant.
Ja also auch so ist halt einfach gut wirklich gut durchdachte haben sich leute echt gedanken drum gemacht und das,
diese diese firma hat so das erste mal für mich so ein bisschen design und leute die mitdenken das hat ja wirklich sinn dass dass dieses konzept war mir vorher nicht so nicht so bewusst,
ich habe davon noch so einen kleinen kleines link der ist der ist nett den trage ich gerne so zwischendurch aber dieser.
Heißt kleineres.
Das sind das ist so 'ne so 'ne.
Days.
Ja every day sling heißt die das ist so eine ein schulter tasche quasi die du auf dem rücken schnallt.
Weißt du was nicht.
Da vorne die haben nochmal so ein every day messenger oder für den rucksack oder so und wenn ich also wenn ich halt tatsächlich mal mit meiner kamera unterwegs bin.
So eine foto tasche meinte hier.
Ja also es.
Ich habe hier gerade den link reingehauen den hat.
Es ist groß genug dass halt mein kleiner dritten soll laptop reinpasst eine kamera noch ein also zwei kleinere objektive ein großes oder kamera und 'ne kleine trinkflasche also so,
dass man ja ganz gut unterwegs ist auch wenn ich jetzt irgendwie tagesausflug konferenz alles reinschmeißen passt.
Du weißt dass bei tim gerade ihr fünfhundert euro verballert habt weil wir demnächst bestellen mit allen taschen was geht.
So was warum denn.
Innentaschen fan bist.
Ja die sind auch wirklich ganz cool gemacht das ist.
Ich sehe dich doch schon wieder zappeln das gefällt dir doch.
Also falls es dir mal angucken möchtest dann kann ich auch einfach mal dabei bringen aber.
Ich bin also sagen wir mal also rucksäcke ich habe mir schon ich habe mir nur ich hätte mir vor einiger zeit meinen rucksack gekauft dann habe ich fast überhaupt nicht benutzt das war eigentlich eher fehlt kauf das hat aber auch was ein bisschen damit zu.
Kauf punkt bist entschuldigung.
Muss ja auch ab und zu mal den sponsor erwähnen hier ne,
das hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun dass ich so bisschen von rucksäcken an sich ein bisschen abgekommen bin ich kann gar nicht genau sagen warum eigentlich da fahrt gesehen bin ich ein großer freund von umhänge taschen,
die vertikal orientiert sind und es gibt extrem wenig,
reich ich hab immer nochmal eine gute alte tom bienen,
tasche die leider bis zum heutigen tag in europa keinerlei distribution haben,
aber die tasche ist für mich nach wie vor unerreicht ich hab noch kein kein anderes design gefunden was überhaupt ähnlich ist.
Es hat auch echt gut aus.
Ich muss die grad nochmal nachschlagen da ich gerade komplett vergessen habe wie das teil eigentlich heiß aber das ist so ein klassiker bei denen ich glaub die haben wir auch nach wie vor.
Da passt das ipad und und dreizehn zoll bestimmt auch rein oder.
Dreizehn soll weiß ich nicht ist es halt,
ich hab da also perfekt für ipad und und und mein elf zoll ja so und das werde ich noch so lange tragen bis apple wieder soll proportionale geräte baut so,
und jetzt muss ich mal gucken hier tom bienen sich da irgendwas getan hat,
wer kram,
sag mal.
Ich war halt konkret nach der suche nach 'ner tasche für reisen konferenzen wo man halt so drei bis sieben tage,
unterwegs war in japan war es halt mit weil sie sehr praktisch war man könnte alles voll stopfen dann hat man sie einmal offen im zimmer rumliegen kann alles zugreifen alles reinschmeißen
rucksack wieder zu und weiter geht's.
Das material ist auch geil aus dem bus gemacht.
Ja also.
Ist eigentlich komplett.
Es ist spritzwasser geschützt oder wie das heißt du hast zwar auch so imprägnieren dings aber du hast sogar die möglichkeit in so einer separaten tasche unten.
Cover.
Cover also es ist abgepackt und du kannst es halt dann einfach festmachen und draus rausziehen oder muss es halt nicht mitnehmen also,
das ist dann wirklich nochmal ein richtiges cover du hast halt den hüftgurt den du gut wegklappen kannst.
Ja das ist auch geil das zum modulare halt.
Cooles feature und überall stabil also was ich da an zeug und gewicht rein.
Du hast ja auch gegoogelt webcam.
Ja also ich habe auch für eine veranstaltung hatte ich das schon bestimmt fünfzehn liter also fünfzehn kilo wasser drin,
und kaffee und hab das damit geschleppt.
In der wüste.
Ne aber wir haben für dreißig leuten fünfunddreißig leute im laub veranstaltet plus helfer und ich war früh morgens wach,
na das war so eine industrie ruine wir haben lieber lieber ab gefülltes wasser bereitgestellt als jetzt aus dem wasserhahn,
und kaffee gab's vor ort auch nicht so richtig war halt alles einfach reingeschmissen hat sich gut stapeln lassen und,
los geht's.
Krass haben ja auch richtig viele farben ich meinem kickstarter gab es ja nur in grau.
Na in unterschieden crowdfunden aber ich mag keine frau am liebsten also der rucksack der schwarz meines längeres irgendwie dunkelgrau viel mehr farbe wird bei mir nicht.
Nee also das andere ist schwarz geht nicht.
Das every day pack pack hatte ich überlegt ist derzeit preislich nicht in meinem budget hab ich auch nicht den bedarf,
da finde ich das schaut halt doch ein kleines bisschen zu zu breit für mich aus als für den alltag also da hätte ich dann gerne ein kleines bisschen etwas schmaler.
Man sieht nicht ja es ist das ist auch oben zu breit glaube ich.
Nein das ist halt so ein bisschen ähm die sind halt ein bisschen flexibel dadurch dass die nur an so.
Wenn ihr aber die abstände sind ja trotzdem locker siebzehn bis zwanzig zentimeter.
Genau also da.
Tom bienen reto heißt mein bevorzugtes teil aber leider ist es irgendwie immer noch nur in den usa direkt erhältlich.
Hat aber auch einen interessanten preis.
Hundertfünfzig dollar.
Für eine umhängetasche.
Für die tasche würde ich auch zweihundertfünfzig dollar.
Das ist total in ordnung aber es ist aus meiner sicht halt nichts was man sich mal eben kauft.
Nee aber das das teil funktioniert bei mir jetzt seit wie lange habe ich das ding,
ewig seit ich irgendwie erst habe also seit.
Ne also.
Da ist jetzt irgendwie ein metallteile kaputt gegangen in zehn jahren ansonsten hält das irgendwie alle bombig und es ist einfach so rund und vor allem einfach,
vertikal an der seite wenn die dinge so breit sind dann bleibst du,
immer irgendwo hängen ist immer irgendwie für irgendwas zu breit immer nicht weiß war auch den vorteil von so einer breiten tasche zu schätzen ich hab auch so eine party beck und wieso diese klassische berlin und wie wir stützen dir das aus irgendwelchem abfall zusammen tasche.
Ein lkw planen.
Ja genau alles wunderbar
aber so laptop und ipad und so weiter vertikal wegstecken und dann hast du die tasche die soll so glatt an deinem körper runtergeht und einfach nicht so viel horizontalen space wegnimmt und mehr so auf a vier ausgelegt dass halt auch noch a vier einfach reinpasst aber eben,
da ist dann auch schluss größer ist das ding nicht dass das das das bringt einfach so die die verarbeitung von diesen tom bienen dinge die nicht einfach,
enorm es ist einfach unfassbar wie gut das.
Wenn es wirklich zehn jahre hält dann kann man da.
Ja ich meine guck dir die tasche an ich meine die die hat zwar schon so der den einen oder anderen streifen von irgendwelchen sachen aber das ist einfach so rein vor den nähten her ist es immer noch alles perfekt,
es ist einfach nichts reißverschlüsse halten alles hält so ja ein haken.
Da ist halt auch nicht die gefahr dass du dir die so vollgepackt dass am ende dann einseitig schulter schulterprobleme.
Na ja doch die gefahr ist trotzdem aber es ist dann am ende nicht ganz so schwer wie bei den größeren taschen.
Ja also nicht so ja keine ahnung diese riesen taschen die auch teilweise gibt wo dann alles mögliche drin landet inklusive zwei laptops und.
Das war das problem so wo warst du denn eigentlich so tada.
Auf,
ja ich war auf zwei konferenzen mein mein september war mein spaßiger monat wo wir auf zwei internationalen konferenzen drei publikationen
dementsprechend war nach dem camp eigentlich dauert spaß also wie das,
wie ich das bei medizinischen konferenzen kenne ist halt du reichst irgendwann ein halbes jahr vor konferenz dreiviertel jahr vor konferenz app streckt ein,
das ist ungefähr eine seite wo du groups gezielt ist was was du auf der konferenz vorstellen willst,
das thema ist und so weiter und so fort und dann kriegst du halt bescheid okay wird angenommen oder nicht,
und auf den medizinischen konferenzen die ich kenne ist das halt entweder als vortrag oder als poster und die meisten sachen sind halt,
als poster also du hast dann ein gutes waren jetzt die größte bei den beiden größten konferenzen in zwei unterschiedlichen,
ja also eine wanne war die größte ems konferenz in europa und die andere war die größte parkinson konferenz weltweit.
Sklerose und parkinson und da sind halt dann irgendwie zwischen achthundert und tausend poster die vorgestellt werden,
und diverse vorträge und workshops und fortbildung pharma.
Skaliert das eigentlich mit diesen posten und ich finde diese poster geschichte irgendwie immer so ein bisschen ich freue mich immer ob das so zeitgemäß ist.
Ich finde es eigentlich gut also es ist in dem fall spannend dass man relativ schnell scannen kann,
mit welchen leuten möchte man sich nochmal unterhalten welche arbeitsgruppen machen arbeiten irgendwie in einem kleinen einem ähnlichen thema es ist halt eine deutlich geringere einstieg förde als irgendwie
und man möchte irgendwie in alle gucken was grad spannend ist ein.
Vielleicht für die leute die jetzt nicht wissen wo wovon wir reden und vielleicht weiß ich das ja auch nicht aber ich verstehe stehen halt dieser poster geschichte vor es gibt auch einen größeren raum und jeder hat da sozusagen so seinen eigenen kleinen stand.
Ja das ist eng an eng an eng an eng du hast irgendwie.
Eng an eng ja genau also so ein sonst lotte.
Du hast einen quadratmeter wo du dich positionierst.
Und wurde dann dein poster aufhängen kann.
Wo ist denn mein poster.
Und das ist null.
Null und da steht dann halt zu unterschiedlichen themen was zu also.
Der kleinste stand den man bieten kann auf der messe.
Aber das sind so die furchtbar ersten layouts und typ.
Das ist das beste das ist.
Gesehen habe.
Ich muss sagen also das ist das ist tatsächlich ein spaß den ich mir bei konferenzen mache wer,
als erstes das a vier ausgedruckte und zusammengeklebt poster findet er hat,
einen preis gewonnen und wer als erstes comics hans poster findet.
Oh ich werde noch einen sonderpreis vergeben für das poster was mehr als fünf schriftarten verwendet.
Oh ja ja auch auch in die richtung also das ist tatsächlich immer so ein bisschen äh mein mein privates highlight ich habe eine schöne galerie von,
posten ich habe auch überlegen irgendwann mache ich mal einen,
vortrag von irgendwie gleich drei bis comic-fans hautton poster,
ja aber ich muss mir noch überlegen wie ich halt die puste anonymisiert ich möchte es ja,
das ja nee nee leider nicht alle also man,
online gestellt andere nicht offiziell ist auch bei.
Sind doch da quasi öffentlich ausgestellt.
Ne das ist keine öffentliche.
Wie viel leute kommen.
Na ja das ist ja ein unterschied ob du nur ein eintritt bekommst wenn du fachpublikum bist und etwas bezahlst.
Ja also das sind halt auch teilweise da werden sachen oder präsentiert,
die noch nicht publiziert sind das heißt die unter sind auf manchen konferenzen darfst du eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht fotografieren und aufnahmen machen was natürlich trotzdem alle machen aber teilweise sind da patienten gesichter drauf,
publikum also es ist.
Wie ist das denn wenn das eine forschungsarbeit ist.
Naja,
ja also ich glaube da kann man schon schon viel nach es gibt es gibt immer so die gleichen schemata von wegen,
die poster zum beispiel die wirklich nur auf einem a vier blatt ausgedruckt sind und dort hängen das heißt man hat dann diese poster wand und da hängt ein blatt in winziger schrift oder,
die die einfach die maße nicht gelesen haben und entweder dann in querformat an null publizieren das heißt passt nicht auf die poster wand und ist dann irgendwie schräg oder bei dem nachbarn mit drauf,
oder die einfach die komplette poster wand diesen kompletten ständer von zweimal einen meter ausfüllen mit ihrem poster es gibt.
Die waren sozusagen schon mal da und wissen genau wie große dinge sind und sind ein schritt weiter.
Ne das es steht es steht ja genau da die poster wand hat die und die,
maße und das poster sollte so groß sein dass es aus anderthalb metern gut zu lesen ist.
Na haben sie auf jeden fall erfüllt.
Haben sie wenn man von ganz oben nach ganz unten kommt und ja also es ist das ist.
Du bist also poster export.
Aber sonst aber sonst wäre jetzt sonst muss nichts auf diese wand außer des.
Steht die poster und dann irgendeine nummer damit man es identifizieren.
Das ist aber eigentlich 'ne ganz gute gelegenheit weil damit könnte man sozusagen ein anderes problem lösen dass nämlich die meisten halt auch einfach keinerlei vorstellungen von räumen und abständen haben.
Aber das ist auch echt schwierig also wir hatten jetzt so bei beiden,
konferenzen einmal hatte man so ein bisschen entspannt platz bei dem anderen waren die poster auf den kompletten kongress gelände so ein bisschen verteilt nach unterschiedlichen,
themen und du standst halt du hattest halt irgendwie so zwei meter rein wo,
poste ein poster ein poster ein poster die halt so standen und das problem war das war nicht mal einen raum,
sondern das war nur so ein party zelt was bei dreißig grad außentemperatur auf einem dach in mittelstand.
Besorgt die wälder königin ne der ist ja klar ne die wälder königin.
Dieses mikrofon.
Das kostet lizenzgebühren hast du schon klar ne.
Hier wird es noch ein bisschen.
Jetzt war,
etablierte die leute wissen auch worauf sich einlassen so weil es so sagen deswegen deswegen kann man das nicht mal so eben durch irgendwas anderes ersetzen obwohl man ja theoretisch auch durch was anderes ersetzen können.
Frage ist was ist denn aber das andere so ein poster funktioniert ja schon ziemlich gut weil du musst erstmal nicht.
Bildschirm hängen zum beispiel.
Es gibt es gibt tatsächlich es gibt auf der,
einen konferenz versuchen sie seit jahren bildschirme zu etablieren also du hast einen separaten bereich mit wirklich
großen bildschirm wo du dein deine poster suchen und,
angucken kannst in ruhe lesen kannst du stehen stühle davor die sind,
das ist aber was anderes und das ist nicht so richtig der sinn und zweck dieser poster fashion,
die poster session ist so ein bisschen speed-dating weil du hast dann zwei stunden,
wo du vor dem poster stehst und alle anderen rennen halt auch vor diesen postern lang und die leute bleiben stehen die das thema interessiert dann kommst du relativ schnell mit den leuten ins gespräch,
oder andersrum du siehst halt in einer sehr kurzen zeitraum unterschiedliche poster zu unterschiedlichen themen oder zu gruppieren ähnlichen themen und kannst halt vergleichen,
und das ist durch zum also dann bräuchtest du irgendwie um das ähnlich umzusetzen achthundert monitore was jetzt nicht ganz,
und dann müsstest du halt irgendwie dieses dieses geld anders gestalten.
Das war mir jetzt nicht so ganz klar dass es da so eine eine zeit begrenzung gibt also.
Also die poster hängen zwei den ganzen tag.
Aber man ist nicht immer jemand daneben.
Es ist nicht immer dahin.
Aber es läuft auch sonst niemand darum dass sie sich an.
Doch also was ich zum beispiel typischerweise mache ist ich gehe morgens einmal alle poster durch gucke was hängt und gucke wo ich dann während der poster session die irgendwie nachmittags oder abends ist nochmal mit den leuten reden will.
Musst du nicht selber bei dem poster stehen.
Na du hast ja drei tage.
Was wäre jetzt wenn das sozusagen so 'ne art animation ist was wäre wenn es interaktiv ist.
Es gibt tatsächlich leute die hängen zum beispiel tablets mit ans posten,
zusätzlich also die haben ihr normales edition poster,
und ein detaillierten spot wurde ein ipad dranhängen wo dann videos oder animationen oder sonstwas laufen aber dadurch dass es eben nicht animiert ist kann man sehr sehr einfach dass der titel das sind die autoren kann man einfach vorbeigehen und scannen.
Manchmal hilft der staatlicher content damit man nicht irgendwie das war da vorhin aber jetzt ist es weg und so dann.
Nein ich sehe das schon.
Und du hast halt auch einen anderen blickwinkel also mit den monitoren da musst du halt im prinzip gerade davor stehen und kannst nicht einfach vorbeilaufen.
Okay aber es geht sozusagen um die initialen kontakten damit folgt das ding ja im prinzip mehr oder weniger denselben regel nicht denselben also unter anderem könnte man auch die regeln an wenn dir für normales werbeplakat gelten,
weil es soll ja sozusagen auch erstmal dich da so hinziehen,
egal ob das comics hans ist oder.
Das kommt tatsächlich mehr auf den content drauf an also die normalen regeln die für ein werbe poster gelten,
gelten aus meiner sicht nicht für seinen tv poster und sei es brauchen,
das war schon die grundlegenden designvorgaben von wegen text muss lesbar sein und müssen gewisse front haben aber,
poster sind für mich halt eine knappe darstellung von tatsächlich einer wissenschaftlichen arbeit und da möchte ich,
nachvollziehen was sind jetzt die statistische methoden was sind die population,
größe also schon in detail was dort passiert ist,
und wenn man diese ganzen informationen zu stark abstrahiert,
werden werden aus meiner sicht information weggenommen die eigentlich.
Über die regeln die für werbeplakat ist es etwas für klausuren da wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen es muss unbedingt jetzt wenig sein was da drauf ist nur definitiv finde ich also zumindest was ich so ein poster bisher kennengelernt habe was,
damals nicht für vieles aber ich habe sehr oft einfach den alltag den eindruck was auch immer da jetzt irgendwie von euch relevant zu sein scheint,
ist einfach zu viel informationen es ist einfach es ist einfach zu voll zu zu unübersichtlich,
zu zu viel von allem.
Ja ja also das sind halt unterschiedliche also ich habe mir da ich habe mir da auch mit 'nem bekannten der halt sein und kommunikationswissenschaft studiert hat wirklich so ein bisschen gedanken und austausch gemacht,
es ist halt zum einen willst du die die relevanten informationen jemand anderem,
mitgeben also zum beispiel die quintessenz die die die jetzt erkenntnisse die deine wissenschaft gewonnen haben irgendwie ein schlagwort den oder in kurzen sätzen,
du willst aber auch genug informationen bereitstellen dass er im prinzip auf ähnliche oder andere schlüsse kommen kann,
und das ist halt so ein so ein bisschen schwierig also ich habe,
gesehen die dann irgendwie ganz groß in stich,
wörtern stich setzen zwei drei zu stichpunkten hatten das sind jetzt ihre out kampf und das ist aber für manche das interessante,
für für mich als wissenschaftler ist es aber das absolut interessanteste weil ich will sehen die daten und was gemacht wurde und meine eigenen schlussfolgerung ziehen,
und das ist.
Daten totaler möchte gerne die daten.
Ja ja ja also es ist halt wirklich wirklich wichtig.
Oliver.
Man kann halt alleine schon bei bei der wahl der diagramm.
Oh gott ich bin froh dass du dass du mich manchmal vorher fragst ob irgendwas gut aussiehst sieht.
Ja ja also man kann halt auch sehr viel informationen tatsächlich so verstecken im daten das,
da nicht mal böse gemeint aber das ist dann einfach miss mischling.
Man muss vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen dass bei grad bei,
ergebnissen präsentieren die meisten forscher haben halt keine ahnung von wie präsentiert man eigentlich etwas so richtig gut,
wie muss ich es gerade eigentlich so aufbereiten dass dieses beschissene art null plakat,
interessant aussieht und derjenige möchte es lesen und danach möchte derjenige vielleicht auch noch mit mir darüber reden das ist halt super schwer.
Ja also wenn man also ich hab angefangen so stichpunkt liste zu machen was man eigentlich beachten müsste und was,
ich immer vergesse als informationen und was was irgendwie drauf sein muss und das ist halt wirklich,
eine relativ lange komplexer liste und allein wenn man da schon abarbeitet dann ist so ein poster halt einfach mal schnell voll,
also es wird jetzt es wird jetzt,
aus meiner sicht wenn man einen halbwegs komplexes thema hat das kann man nicht in irgendwie drei hübschen diagramm zusammenfassen und dann ein,
für normale leute visuell ansprechendes,
ergebnis liefern ist sehr schwierig und das ist aus meiner sicht aber auch nicht,
also das ist schön wenn es so ist aber das darf nicht der anspruch sein wenn die wissenschaft darunter leidet,
sondern ich bin froh wenn die leute wissenschaftlich sauber präsentieren,
also selbst wenn sie dann comics hans draufhaben okay kann man ihn sagen du comics ist jetzt lustig muss nicht sein dunkelblaue schrift aus schwarzem hintergrund ist ein bisschen schwierig zu lesen,
könnte man vielleicht auch nicht der regenbogen als hintergrund ist cool aber vielleicht ein bisschen tomaten,
solange halt aber die informationen da sind und wenn halt nicht beschrieben sind oder das messverfahren nicht beschrieben ist.
Aber das sind ja zwei vollständig also meiner meinung nach gibt es,
drei hier miteinander verstorbene sachen so das eine ist natürlich klar du musst natürlich dein inhalt richtig darstellen und du musst die daten da liefern so das zwingt sozusagen jetzt die wissenschaftliche darstellung wobei ich halt auch sagen würde irgendwo ist dann ja dann auch die die
die
soll ich sagen irgendwann ist dann die die kapazität dieses poster s dieses gedruckten dings auch einfach erreicht da muss man einfach akzeptiert,
immer umfangreicher sein wird als es in aalen null darstellbar ist so auf anderthalb meter.
Andere sind natürlich was du jetzt schon angesprochen hast so grundlegende erkenntnisse über,
welche visualisierung für welche art von daten bietet sich denn bitte an ne und dann natürlich auch so ganz grundlegende design sachen mit,
farben typ po graf ie,
abstände zeilen abstände zeichen abstände spalten abstände dokumenten rentner et cetera weil ja generell in so kreisen und das ist ja auch eine neue krankheit deswegen spricht das auch an,
space ist fehler also weiß ist sozusagen
ungenutzt unsere lehre beide müssen irgendwie gefüllt werden so man hat immer so diese daten kompressionen wahnsinn und dann so wieder da geht da noch was rein guck mal da ist ja,
platz irgendwie so ja sondern wie anfängt noch zwischen den zeilen irgendwas zu schreiben
das ist so das anderes nächste aspekt ist dass man natürlich auch mit der dynamik der bewegung der betrachter arbeiten kann das heißt du kannst halt explizit auch deine abstraktion in schriftgrößen übersetzen das heißt,
du schreibst am größten die allgemeine aber zunächst einmal zu vermitteln der informationen umso näher dran tritts umso mehr kleine kästchen mit kleineren,
informationen hast du das heißt wenn du es genauer wissen willst dann musst du halt eine lesebrille nochmal rausziehen und dann hast du da irgendwie noch dein.
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig weil du hast johannis innen auf den meisten konferenzen die ich
gesehen habe hast du gar nicht den die möglichkeit soviel space abstand zu haben entweder stehen leute direkt vor dir also du hast halt denn nur so ein zwei meter korridor wo auf der rechten seite und auf der linken seite,
aneinander gereizt diese poster sind das heißt du als person als ansehen da gehst im prinzip in der mitte durch,
und zu große schrift erschlägt dich und du musst dich halt kopf viel bewegen um überhaupt jetzt den satz lesen zu können und zu kleine schrift du kommst da gar nicht ran weil eventuell leute davor stehen,
also mit schriftgrößen variieren bin ich sehr sehr vorsichtig,
lieber andere mittel des highlights zum beispiel nehmen.
Schriftgrößen soll man ja auch eigentlich nur so verwenden wie es dem text plus zugute kommt dem leser fluss zu gute kommt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein dynamisches problem also es kommt auch immer auf die leute an wie sie nun anderthalb meter stehen oder zweieinhalb oder wo sie gucken genau.
Hauptsache ist gut abfotografiert bei damit man später aufnehmen kann es ist so,
man tatsächlich auch manche hat aber den effekt dass.
Nur machen und dann einfach weitergehen und keiner.
Das ist nicht das das problem aber was ist denn wenn das hinterlegte poster sich dann nochmal ändert wenn man fest also wenn im nachhinein das poster eventuell mit seinen inhalten angepasst wird,
ja aber das kannst du ja als kurz genau gar nicht kann ich feststellen.
Ja was meinst du dass der das nicht die neueste version bekommt weil gerade mit dem link kann man das doch regeln.
Du würdest den link direkt auf die pdf immer setzen.
Ja aber in einen qr-code ist ja halt nur nur einen link,
das heißt der hersteller des postet das und der provadis links kann da zu zugriff zeiten einfach mal was ändern das heißt wenn du nur den qr-code speichert und nicht das poster selbst abfotografiert,
können da dir im prinzip andere inhalte präsentiert werden als wenn du jetzt das poster abfotografiert.
Sieht das problem nicht das hört sich an als wenn du nicht der der master auf dem link bist.
Nee andersrum wenn mir jetzt einfach nur ein link provider wird hier das ist der code das ist meine forschung dann könnte rein theoretisch der diesen link zur verfügung stellt einfach seine daten ändern oder.
Ja ja genau ja ja.
Genau das will man aber ja eigentlich nicht unbedingt also du willst ja sicher gehen dass dieser link den du jetzt gespeichert hast dass da nicht.
Das was du gesehen hast.
Eine andere korte ist oder was anderes dahinter steckt.
Ich glaube dennis sieht die mut willigkeit etwas böses zutun dahinter nicht sondern du siehst sowas wie thaiboxen zu fixen ist eine sache.
Ja wenn wenn der wenn der plötzlich mit 'nem ganz anderen poster kommt dann auch einfach gleich nicht dran kleben also dann ist ja dann sein problem.
Das ist das was der tag.
Er will da was von dir eigentlich du willst also weißt du so wenn der das nicht ordentlich macht und dir das poster und am arsch weg ändert ja dann hat er doch das problem weil du gehst dann halt zur not woanders hin.
Na ja er kann halt seine daten zum beispiel besser darstellen,
oder ein ganz anderes thema mir unter jubeln an dem ich eigentlich gar nicht jetzt.
Ich verstehe nicht was du also das hört sich so als wenn du nicht selber dein korkut an deinem poster verwaltet.
Nein nein nein eine andere andere richtung der leser der leser kann nicht nachvollziehen was ich an diesem qr code geändert hat beziehungsweise an dem link dahinter.
Ist doch nicht schlimm.
Na doch es kommt darauf an was deine absicht ist wenn du.
Was ist die absicht des lehrers.
Du willst das was du gesehen hast in dem poster vielleicht nochmal nachricht.
Du meinst es könnte sein dass er nicht das gleiche poster,
kriegt als dort ja aber der der dort ausstellt das ist doch der hat doch das größte interesse weil da gibt auch solche geld dafür aus dort zu stehen und dem vorbeigehen denn was anzubieten das ist doch gar nicht in seinem interesse seine seine seine gäste zu verarschen.
Natürlich natürlich du wirst vielleicht deine forschung besser darstellen lassen als dass sie eigentlich ist,
fashion von daten ist ja so ein ding also du kannst.
Da kannst du auf der messe auch schon gleich machen.
Ne auf der messe hast du halt ein gedrucktes poster das fotografierst du einmal ab und dann ist das im prinzip nicht mehr veränderbar von außen das das das foto ist dann.
Ein bisschen so ein bisschen beleg davon halt auch.
Ich weiß jetzt was ihr meint aber ich meine auch die welt ist dynamisch und natürlich ändert sich auch immer alles also,
dass man jetzt groß beschissen wird sehe ich als geringeres problem an als dass er natürlich auch weiter,
seine arbeit und so weiter und so fort.
Ja
Was sollen wir denn da bescheißen da können sie auch schon gleich bescheißen also wenn da bescheißt da macht er das auch mit und ohne dann war 's dann ist der ihr doof,
früher oder später raus das ist eine andere sache aber ich meine deswegen keine cola ko zu benutzen aber ich glaube wir vertiefen und zu dollar.
Erzähl doch mal lieber weißt du was schreiben darüber wie die poster machst.
Äh also huckel hatte glaube ich vor vor einiger zeit schon mal designer.
In den letzten sendung.
Genau angesprochen also derzeit bei uns standard ist eigentlich eine arbeitsgruppe powerpoint,
genau auch in anderen forschung drücken es so an null poster erstellen mit powerpoint.
Das wissen wir auch warum die dinger so aussehen wie sie aus.
Ja also ich hab auch schon glaube ich welche die in wort erstellt worden gesehen aber,
habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Such mal bitte danach.
Not for science.
Habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen ich muss auch sagen die poster werden qualitativ doch besser ich habe letztens also dieses jahr hab ich kein comics hans poster nur andere komische fonds gesehen also.
Dafür ist wahrscheinlich der rest alles in areal.
Solange es gut lesbar ist.
Also ich nutze findet die publisher das.
Welche fonds benutzt werden.
Abwechselnd ne.
Nein wie heißt das doch gleich.
Ich hatte 'ne zeit benutzt im prinzip,
google zwei google von also derzeit nutze ich monster rat und oben,
bin damit aber noch nicht so zufrieden ich glaube ich hatte eine zeit oswald und wenn man oswald,
ich glaube das war aus wald oder robot otto ich glaube es war brutto beim euro brutto irgendwie in schrift größe zweiundsiebzig hat und das auf einem an null poster aufdruck dann hat das da teilweise,
pixel die buchstaben sind nicht exakt auf der gleichen höhe können nee das geht nicht das,
muss jetzt irgendwie anders gehen und hab da aber noch nicht mein mein.
Es ist halt gut die google fand sind wahrscheinlich auch eher für bildschirm die meisten optimiert oder.
Der roboter.
Moto ja genau das ist eine klassische display schrift naja das ist schwierig.
Vorher nie aufgefallen und vorher hat es mich auch gar nicht interessiert bist mich dann irgendjemanden sensibilisiert hat für ja du typo grafik ist wichtig und hier lies mal das und hier probier mal das aus und oh aha und dann stört dann plötzlich sowas.
Ja total und genau google hat ja schon bei den google fans gibt 's dir auf jeden fall über die rings schon mal so ein bisschen 'ne idee was gut zusammen passen könnte,
muss nicht alles.
Also ich hatte lange zeit erfindet die designer,
ich nutze jetzt weiterhin erfindet die designer irgendwie für meine diagramm weil die kann ich mir aus preisen einfach als exportieren
infinity designer rein schriftgrößen farben alles anpassen wie ich will und dann baue ich mir mein mein poster im prinzip in publisher zusammen
und bin,
damit eigentlich sehr zufrieden ist halt nur so ein bisschen buggy,
aber ich hoffe einfach dass das verbessert sich,
und ja wir arbeiten jetzt so mit,
zwei drei anderen leuten mit dem programm und das klappt sehr gut das heißt das kann ich an sich nur empfehlen und ist bei allen maßen besser als powerpoint.
Ja beim freund kann man auch,
pfund kann man kann man einiges kaputt machen und von kann man auch einiges gewinnen also es gibt einfach von uns die so eine,
klassische also das ist der klassiker so wie die universum und so weiter die sind auch in allen möglichen,
dicken gibt so dass halt auch mit so mit boot und die technik und an verschiedenen überschriften und headlines und so weiter arbeiten kannst sondern einfach so ein reiches tools hätte
hass und man sollte auf jeden fall auch immer noch mal gucken ob man nicht dann fließtext dann doch lieber auch mit tarifen von smart,
weil es sich dann zeit weil vielleicht noch etwas besser lesen lässt.
Genau genau das sind äh da bin ich sehr froh dass ich da andere personen habe die mich auch sowas hinweisen weil ich bin.
Du bist einfach auch irgendwann betriebsblind du kannst halt auch nicht alles wissen.
Ja ich finde mich langsam in design von dingen ein ich mein vor vier jahren meine vortrags folien waren einfach noch weiter hintergrund schwarze schrift und.
Völlig valide.
Halt nicht viel also schon ein bisschen mit graphischen sachen aber,
das war halt so mein mein mein standard,
damit da wusste ich auch nicht wie ich wie ich was ich anders machen könnte oder wollen würde ich habe halt den bedarf nicht gesehen und dann kam halt so ein bisschen erziehung und information und.
Erziehung aus erziehung erfahren endlich in deinem leben.
Ja natürlich typo grafik erziehung.
Was hast du gemacht.
Das war's.
Nur darauf hingewiesen dass sie nicht mehr so freundlich zu allen personen sein so.
Ja das war die erziehung die ich hätte genossen.
Ey die hat immer die ganzen dumpf packen in der uni abschreiben lassen das kann ja wohl nicht angehen also die die wirklich kein bock haben was zu machen und dabei immer diejenige ja natürlich.
Ja hier ich kenne.
Ja nein sie ist viel zu gut dieser welt viel zu gut aber.
Gelernt von den.
Oh ja das das war schönste moment als security der vortrag wie du die an gebrüllt hast mein gott ist mir das herz aufgegangen weißt du hast wir haben ziemlich schlechte folien gehabt glaube ich in dem vortrag.
Ja ne.
Erzähl mal weiter.
Aber die volle müssten wir wirklich mal raussuchen die sind bestimmt richtig schlimm.
Ja die waren halt auch einfach nur schwarz und weiß und jetzt arbeite ich bin ja so ein bisschen also hab ich mich durch unterschiedliche sachen durch.
Ich werde folgendes vorschlagen man sollte zumindest auch an seinem brand arbeiten ja so,
und das ist auf jeden fall ganz sinnvoll sich also man muss ja nicht immer alles selber machen,
es ist zum beispiel durchaus zu erwägen für wissenschaftler ja mal so post hat ich meine die anforderungen an poster sind in gewisser hinsicht immer dieselben.
Oh da habe ich auch zwei beispiele.
Aber du würdest mir zustimmen ja es ist ja relativ klar definiert wir haben jetzt mehrere sachen dabei so das diese situation betrachtung anschalten das ist das publikationen format an null also es ist jetzt nicht so dass er jetzt extrem viel varianz drin ist
also wie viel gutes leids,
könnte man zur designerin oder designer seiner ihrer wahl gehen und sich einfach entsprechend tablets machen lassen,
sozusagen komplette vorlagen darüber und diese sonne ganz ganz persönliche note auch haben.
Ja also wirklich primär pharma gesponserte poster haben corporate designs also diese,
schauen auch wirklich schön aus man kann trotzdem immer noch viel falsch damit machen aber sie haben ein einheitliches farbschema.
Fahr mal gesponserte.
Also was meinst du wo sonst dass das geld herkommt für die wissenschaftliche.
Nein das ist mir schon klar aber wie wie fern nehmen die dann auf das poster design also wodurch.
Halt nicht comic-fans drin ist.
Die forschung die davon gesponsert ist da kriegt man dann auch gleich von dem unternehmen noch zu tabletten.
Kann man oder größere unis haben zum beispiel auch teilweise ein corporate design und wie das ausschauen muss und tablets,
ein problem damit ist das ist mir da hatte ich halt auch so ein bisschen drauf gedacht problem ist tatsächlich du kannst dieser erste eindruck,
bleibt dann nicht mehr hängen von dem poster wenn du drei oder vier poste hast,
ein gleiches corporate design haben gleiche aufteilung gleiche farbe.
Das sind die nicht mehr individuell sondern es geht unter du weißt nicht mehr welches welches war.
Genau genau und das ist tatsächlich das das war mir halt auch nicht bewusst oder wenn alle blau sind.
Na klar ich rede nicht von so wie alle anderen sondern so wie du ja.
Aber wenn auch ihre immer blau sind dann weiß ich auch nicht mehr welches von ihr war das jetzt das vom letzten jahr oder das vom vorletzten jahr.
Kannst du mit den farben auch durch rotierende wasser halt jedes jahr eine andere akzent farbe.
Aber wenn du eine arbeitsgruppe hast oder eine universität die halt einfach vier poster haben und davon zwei oder drei nebeneinander hängen,
und vielleicht ähnliche studie andere auswertung schwerpunkt titel ist zu neunzig prozent also die kannst.
Mir ist auch gerade entfallen dass ihr natürlich alle so in gruppen arbeitet und was mache ich ja.
Deutsch wenn du das coolste geilste thema ist dann nimmst du doch wieder comics hans weil dann das war doch das geile zeug mit dem comic.
Das fotografiert auf jeden fall.
So geht das nämlich.
Das ist schon so dass es schon so ungeil ist wieder cool ist.
Ja so sascha lobo style.
Fest.
Ja ist egal.
Weiß ich aber zum beispiel auch hatte ist ähm drei poster mit exakt gleich im aufbau ähm in drei unterschiedlichen farben.
Also arenal und alex und.
Ja also blau rot und grün war dann halt die poster man hat halt gesehen okay irgendwie kannst du die auch wieder nicht auseinanderhalten nur wenn du das gleiche design nimmst und den,
und die farbe ändern.
Der rot-grün und so weiter für rot-grün blinde.
Ja auch also das ist tatsächlich eine nicht ganz triviale frage wie man die poster so individuell gestaltet,
dass sie irgendwie eyecatcher sind und man sich daran erinnern kann,
und wie sie aber trotzdem irgendwie im corporate design oder gruppen und so uni derselbe genutzt werden können dass halt jeder in der arbeit komme mit arbeiten kann.
Ja du brauchst so 'n so 'n so 'n maschine learning basierten layout remixe der dir sozusagen immer wieder individuelle designs macht aber aus derselben denkweise heraus.
Einzigartig.
Na gut also ich steck mal mit meinen ganzen dummen kommentare ein bisschen zurück.
Ne ist ja also ja es ist halt ich habe noch noch,
keine lösung außer ring irgendwie den leuten bei uns sensibilisiert und.
Aber es muss schon was geschehen oder also mein eindruck war immer so ein bisschen so.
Kommt drauf also die beiden konferenzen muss ich wirklich sagen die sind jetzt in jedem jahr besser geworden,
da tut sich auch was aus meiner sicht ist jetzt ich sage mal achtzig neunzig prozent sind sogar akzeptabel poste,
also die kann man so stehen lassen lesen sind jetzt vielleicht nicht total super typ programmiert,
für mich wäre jetzt eher noch dass es inhaltlich sauberer wird so nicht nur bar charts nicht nur peeling auch die nächste bitte,
reporten also das sind dann ein eher so sachen die auch noch aus meiner sicht wichtiger sind.
Ja aber das ist ja auch wieder individuell auf den der da lang läuft oder.
Nee nee das ist einfach wie man so gutes wissenschaftliches arbeiten also das,
ist halt also bestimmte sachen sollte man einfach nicht machen und das müssen die personen halt einfach auch wissen dass man es nicht machen sollte.
Gut was hast du noch erlebt auf deinen konferenzen.
Ich habe süßigkeiten mitgebracht.
Du meinst alles was hier rumliegt dass es gerade.
Du bist auf der studentenfutter was du.
Nee also ich hab die sind aus schweden und ich werde nicht das französische ding hier aussprechen das sind.
Bestimmt ganz lustig wenn der franzose.
Nein nein dämonische ja.
Oder spricht man nicht weißt du das ist das so ja.
Ja beim französisch,
in der schule gelernt ja zwölf jahre.
Zwölf jahre achso du warst ja auch so 'ne sprachschule,
ich weiß schon welcher schule warst aber ich meine die haben auch viel sprachen gemacht.
Und den na und das tanzen hast du vergessen.
Tanzen gibt kein tanz bekloppte.
Na hast du nicht gesagt du kannst deinen namen tanzen.
Nein das habe ich nicht gesagt das sagen immer alle über waldorf.
Aber du kannst dir deinen namen tanzen.
Ich kann auch ganz andere sachen denn es wird mega talentiert also ich meine wollen jetzt nicht das gesprächsthema waldorfschüler aufmachen also lass mir das.
Ja für mich ist halt immer so das spannendste tatsächlich wenn ich im ausland bin die supermärkte.
Was ist denn hier mit laboratorien.
Die sind lecker das sind so husten.
Es ist gut für dein herz stimmchen.
Ja es ist nicht gut für meine zarte linie.
Deshalb sind sie so klein.
Ganz kleine zucker glücklich.
Ja
Ich fand fand die sache mit den ingwer.
Ich hab auch den mango pfefferminz die sind auch relativ scharf.
Aber es ist ja relativ sinnlos jetzt darüber zu sprechen wenn es die dinger nicht irgendwie irgendwo auch zu bestellen gibt oder muss man,
was ich mal geguckt.
Ja das weiß ich nicht.
Hast du eine filiale link mitgebracht.
Ich glaube es gibt ein paar schwedische versandhandel.
Also es sind vegane ginger von rené wollt her heißt die heißt die marke anscheinend müssen.
Ach so das ist ja der.
Vegane kaugummis also nicht kaugummi kaugummi sondern so frucht comedy an auf den man rumkauen kann,
und bis jetzt erstaunlich lecker.
Punkt punkt da sieht man auch genau nach dem aus guck mal du hast ein chat.
Wie der wollt her kommt aus schweden ja.
Ja das ist der schwedische shop von denen also tala hat wenn du dich kurz daran erinnerst gesagt dass sie das aus schweden mitgebracht hat.
Wollte er hört sich eben nicht nach schweden.
Doch nicht aber so heißt die firma halt.
Ich bin.
Wurde wegen der arsch gegründet,
ich glaub in armee land und haben den namen gewählt weil es klingt so vertrauensvoll nach gutem eis.
Motor head fans die wollten auch sowas.
Also der war gut.
Erfunden jetzt.
Mein zweites highlight war tatsächlich petty bücherecke ähm äh,
also ja klar wann wann coole konferenzen ich habe viel gelernt aber mein mein highlight war so ein bisschen die haben da halt immer so einen kleinen bücher stand wo man viel zu überteuerte fach- bücher kaufen kann,
wie das leider der fall ist dies bei amazon alle locker zehn euro günstiger gibt was sehr lustig ist aber ich habe dadurch die box,
oxford hand box series entdeckt
ich hatte das zur medizin statistik in der hand und das ist halt wie so eine so eine kleine bibel also wirklich taschenformat sehr sehr dünnes papier,
und sah nach einem sehr guten nachschlagewerk aus das gleiche gibt es halt irgendwie auch für movement des orchesters und dann hab ich mal geguckt und,
aus der reihe gibt's halt irgendwie alles also von,
oxford handbuch series von jetzt irgendwie handbuch of war über feminismus über irgendwelche obs gur nischen archäologie es kommt eine komplette medical series,
und wenn das eine wissenschaft ist,
kriminologe passt das nicht du bist ein management politiker seins ja also.
Media performance.
Ja also wenn die wenn die alle ähnlich gut sind wie die die ich in der hand hatte kann ich's,
da ist das vielleicht sicherlich einen blick wert,
ein gewisses genesis library projekt dass man über zwiebel browser erreichen kann hat auch einiges vorhanden,
aber ja also ich war hellauf begeistert.
Es gibt sie sofort handbuch of story fokussiert jetzt zwar nicht unbedingt auf podcast aus geht zumindest schon mal in diesem bereich.
Technology impact part vier.
Okay.
Es ist halt eher so ein so vielleicht so nach also nachschlagewerk.
Lese faul.
Ja andere andere spannende ich habe kennengelernt was ein roter roth ist,
ein roter rot,
das ist im prinzip ein apparat das sind so trend scheiben die um ein sich drehenden starb
also an einem sich drehenden stab angebracht sind umso selections zu bilden und dann werden neu die mäuse auf diesen mittelstadt gesetzt und der fängt an sich zu drehen und dann wird die zeit gemessen wie lange die maus ich halten kann bis sie runterfällt,
und unten ist halt so eine kleine durch schwerkraft,
aktiviertes stoppuhr und dann kann man halt ablesen wie lange die maus auf diesem sich drehenden stab gehalten hat.
Fällt mir eine ganz wichtige frage zu ein toller.
Wenn die mäuse mäntel des ortes haben dann können sie nicht so lange halten und da kann man gucken ob sie besser oder schlechter wurden im verhältnis zu anderen mäusen.
Das ist richtig es geht aber nicht um mäntel des ortes aber,
ja es ist tatsächlich so es wird ja.
Warte jetzt ein punkt bekommen oder nicht erzählen ja mit.
Zwei von drei richtig es wird tatsächlich noch sehr sehr viel mit maus modellen gearbeitet das heißt man hat irgendwie genetische variante.
Also ist das so ein verteilung prüfer oder was oder so.
Man dich da draufsetzt schon.
Labyrinth sind eher so verteilung das ist tatsächlich mehr so physische,
kann sich halten fällt nicht runter gleichgewicht.
Aber die mäuse sind von haben von sich aus diese des ortes.
Aber wenn die mäuse verpeilt sind so.
Ja was heißt jetzt verpeilt also ja.
Was heißt schon verpeilt klar dann kann man auch podcast mitmachen ja nee wenn man in diesen zustand wenn man nicht mehr so ganz so also welche welche welche fähig.
Mental.
Ist ja nicht ist mental ist ja auch 'ne haptische wahrnehmung.
Tief kommunikativ und wahrnehmung das sind halt nochmal so zwei sachen also das eine ist.
Kognitive und wahrnehmung nicht dasselbe.
Nee kommission ist eher so zum beispiel rechnen rechne schwächer also kondition ist oder du hast keinen großen wortschatz kondition ist eher so so lernen,
wahrnehmung kann aber einschränkung der sinne sein also du kannst geistig total fit sein.
Aber blind okay.
Oder du kannst wörter nicht verstehen weil einfach das.
Es ist alles bis aber zu blöd.
Ja
Muss ja nicht immer gleich zu blöd sein.
Ja also.
Finde ich auch aber es.
In der verarbeitungsverzeichnis sprechen obwohl du die wörter richtig wahrnehmen kannst und dann gibt's halt noch so du kannst die muskeln einfach nicht richtig ansteuern und kannst deshalb nicht laufen oder,
ja koordination so umsätze ganz groß und das ist tatsächlich das ist noch einer der nette tests die man somit mit maus modellen macht und ich fand das irgendwie ganz lustig und es hat einen lustigen namen.
Das rote rot das ist so quasi so nominiert des test teil da stellt man sich einfach hin und dann kann man sozusagen seinen mäusen irgendwas.
Eine schon bei fünfzig sekunden runtergefallen die eine bei einundachtzig sekunden und alle anderen drei sind bei hundertachtzig sekunden die halt noch durch wobei die ganz rechts gerade abstürzen ist und wahrscheinlich in der nächsten sekunde die stoppe unten stoppt,
und wenn man rechts sieht man kann verschiedene übersetzungen also geschwindigkeiten da einstellen.
Also man ist generell in der wissenschaft eher nicht so ne,
mäusen und raten und anderem getier aber das fand ich ein ganz lustigen test,
gerade so halt für für balance und wie gut sind sie denn eigentlich ja ist also ballons fähigkeit von mäusen wird zum beispiel in sekunden gemessen sowie.
Man ja auch mit menschen machen.
Könnte man könnte man aber die eu-kommission sind immer so ein bisschen,
wenn man sowieso schon fragile menschen auf sich bewegende rollen setzt um dann zu gucken wie lange sie brauchen um runterzufallen.
Wirklich.
Ja
Wenn wir da nicht wieder bei der apple watch wo apple millionen von menschen irgendwie überwacht und,
drüber macht und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist das lustige in der it sind die ethischen anforderungen ganz andere weil die haben keine keine standardmäßig,
kommission das heißt wenn du in der einen versuch machen würdest,
so ein system zu bauen und dann freiwillige die zufälligerweise irgendwie patienten sind aber nicht über die uniklinikum rekrutiert wurden dort ein spannst,
dann geht's ist zwar ethisch moralisch fragwürdig aber es.
Vielen dank für die vorlage muss ich doch platz mal einen kurzen werbeblock einführen sich nämlich jetzt fast gerade verpasst aber,
gerade in meiner serie forscher geist mit dem peter hofer schöne sendung gemacht und die möchte ich allen informatikern sehr ans herz legen,
über verantwortung in der informatik.
Sehr gut sehr gut ich bin absolut dafür.
Ja auch dafür und das ist nämlich ganz interessant weil die haben nämlich da an der tu in wien haben sie das quasi eingeführt dass alle die damit informatik anfangen
quasi diesen einen flechtkurs mitmachen müssen und der heißt way of thinking in informatik,
und das ist so neun plus eins kapitel system wo sie quasi so zehn denkweisen vorstellen,
beginnen mit was erstmal nicht so richtig dazu gehörte der nicht in nicht wissenschaftlichen methodik dann geht es halt immer so weiter mit wissenschaftliches denken
mathematisches denken computer thinking und so weiter,
super super podcast kann ich nur empfehlen,
ganz toll zwei stunden einfach geiler geiler einblicke in wie man so mit moral ethik und so weiter und informatik umgehen sollte.
Das ist tatsächlich war dieses jahr auf einer konferenz konferenz unter die war eher
informatiker und mechatronik und so nicht medizin lastig aber in medizin,
und da waren,
ordentlich viele poste wo ich mir so dachte dass wir so nicht durch eine ethik kommission durchgegangen oder also hat er überhaupt 'ne ethik mal drüber geschaut.
Weil es wie poster schon so unerotisch waren oder ob das.
Na weil die forschung die auf den portalen präsentiert wurde also also.
Gesichtserkennung alle irgendwie durchleuchten biomilch daten sammeln und untersuchen und so.
Ja zum beispiel auch einfach methodisch fragwürdige die wollten schlaf analyse mit connect machen und haben halt wollten im prinzip eine vor analyse machen ob ihre ihr system ihr classic feier funktioniert,
was sie gemacht haben ist die drei entwickler haben sich selbst,
unterschiedlichen positionen aufgenommen im stehen,
sie haben sich in einen freien raum frontal gestellt nach links und nach rechts drei personen mit irgendwie zehn wiederholungen,
und haben daran ihren systematischen ansatz validiert und gesagt ja funktioniert der dann auf schlaf analyse und position erkennung im schlaf analyse übertragen werden soll,
stehend.
Ich finde den fehler.
Gleich drei homogen.
Ethik nichts zu tun sondern ist einfach.
Drei drei weiße.
Na aber ethik guckt halt auch auf sowas rüber ja wenn wenn deren methodischen ansatz schon nicht.
Das damit ethik zu tun ist einfach technisch kacke was die da machen.
Na ja aber die ethik prüft ja ob im prinzip dass das was du,
für den einsatz an einem patienten akzeptabel wäre.
Das ist ja ganz klar nicht.
Und diese methodischen ansatz stimmt schon irgendwie vorne und hinten nicht oder was halt vielleicht ganz fancy ist aber so fernsteuerung mit elektroden von tauben,
ohne jetzt irgendwie sinnvoll machen zu können warum das denn jetzt wichtig ist dass die mehrere,
tauben mit elektroden implantieren nur um die dann im kreis rennen zu lassen da finde ich halt auch so die modelle da sollte auch die ethik mal drüber gucken und war zumindest nicht erkennbar dass sie das getan hat,
könnte ich.
Schon ich renne auf die türen mit der einen gleiche podcast ich habe ich den.
Ja ich bin ich bin hell auf begeistert ich werde ihn hören.
Ja ist auch toll der peter ist auch ein ganz großartiger erzähler und erkläre und von daher macht das in jeder hinsicht spaß wie ein podcast nur spaß machen kann rufen sie jetzt die nochmal.
Neben mir.
Eine noch eine spannende technische neuerung es kommen also ich hatte ja schon mal von tiefen stimulation erzählt zum einen habe ich gelernt.
Das muss uns aber nochmal.
Also tiefen hören stimulation sind elektroden die mitten ins gehirn gesteckt werden,
und dann funktioniert das im prinzip wie ein herzschrittmacher areale die nicht mehr so richtig konsistent feuern und hormone produzieren werden angeregt wieder zu feiern.
Durch.
Durchströmt wie ein herzschrittmacher,
genau ähm großes komplexes thema schwierig große invasive maßnahme pipapo,
die die ersten hersteller von tiefen hirn stimulation bringen jetzt systeme mit bluetooth raus sodass du dein handy,
an die tiefen hirn stimulation einheit zum zum einstellen,
nutzen kannst.
What.
Ja ja also äh das dachte ich mir auch dass vor allem software-updates werden wohl automatisch über einen sicheren weg er übertragung auf die systeme gespielt.
Ja will man ja eigentlich auch haben irgendwie.
Auf jeden fall.
Von der menge schief gehen ja wie denn sonst ich meine wenn die alternative ist oft sehr auf einem nicht auf einem sicheren weg zu machen also dann geht das ja schon.
Also ja dieses themen die ich kenne ist ein dürfen glaube ich die einstellung selbst nur ärzte machen und zum anderen werden die halt dran gehalten wie auch bei bei herzschrittmachern also du hast halt so einen kleinen empfänger unter der haut sitzen,
und einen enthält was du dran hältst und dadurch,
passiert die kommunikation aber man könnte es ja jetzt,
mit bluetooth machen über das handy und automatisieren und es ist ja sowieso also es geht jetzt mehr in die richtung die elektroden können nicht nur,
triggern also,
strom aussenden sondern sie können auch die aktivität gleichzeitig messen die neueren das heißt es wird so in die richtung automatisierte optimierte feedback lupe gehofft,
dass man autonome systeme mit also ja in dem patienten baut.
Im patienten.
Ja ja was automatisch also automatisch deine hirn aktivität in bestimmten areal regelt weil sie dafür nicht zu gut sein und sie darf nicht zu schlecht sein und,
das ist halt das ist halt,
ich finde das extrem krass vor allem weil ich jetzt auch gesehen hab es gibt tatsächlich ein rolle das heißt wenn aus irgendwelchen gründen diese elektroden wieder,
rausgenommen werden können müssen ist das lebensbedrohlich,
wenn die elektroden einfach ausfallen und nicht mehr funktionieren.
Weil es so ein gewöhnungszeit sekt schon gegeben hat oder.
Weil die ja weil die im prinzip die erkrankung so schwer ist und nur mit diesen elektroden halbwegs stabil gehalten wird und wenn jetzt aber plötzlich da.
Der hacker kommt und sie abschaltet ist vorbei.
Na dann liegst du im schlimmsten fall katholisch und beatmet im bett und kannst gar nichts machen für ein.
Na ja ich meine jetzt fehlt nur noch die software von irgendwelchen ländern ab mit denen sie die context irgendwie im arsch sind in zwanzig jahren teilst du deine rechnung nicht und sie schalten dich ab solange bis zu zustimmst oder was auch immer.
Ja
Ja also irgendwann geht.
Na wenn sie sich so der kontrolle haben dann können sie sich auch einfach dazu bringen regelmäßig daueraufträge einzurichten.
Ja kein geld das werden sie dir mal schläge vermitteln wenn er nicht schnell genug arbeitest.
Not weil du das jetzt gerade mit dem bluetooth erwähnt hast vielleicht weißt du da was drüber,
hörgeräte haben jetzt doch auch teilweise so die möglichkeit direkt mit dem handy gekoppelt zu werden damit du quasi wenn du telefonierst nicht noch die akustische kopplung hast im prinzip ist das ja quasi sowie,
sowie mode nach der zeit der akustik.
Schon digital reinkommt dann bitte gleich zum hörgerät durchstreichen und nicht erst.
Genau weißt du da irgendwas drüber.
Ne ist nicht mein.
Aber das gibt's doch schon ziemlich lange oder.
Ja es gibt schon eine weile aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt das thema schon paar mal aufgeschrieben aber so richtig da auch nicht den einblick.
Also hören es jetzt auch nicht mehr so bei dir.
Ich bin ich war nur überrascht weil vielleicht habt ihr es mitbekommen,
aufm camp oder war das schon auf dem letzten kongress glaube ich auf dem letzten kongress auch schon so das wusste nämlich auch nicht dass alle hörgeräte sohn empfangs so ein direkt empfang system haben und das war eigentlich in jedem guten konferenz center,
so induktion schleifen ausgelegt hast über die der hallen sound auch übertragen wird so dass du quasi mit einem hörgerät direkt induktive in diese schleifen nicht einklinken kannst.
Also ich weiß nur dass da irgendwie spezielle angebote für hörgerät tragen.
Also ich habe.
Das ist das genau das ist das was ich meine.
Interessanterweise mich mit jemand am wochenende genau über diese sache unterhalten weil er ein koch der implantat hat,
genau das natürlich genutzt hat mit dem streaming.
Camp in hans camp,
und genau und da gab's das zumindest in einem zelt induktive hören lage,
naja und bluetooth ist natürlich an der stelle eigentlich auch ganz interessant weil es da nicht wie für hörgeräte auch die optimale kopplung ist warum warum nicht und bei den implantaten,
es ist ja eigentlich ähnlich da wird's ja im prinzip auch,
sound haben und nicht noch mal den verlust die über die die luft haben,
was war da die.
Wir haben uns im allgemeinen unterhalten und auch so über ein bisschen was kann er über die,
über die app steuern dann zu.
Implantat mit app steuerung.
Na dass das ausmachen kannst oder sache leider.
Ausbauen kannst du einfach den clip sie abnehmen.
Ja aber gezielter steuern das ist ein bisschen runter regelt und sondern und ich glaube auch dass ab schirme von oder war das automatisch drin dass du so nur in eine bestimmte richtung hören kannst total falsch also aber das hinter dir dieses gespräch was hinter dir stattfindet,
dass du das nicht mehr so hörst du noch einen gewissen winkel vor dir wahrnimmst.
Also es gibt es gibt ein ganz spannendes youtube-video von der jessica ich suche den link mal raus die so ein bisschen erklärt wie denn eigentlich sharing los ist das ist ja nicht so dass man,
nur leiser hört,
sondern das ist so dass man teilweise auch zum beispiel noch jedes zweite wort versteht oder dass man nur bestimmte frequenzen hört oder dass dass man einfach mit starken
anderen geräuschkulisse die wörter nicht mehr richtig rausfiltern kann und da ist halt so eine so eine individuelle steuerung welche frequenzen man jetzt haben will oder was,
was genau jetzt die geräusch quelle sein soll.
Glaub ich ganz gut und da ist es halt wirklich,
da bringt das auch da da kann die person selbst auch sehr gut einstellen und einen einschätzen was sie jetzt eigentlich braucht oder was ihr was bei ihr ankommt weil,
da gibt es wenig,
kopplung mechanismen weil selbst wenn jetzt zum beispiel die der gehör verstärker oder das das hörgerät,
bestimmte frequenzen wieder wieder verstärkt heißt es ja nicht dass sie das versteht weil die komplette,
nerven und verarbeitung mechanismus im gehirn kann ja trotzdem nochmal irgendwie komisch und angepasst sein,
dass es nicht richtig verarbeitet wird also das ist glaube ich eine sehr sehr.
Könnt ihr nochmal ganz interessanter trend werde ich für sie hatten wir uns hier schon mal über tinnitus unterhalten.
Oh ja.
Das fällt ja im prinzip auch so ein bisschen so in in diesem bereich also man auf der einen seite hast du halt leute die auf ein gerät angewiesen sind oder bestimmte ausfälle haben die mehr oder weniger klar definiert sind,
oder du hast halt einschränkungen durch das gerät wie bei der implantat weil das ja letzten endes,
direkt in die verstecke reingesteckt ist und da versucht das halt irgendwie zu simulieren umso mehr du halt da unter kontrolle bist kannst du in bestimmte faktoren ausblenden da ist es ja irgendwie alles standard also audio prozess sozusagen standard sowas wie tinnitus,
weiß man ja eigentlich immer noch relativ wenig aber was jetzt für,
fortschritte gemacht haben in den letzten jahren aber was du schon gerade erwähnt hast du die tricks ja glaube ich so eine von diesen,
populären apps keine ahnung ob das wirklich hilft.
Welche sorry.
Teenie tracks.
Also die das prinzip also ich kann jetzt relativ wenig dazu sagen,
wie viel da dran ist aber da es in den letzten jahren nicht weggegangen ist das thema denk ich mal habe ich eine andere ist wahrscheinlich was.
Nicht therapierbar nicht nicht heilbar symptome sind nur sind nur zu lindern.
Denkbar so auf jeden fall ich fasse es jetzt mal ganz leidenschaft zusammen so man muss ja lange zeit nicht was löst das überhaupt aus so,
und mittlerweile schaut man sich relativ,
eigentlich zu sein dass es jetzt keinerlei schwäche des hörsysteme ist sozusagen etwas was im hirn,
stattfindet also das hirn reagiert quasi über und erzeugt dann eben diese schöne,
so und dann hat man halt so experimente gemacht mit was ist denn wenn man jetzt genau diese frequenz bereiche die da so über steuern quasi,
weniger bedient also quasi dem hören so ein liquid leiser vor schaltet und dann einfach bestimmte bereiche ausblendet und das,
habe wohl bei manchen personen gute ergebnisse,
frag ich mich jetzt halt so ich meine ich habe ja auch tinnitus und ich halt immer so gefragt so,
ich nehme ja eigentlich so über mein smartphone relativ viel war für podcasts hört musik lalala,
so aber jetzt irgendwie mir einzelne musik feiern,
umzuwandeln um die dann ab zuspielen sowie ein bisschen geknackt wenn man so ein leiser ja im prinzip auch auf system ebene einblenden könnte also warum kann ich nicht mein telefon.
Wer soll das automatisch machen.
Genau einfach quasi mir so ein profil setzen und sagen so hier ist mein equiliser der das einfach generell macht und diese frequenzen generell herausfiltern und wenn man über meinen kopfhörer wenn ich immer mein kopfhörer höre dann ist es halt alles nicht mehr da.
Tiny tracks arbeitet mit sennheiser zusammen und die ich weiß nicht ob es schon raus ist.
Den kopfhörer rein.
Die machen das in die kopfhörer rein genau oder dass die dass die app im prinzip einen höher profil für die kopfhörer bestimmen kann,
weil das ist ja auch in die muss er individuell angepasst werden was jetzt dein individuelle forscher erhöhter ist und das ist ja ich glaube das machen die in die kopfhörer rein,
und ich weiß nicht ich hau einfach.
Blöder ist eine funktioniert es hat nur mit den kopfhörern.
Ja das ist richtig.
Geknackt weil wir da will ich ein sinn haben noch benutze ich nur ein.
Auf der einen seite könnte man sagen du kannst jetzt alle möglichen geräte mit einem kopfhörer hören auf der anderen seite könnte man sagen ja du machst das einmal mit dem.
Ich stehe jetzt aber.
Alle möglichen kopfhörer benutzen also beides hat vor- und nachteile.
Steht jetzt nicht dass es nur mit denen machen.
Aber wo soll der nachteil sein dass im telefon zu haben.
Vielleicht noch andere geräte hast.
Wie andere geräte was andere.
Nicht nur dein telefon dass da noch andere sachen die sachen abspielen,
ein fernseher den du vielleicht mit kopfhörer hören willst oder was auch immer und dann wäre ein kopfhörer der das alles bedienen kann halt praktisch also jeder hat das so was eine hat viele geräte braucht einen kopfhörer und ein anderer hat ein gerät aber viele kopfhörer oder irgendwie.
Was meinst du ja okay gut ja das ist natürlich ein punkt aber ich fänd's ja gut also ich.
Ich kann das einfach mal alle geräte unterstützen.
Ja ich meine apple könnte das auf jeden fall schon mal auf eine ganze menge geräte bringen,
einfach dieses equiliser profil auch aufm weg und auf dem ipad und auf dem apple tv und so weiter einfach einschalten wenn ein bestimmter kopf voran geschlossen ist schon ganz geil,
aber ich mein wir haben uns daran gewöhnt.
Ja nur wenn ich viel stress hab.
Ich wollt grad sagen bei mir jetzt auch mal gefickt,
mal ein bisschen langsamer machen und dann geht es direkt.
Bei manchen nicht beeilen also es ist gut wenn 's wieder weggeht gibt's halt viele viele unterschiedliche gründe.
Hatten richtig fiesen tinnitus und zwar dachte ich am anfang immer da ist eine lücke im raum,
und dann habe ich nach tagen gemerkt hey ich drehe mein kopf und die mücke dreht sich mit
das ist aber es war nur rechts und da dachte ich äh alles klar das kann keine mücke sein weil ich hab 's auch nicht gefunden in meiner wohnung mit weißen werden weil ich kenne alle möglichkeiten und ja,
aber 'ne mücke ich sag das war wirklich schlimm.
So ich habe die ganze zeit mögen um mich herum und daher ist es halt dass es dass die definition von.
Gibt gezielt unterschiedliche frequenzen.
Also nicht dass es jetzt klingt wie mücken aber es ist.
Ne das war wirklich wie eine mücke so.
Es ist immer was da ja okay gut aber es ist eigentlich okay jeder macht anders sein.
Schlecht ich kann mir auch erst nicht drauf dachte.
Jeder hat so seinen geräusch.
Seine eigene.
Wir wollen ein bisschen über sex reden oder weil es stand im da müssen wir auch machen oder.
Ja kann man machen wenn taler durch ist.
Ich kann noch ganz kurz über mein windows gerät lästern oder mein leid klang weil dann habt ihr habt.
Was heißt über den windows du meinst über den pc hat er das windows hat er damit nichts zu tun.
Ja ich weiß na ja es ist ein windows gerät.
Na du könntest ja auch ein richtiges betrieb sind.
Kannst du auch.
Nicht am betriebssystem es liegt primär am gerät.
Wenn du es hat das nichts zu tun also mögen vielleicht apple fan boys.
Beschreibung richtig.
Apple fans sein und windows becher aber in diesem fall hat das windows keine schuld.
Nee an diesem sondern schuld ist dass es ein nischenprodukt habe wo es noch keine
also problem ist ich musste bei meinem kleinen süßen geliebten zweitausendsechzehn mal wieder die
ich hab's jetzt halt seit zweitausendsechzehn,
letztes jahr schon einmal getauscht die damals mit garantie jetzt ist die batterie wieder geplättet gewesen und musste ausgebaut werden,
nach äh diversen hin und her mit razer hieß es am ende nach diversen e-mails ja ach übrigens ist doch kein garantie fall mehr,
du könntest das jetzt für summe x einschicken und dann würde noch mal austauschen temperatur extra kosten und ich dachte so ne,
und war halt irgendwie auf der suche nach einer batterie für das gerät hersteller eins kam aus china dann nach etwas umwegen falsche batterie gesendet wieder zurück andere hersteller,
jetzt habe ich eine china batterie nicht mit einem e-kennzeichen sondern eine cd kennzeichen,
was super funktioniert nur irgendwie ein millimeter zu dick ist so dass ich so lang,
es wirkt und also die das das metall wirbt ist also immer noch keine optimale lösung aber ich hab nach fast zwei monaten endlich wieder ein laptop mit einer benutzbar batterie das ist ja.
Kannst du mit dem ding fliegen.
Ist so ein problem für so ein teil der batterie zurück.
Ja anscheinend schon weil das halt so ein nischenprodukt ist.
Aber ihre tasten leuchten also einzeln das ist ganz wichtig.
Ich kann über meine meine farben auf der tastatur.
Nein es glitzert es funkelt.
Ja ich kann sogar.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Also keine funktionierende batterie aber funktionierende tasse.
Ich habe jetzt eine.
Hast du ist das ist das ein bisschen fitter oder hast du das programmiert.
Nee das ist tatsächlich implementiert aber es gibt ein für diese tasse also razer stellt.
Gamer sachen.
Ja mechanische tastaturen die auch dieses feature haben und es gibt eine dafür und ich hab vor drei jahren oder so 'ne steuerung,
dafür testweise angebaut so dass halt meine hände im prinzip über display geschwebt haben und sich dann daraufhin auf dem über der tastatur geschwebt haben und daraufhin hat sich dann die farbe auf der tastatur geändert,
es kann man.
Es gibt ja so so so autos diese unterbunden licht nähern rühren unterm auto haben und damit durch die stadt fahren motorradfahrer gibt's auch die sowas haben und und teile hat das halt auf ihrem.
Wie heißen diese leute nochmal.
Oh nein.
Nein die leute die sollte so so lampen und am auto haben da gibt's noch einen namen für ne da gibt's da gibt's irgendwie speziell für diese tour.
Keine ahnung ich bin da nicht drin in der zehnten.
Ich nichts auto.
Du nichts auto aber du tastatur auf jeden fall,
sarah auf jeden fall total fans hier aus ich bin ein bisschen neidisch auf wenn's jetzt nicht unbedingt so ist dass das jetzt äh total verbessern aber ich hätte das ganze geld für mein ipad also ich hatte überhaupt.
Du hast keine tastatur doch das erste tor.
Ja ich hätte gerne beleuchtet das hast du für meine ipad weil.
Also.
Ich hätte gerne ein.
Ich will nichts sagen aber diese ipad tastatur die ich von logik gekauft habe die hat mir natürlich ist die beleuchtet die ist auch noch beleuchtet.
Noch beleuchtet okay dann muss ich mir die kaufen ist jetzt ist alles vorbei.
Klick.
Es ist alles ok.
Ich war ja am anfang nicht so richtig sicher ob die tastatur cool ist weil sie das ipad was ja sehr leicht ist sehr schwer macht.
Ich kann meinen eigenen erfindet link jetzt anklicken hier auf der webseite bringt zwar nichts aber ich kann 's trotzdem machen.
Diese tiny tracks von sennheiser das nochmal schnell nach weil du mal jetzt ist ob das schon gibt oder eine ankündigung da steht seit zweitausenddreizehn machen die das schon.
Da stehen ja auch die.
Oben einer gut usa russland und deutschland her.
Also sie ist bei den auf der seite sind die für die neurologischen,
erkrankungen mit aufgelistet.
Ja nein mein razer ist toll er hat keine,
ist immer noch toll funktioniert der.
Es könnte sein dass die elektronik die batterie auflegt dass die einfach scheiße.
Ich vermute eher dass es dass das gerät ein bisschen zu heiß wird und dadurch die batterie laufzeit einfach verkürzt.
Du sollst da nicht auf dem sofa laden.
Tue ich nicht ich benutze es nein.
Nicht auf eine heiz matte oder auf auf den anderen part two den rechner draufsteht was.
Sein tischtennis.
Gott stellt sogar smartphones.
Ja ja also ich.
Aber keine akkus.
Na ja keine ahnung zumindest komme ich nicht nicht nicht sinnvoll ran also vielleicht hätte ich auch einfach aus den usa irgendwie importieren müssen aber hier in europa gab's halt nur dubiose chinesische anbieter,
wo ist halt für irgendwie ja lenovo sowieso aber auch für die ganzen details und so da ist halt einfach der markt viel größer und da kriegt man einfach 'nen zumindestens sauberen shop wo man einfach die,
die batterien kaufen kann aber ja so die probleme habt ihr mit euren weg nicht.
Nee wir haben ganz andere probleme in unserem,
was hast du denn für probleme mit deinem mac dennis was hast du das neue us installiert,
katharina ließ es sich installieren,
zyklus mitgemacht oder.
Ich habe den beta zirkus mitgemacht da ist aber nicht so viel passiert hat mich jetzt aber auch nicht so ganz tief da rein gebaggert habt einfach genutzt und da war jetzt nichts anders äh,
wollte gestern abend an das richtige installieren das ging dann irgendwie nicht,
und dann muss ich das beta irgendwie einmal ausschalten dann hat er keine updates mehr angebot und viel mehr sein ja alles klar der denkt jetzt mehr oder weniger irgendwie wieder dass ich halt noch die vor version hab und da musst du in den store gehen und musst einmal sagen ich will das neue us haben weil das ist ja sozusagen kein update sondern dass er einmal,
was neues und dann hat er sich installiert aber das war alles nur wegen der peter geschichte das heißt ich bin das ganz normal installieren kann und ich habe jetzt hier die version nummer,
eine stufe neuer als irgendwo anders gelesen hab und zwar neunzehn a fünf acht drei mal woanders war fünf acht zwo aber euch jetzt nochmal so gesagt haben,
in einer zahlen vergleichen will.
Äh was soll ich denn hier.
Ne aber sonst geht es erstmal.
Neunzehn a fünf acht drei habe ich.
Ja okay dann ist es wahrscheinlich die person die da raus kommt irgendwer meinte die version des fünf acht zwo a.
Was soll ja die die die golden master war also sie haben das release war nochmal.
Einmal einmal nee sonst habe ich hier noch gar nichts gemacht das was man merken würde wäre wenn man ja sein i phone jetzt hier im backup machen will weil das ja in den feinen ausgelagert ist ich mach das aber nicht auf meinem laptop sondern zu hause auf meinem,
ich habe keinen bock mein backup mit mir rum zu schleppen wenn das besser als wenn das bei meinem rechner zuhause drauf ist und sonst hier keine ahnung,
läuft jetzt tom tom zum beispiel nicht mehr weil die zu blöde bande vierundsechzig bitte application rauszuhauen deswegen gibt's jetzt keinen tom tom home mehr.
Das ist tom tom.
Tom tom ist der navi hersteller für navigationsgerät zum beispiel auch für motorräder,
da gibt's so 'ne app mit der du in die neuesten karten auf dein navigationsgerät weis überladen kannst und das ist eh schon so in java programmiert nehme ich mal an und das ist irgendwie immer noch zweiunddreißig bitte,
und aktuell hier läuft 's auf meinem auf dem katharina hier nicht ich hoffe ich sag jetzt nichts falsches hier aber er will nicht starten,
sonst,
habe ich jetzt nicht so tief geschaut.
Ich habe dumm gefragt so wie das mit dem update aussieht äh für katharina weil also wenn ich eins gelernt habe über die letzten jahre dass man die finger davon lässt in der ersten zeit ein update zu machen als.
Komm ja genau.
Als oder generell als.
Irgendwas benutzt dann immer so ein bisschen warten selbst aber nicht auf die punkt eins warten will also so zwei drei tage kann ja jeder aushalten,
und da könnt ihr nochmal was kommen oder man hört hier ganz zehn prozent ist beim installieren ging das nicht oder so gab es ja schon irgendwann mal
und wenn man die drei tage abwarten,
wenn einer natürlich sowieso voll der hacker und nervös und nur dem ding rum spielt und spaß daran hat sowieso alles herauszufinden der muss natürlich gleich sofort so früh wie geht weil das sind ja genau die leute die rausfinden das was nicht.
Genau er hat 's auch auf seinem test rechner drauf und meinte halt so dass die entwicklung der komplett,
noch kaputt ist ein krampf überhaupt irgendwas zu installieren ist dann erwartet natürlich alle alle zweiunddreißig apps sind jetzt raus unter anderem c sechs,
weiß ich nicht ich bin ja so lange schon nicht mehr auf dem adobe kram guck mal wie wie alt es ist.
Ja manchmal auch im chat fünf geht nicht mehr irgendwann sechs nicht geht na.
Ich weiß nicht was kreatives.
Ich bin auf jeden fall.
Scheinbar ist es.
Das ist das wichtigste feature was ich eigentlich so im sinn hatte ausgerechnet auf meinem rechner gar nicht läuft.
Wollte seid kabel nutzen mit seinem neueste ipad pro richtig und zwar mit seinem nicht neuesten.
Das ist das neueste neueste das neueste macbook was geiles.
Was geiles aber jetzt nicht gab 's nicht mehr danach noch neues macbook achso okay also du hast das das geilste aber nicht neueste macbook er und das unterstützt auf jeden fall dieses zeit irgendwie nicht.
Ne das unterstützt mein macbook ehrlich,
so rum ist es doch ja.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob das so rum ist dann steht da irgendwo was die anforderungen sind also was genau das problem ist war oft wird das herausgefunden dass sie sagen ok folgende rechner gehen nicht mehr weil die cdu unterstützt irgendwie tomic shops irgendwo trallala nicht oder weiß oder irgendwelche virtual features nicht.
Mittel kann naja.
Ja aber ähm deswegen vergleich was hat was ist denn bei.
Ich habe keine ahnung also ich meine es ist macbook pro seit zwanzig sechzehn also quasi die neun die scheiße teil also mit scheiße tastatur und mit irgendwie,
die gehen angeblich macbook pro ab zwanzig sechzehn macbook ab zwanzig sechzehn macbook er.
Kann es wirklich sein dass es an diesem an diesem diesen tee eins oder wie er heißt.
Keine ahnung make-up zwanzig sechzehn und eine kritik von pro klar,
ab zwanzig achtzehn der neue halt und der und der max und der pro,
nur hier steht nur mit pro.
Ja da ja ähm der alte frau von katharina nicht unterstützt wird kann's ja nur der neuere sein.
Ja aber die tonne aber denn die tonne hat aber kein zweites.
Eins ne okay dann ist es vielleicht wirklich dass es irgendwie so eine wlan geschichte ist dass sie für die kommunikation und wie so ein eigenen channel aufmachen.
Ja aber das ist ja hemd auf das gibt's ja gibt's ja auch auf meinem sehr drop quasi.
Ja okay was hätten wir noch dann irgendwie grafikkarte irgendwie was.
Ja ist ja weniger ein problem der grafikkarte grafikkarten haben ja beide.
Na ja kommt drauf an was ihr davon stream übertragen ist dass äh pixel genau oder ist das hier auch so 'n xt also so ein zeug,
also weil sonst wären die pur die ganzen daten übertragen wir müssen ja auch ein bisschen weg komprimieren wobei das machen sie mit diesem apple tv,
play machen sie ja auch schon eigentlich nur das kann das ding ja auch ne dann ist mir dann ist mir nicht so klar was das für eine.
Weiß auch nicht vielleicht ist es.
Leistung vielleicht dein ding ist ja nun mal nicht so schnell oder.
Na komm ja nichts gegen mein er mein erst geil.
Aber es kann kein zeit kam.
Zeit gar kann man eher nicht so rum ja so muss man.
Ja ja so kann man sich auch schön reden.
Ja sorry ich würde ich hätte ja gerne in den letzten zehn jahren viele max gerne gekauft wenn's welche gegeben hätte.
Wie geil werden.
Die geil werden aber das ist er ist einfach der letzte der sich nur verbessert hatte und seitdem ist halt essig aber apple sorry ich kaufe nix ohne escape tasse.
Ja ich habe das ja nicht so gehandelt wie du und das ist ja was jetzt hier von scheiß habe.
Der ist doch völlig völlig völlig bekloppt.
Soll der kacke was wirklich.
Ich will es cap tasse ich will eine ordentliche tastatur haben an meinem computer.
Ich würde mal sagen das ist die geilste technische hardware in der schlechtesten hülle,
also cdu geil bildschirm geil alles geil aber diese tastatur und so und das es ein bisschen zu mega dünn ist glaube ich das ist,
nee geht nicht so gut aber das hat man schon wir wollen ja nicht über über wie sagt man,
alte.
Doch darüber muss man einfach reden ja also.
Immer wieder reden ja immer drauf auf die wunde.
Ich will es einfach nur nochmal zum besten geben ich halte immer noch aus so und jetzt habe ich die absurde situation ist dass sie in so einer situation nochmal kommen also ich besitze tatsächlich derzeit eins zwei,
drei vier fünf,
einer davon steht allerdings grade im regal weil ich den rest für den grad noch keinen platz hab aber das wird sich ändern.
Ja ich weiß du bist eine aufräumen phase.
Ist das nicht so anklage denn.
Du hilfst ja nicht immer nur hierher und ist eine pizza ja.
Dein büro was weiß ich wo du dein zeug eingeräumt haben willst.
Na ich brauche immer hilfe tala auf jeden fall,
die große mehrheit also drei von diesen max und einfach zu alt für das neueste betriebssystem zwei davon sind sogar schon zu alt für das
bisherige habe schon ja also ich habe zwei die laufen jetzt unter heiß ja einer hängt jetzt in woche habe fest dann ist regal und dann habe ich mein macbook und das kann irgendwie nicht mehr alle features,
soweit ist es.
Das kann doch katharina ja denn er.
Ja aber es kann halt schon features nicht es kann halt das halt nicht und das heißt ich hab halt nicht das volle paket.
Und du solltest unbedingt haben oder wolltest du einfach nur mal austesten.
Ich sehe da durchaus anwendung weil weil ich hab mein mein ipad,
weil das schon sehr attraktiv ist und manchmal finde ich so zweiter also was weiß ich so kleine präsentation machen und gibt es schon so verschiedene situationen wo ich mir das ganz praktisch vorstellen kann
und ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht so drauf geschaut dass dafür auch noch mindestanforderungen gab dachte naja gott schalten sie ein.
Dass wir das nicht mitbekommen hast weil das ist das worüber ich mich eher sofort geärgert habe weil das hat dumm glaube ich noch an dem tisch gesagt so meinte das funktioniert nicht auf,
auf deinem weil dumm hat den anmeldung ich glaube wir hatten drei zehn oder fünfzehn zoll macbook wie du hast dennis und als screen halten,
und das war so für mich so geil dieses ipad ist dann so vielseitig einsetzbar will ich unbedingt ipad das ipad.
Kann das auch nicht.
Aber mein macbook kann es auch nicht.
Hast du nicht auch so ein flaches ding.
Das flache ding war von meiner arbeit von meiner damaligen und die wollten natürlich dieses flache macbook wiederhören.
Und da sind auch gerne gegeben was hat er keine.
Schafft ihr das sehr gerne zurückgegeben.
Den scheiß.
Ja mein alter chef hat ja auch das ding am liebsten aus dem fenster werfen wollen weil er so unzufrieden war.
Ja aber jetzt ist wieder geil weil jetzt kein zeit karl es wird es wieder haben.
Jetzt habe ich halt keinen zweiten also das ist halt eine sache die ich dann nicht verstehe so ich will ja nicht die übertragung haben von stift auch also das wäre mir halt wurscht aber wenigstens als screen zu benutzen finde ich irgendwie schon nice,
außerdem mein rechner ist zwar ein bisschen älter aber er tut halt noch verdammt gut und ich sehe auch nicht ein da jetzt schon wieder zweieinhalbtausend oder wahrscheinlich ist man jetzt eher so weit dreieinhalbtausend für neues macbook mal eben auszugeben,
ich bin ich nicht so nicht so verschwenderisch sein.
Also ich denke mal die,
weil wir ja fast überhaupt aus der zeit gar nichts neues erwähnt haben von diesem katharina da steckt schon noch ein bisschen was dahinter also wir haben jetzt auch sonst nicht da nichts gemacht aber ich denke wir können in den nächsten sachen immer wieder sachen finden was wir so
erzählen was wir so gefunden haben einen neuen features und da ist wahrscheinlich auch 'ne menge leute gibt die eben wie hocke auch und und du ja auch noch nicht noch nicht installiert haben und noch sozusagen auf gründe warten warum denn das geiles oder dann zumindestens hören können dass es jetzt noch nicht
ganz schlimmes wie wir alle behaupten dass man sehr installieren und benutzen kann.
Genau ich muss damit arbeiten können weil ansonsten hätte ich schon längst installiert weil du hast ja auch das problem wobei ähm für mich ist es nicht ganz so sehr ein problem wenn du auf deinen ids oder ipad us geräten die neueste variante von ipad,
von diesem dreizehnter us benutzt,
kommt er auch häufig der hinweis so hey schön und gut dass du jetzt hier dieses äh fancy neue feature ich glaube bei den reminder es nutzt
aber mindestens eins deiner geräte ist noch nicht gearbeitet und das würde ich halt schon ganz gerne nutzen also bei den apple notes fällt's mir zum glück nicht auf
da scheint alles auch noch zu funktionieren,
und das hab ich bisher nicht genutzt aber ich weiß nicht ich bin halt schon in dieser apple integration auch ein bisschen gefangen mit der cloud,
also ich komme ohne apple notes nicht mehr klar,
da ist mein leben halt einfach dahin.
Gefangen in der cloud.
Fang in der eine klar.
Lost insel cloud.
Lasten der cloud.
Ja so ging es schon eine geile sache wenn's funktioniert.
Ja vor allen dingen wenn man jetzt wirklich so scheiße viele geräte von von diesem apfel.
Ja das weiß ich ja noch nicht.
Wie sieht denn jetzt apple music.
Es ist wieder verwandte immer geil war aber er wurde immer älter und immer mehr grumpy und jetzt ist man froh dass er beerdigt wurde.
Oder kannst du es mal nicht drauf was.
Ne das kannst du zurück.
Schneiden wir raus.
Ich dachte du redest von dir.
Ich ne ich habe gesagt der entfernte verwandte.
Das ist wieder der entfernte.
Der ne entfernt oder nicht was sondern der verwandte oder bekannte der voll cool war aber mit den jahren wurde immer älter und immer mehr grumpy und dann ist er jetzt gestorben und das ist eigentlich ganz.
Ach ich war grad nochmal fragen was hast du ja ich bin gespannt ich meine aber ähm benutzt du evil music,
okay weil das aber du benutzt apple music und das ist nett oder schön oder gut oder.
Ich bin erstaunt darüber dass ich tatsächlich wieder angefangen habe mehr musik zu hören deswegen ich habe damit nicht unbedingt gerechnet aber es ist so.
Oh da bin ich gespannt weil man auch mehr musik wieder entdeckt.
Ja also einfach diese,
dieses man kann auf alles sofort also alles ist in,
das meiste so was man so hört zugreifen,
und kann schnell in so ein recherche modus kommen und schnell einfach mal so ein paar sachen reingehen und sich auch irgendwas mal wieder hoch holen was man schon so ein bisschen vergessen hatte und.
Früher.
Ja aber ist halt deutlich einfacher als paradies.
Ja und legal vor allem.
Legal und irgendwie auch komfortabler und pipapo also zum beispiel ich hatte doch neulich hier heute vorgestellt ne diese geile techno martin band und,
es geht mir immer noch nicht aus dem ohr und irgendwie tagelang da sagt nur leute gehört und moto moto moto moto und dann haben sie irgendwie jetzt noch ein paar singles rausgebracht,
wir haben schon mittlerweile so ein repertoire von ungefähr so fünfzehn songs oder so richtig große aber nicht gezeigt,
und dann wurde mir irgendwie nochmal klar dass das ja alles cover sind.
Hast du die originale.
Und dann habe ich mir so eine playlist gemacht und natürlich waren alle gecovert songs halt
auch verfügbar und hab da so 'ne playlist gehabt wo ich dann immer das original und dann die meute variante immer abwechselnd gehört habe dann habe ich das irgendwie gehört dann kann ich natürlich dann auch wieder da wieder auf andere sachen und auf einmal los in music,
ich war los in musik so ne und,
ja so bin ich auf ein paar ganz geile sachen gestoßen auf die ich sonst halt irgendwie so nicht gestoßen wäre und mittlerweile finde ich das irgendwie eine wertvolle ressource und das ist dann sozusagen auch mir das geld insofern wert weil es halt
immer noch deutlich weniger ist als man ausgeben würde wenn man.
Das ist alles kaufen.
Das kaufen würde zehner.
Also hundert im jahr jan zehner im monat oder ein hunderter im jahr.
Genau oder du machst halt family pack dann hast du irgendwie fuffzig prozent mehr.
Es klingt halt genau nach dem was ich mit spotify.
Das ist genau dasselbe.
Ja also exakt gleiches phänomen ich hab damals im studium halt dieses fünfer fünfer monat abo quasi abgeschlossen und soll immer noch fünf euro für ohne werbung und,
so viel wie eigentlich noch nie in meinem leben musik entdeckt weil ich irgendwie,
immer nur von anderen personen mal so einzelne sachen sonst kennengelernt haben jetzt aktiv.
Im chat wird nochmal korrekt darauf hingewiesen es gibt tatsächlich eine bitte version von apple music im web was im wesentlichen genauso aussieht ob es wie die app übrigens weil du gerade fragt das wir das.
Ja das ist genau das genau das hab ich mir grade gewünscht das zu sehen da schon mal reinzuschauen in der tat weil,
na aber mir geht es jetzt also ich fand halt itunes bis zum letzten update,
nicht wirklich bedienbar was apple music angeht dann habe ich musik ausschließlich über das telefon,
und seid wahrscheinlich noch habe dass man es überhaupt bedienen kann aufm aufm weg
und mir ist halt schon da aufgefallen so ich habe irgendwie total viele alte sachen mir wieder angehört so von früher als ich wo wir zusammen auf konzerten waren dann irgendwie andere alte bands wiedergefunden und das ist halt schon wahnsinnig geil
ich meine das was dir halt präsentiert wird das jetzt ausschließlich eher so der poppiger bereich
ja gut ich hoffe dass das schneidet sich dann auch so ein bisschen auf das was man hört zu nicht dass man hier diese ganze klicke bunte sachen ständig damit genervt wird.
Wenn ihr es itunes weg ist und nicht mehr irgendwie vertrieben wird äh wie kriege ich jetzt musik,
als mp drei auf mein mobiles endgerät oder ipod schaffen welche app.
Das ist jetzt hier im feinde integriert und die synchronisiert jon musste dann.
Was hast du das selbe u sein da facebook vor in itunes hast hast du jetzt im finale.
Ja dass ich für mein windows gerät glaube ich kein feinde habe.
Na da wird 's weiter.
Also der findus ist alles gleich da gibt's nach wie vor nur itunes das wird sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht ändern solange bis sie wenn es komplett aufgeben,
also ich finde es ja schon ein bisschen ärgerlich dass man irgendwie nicht ein ipod nehmen kann und da apple music kram drauf ballern kann,
weil ein ganzes jahr noch weiter hören nicht mehr bezahlt ja gott macht halt drauf oder was weiß ich,
also wenn man die musik klauen willkommen die sich sowieso relativ einfach klauen gibt's irgendwie passende.
Rechts geschichten und so wahrscheinlich.
Ist ein bisschen albern und was mich auch noch total nervt muss mal gucken ob sich das jetzt irgendwie geändert hat das ist halt immer wieder so was ich hasse dj mixer schmeißen deine deine mediathek rein,
willst du es auch gesund bekommen also ja ist zu lang oder er ist zu groß ist scheiß drauf irgendwie.
Ey das ist so nervig ich habe.
Zahl hier für terabyte cloud jeden monat denn warum könnt ihr nicht das fucking teil da reinschmeißen ich meine.
Das versteh ich auch nicht.
Also ist das nervt.
Weil sie mit deinen daten keinen druck machen können.
Ja aber wo ist denn der unterschied ob ich jetzt dreißig songs oder,
eine datei aus dreißig songs da reinwerfen ist doch genau derselbe speicherplatz.
So na weil sie denken dass die kleinen songs halt hunderttausend fach bei den anderen auch liegen.
Weil sie denken.
Weil sie noch nie ein richtig gutes langes musik sets scheinbar vor sich gehabt haben.
Ja weil es einfach amerikaner sind die einfach keine ahnung haben von dj kultur sorry ich werd schon wieder rassistisch.
Wir haben so bin ich sehr viel zu sagen der junge ist aufgefallen.
Ne gibt's ja auch erst seit jetzt gerade kann man auch nicht so viel sagen muss erst mal gucken.
Ist euch aufgefallen wie sauber das hier im studio ist ne dachte ich mir schon aber mir weil ich nämlich mal rum wahrgenommen habe und den hier mal irgendwie durchs studio gejagt habe weil man kommt.
Ach so ja doch am boden ist ein bisschen sauber jetzt wo ich hingucken man kann tatsächlich die maserung wiedersehen.
Maserung so dreckig war's nun wirklich hier nicht ist es wahrheit.
Leist übertrieben.
Ja sehr leise sehr sehr sehr leicht.
Das kann man auch in socken hier rumlaufen.
Ja barfuß auch kannst du von frühstücken.
Also ein kumpel von mir,
ich hatte auch mal einen rumba und ich gucke erstmal was andere leute mit ihrer technik machen bevor ich da auch einsteigen ne bevor ich äh genau geld ausgebe für gadgets und da hab ich schon gesehen hat das war voll begeistert guck mal hier es macht alles sauber so wie du jetzt auch und dann hätte ihn,
reinigen müssen den rumba waren natürlich schon so faul ist auch immer hängen geblieben an irgendwelchen ecken da waren auch zuvor im see zu kümmern und dann hat er den anderen kumpel
der das gleiche dachte dass er damit du deine bude schön sauber kriegt und der hatte genau das gleiche wohl und die haben dann geschwärmt dann von den rum was die sich selber entleeren können an so einer station die ist inzwischen ja sogar gibt
aber dann musst du halt auch die station irgendwann sauber machen also die so richtig ist es nicht so dass das problem,
dass man nichts mehr machen muss dass die bude sauber ist dass geburt einfach nicht nie geben.
Sagt die falsche erwartungshaltung.
Ja das haben die leute aber natürlich.
Ja klar aber es ist nicht meine.
Echt nicht okay sondern.
Na so ein rumba macht etwas was du selber nicht machen kannst,
er nimmt einfach staub weg,
wo du gar keinen mehr siehst also den einfach mit einem besen nicht weg bekommst und wo du in dieser akribisch staubsauger niemals hinterher sein würdest also ich hab detail jetzt hier eine woche lang wirklich am laufenden.
Nass aber hoch weggenommen oder.
Mal hin mal weg ich hab die mit alles ist ja irgendwie mal sauber gemacht worden und natürlich kann ich noch dadurch dass wir noch mehr zeug verschwindet kabel noch hoch gelegt werden und so weiter kann ich ja noch einiges verbessern
mittelfristig will ich hier die situation schaffen die quasi so rum war freundlich ist oder da mal roboter staubsauger um es mal ein bisschen allgemeiner zu halten dass ich mir ein modell kaufen wäre es jetzt hier quasi so
der kommt von woanders weil ich mir nur ausgeliehen,
der kann auch nicht regelmäßig programmiert werden dass er irgendwie regelmäßig loswerden aber genau das wäre halt das ding man sagt so hier jeden tag,
um was weiß ich nachts um fünf wenn ihr einfach nichts mehr garantiert nichts mehr los ist im studio,
dann eier hast du hier einfach durch und nimmst den scheiß raus.
Und du musst die tür zu machen wahrscheinlich dass so 'ne schwelle.
Erkennt er treppen und so weiter könnt ihr alles wir haben da so sensoren und so weiter die bleiben da dabei stehen das ist gar nicht so das problem,
das durchaus funktioniert und wenn man halt so ein bisschen sein boden regime im griff hat dass man nicht so viele rumstehen halbzeit schwierig mit den stühlen das geht ja nicht darum dass immer alles perfekt,
clean ist das geht darum dadurch dass wenn das teil oft regelmäßig rüber läuft,
und ich hab mir halt immer angeguckt so okay nach diesem durchlauf wie viel scheiße ist jetzt noch drin am anfang war das halt viel viel viel viel viel irgendwann was er selber weniger sagt mir so okay ist wahrscheinlich nichts mehr zu holen,
und dann kam das teil immer wieder mit so einem fusseln paket nach hause wo ich mir dachte so.
Tschüss.
Ja geil irgendwie so und das das macht so ein bisschen den den unterschied weil es ist halt irgendwie auch das was räume so so so unangenehm machen.
Seid voll,
gilt oder wahrscheinlich die meisten roboter killt sind halt lange haare da bist du dann halt wirklich am fluchen.
Aber ich dachte der saugt noch eine seine rollen bleiben wir dran hängen.
Die rollen genau dasselbe wie.
Kleinen dreh schraubt und wenn sich dann langes haar ein rollt sie sollen wohl aber ganz gut zu reinigen sein also muss halt dann die bürsten.
Ja man flucht halt trotzdem ohne ende genau also es ist halt für langhaarige menschen so ein bisschen so ein machst halt was anderes danach sauber nicht mehr den boden sondern den rumba sehen aber.
In meinem wohnzimmer liegt so viel kram auf dem boden rum da durchstecken nachher alles weg.
Der baut sich selbst weiter mit dem zeug was da drum liegt.
Der wahrscheinlich.
So warum ich das eigentlich erwähnt habe also den chat kommt schon die vermutung ich habe mir einen staubsauger roboter gekauft das nicht richtig hat mir die nicht gekauft sein ich habe den hier benutzt und ich habe aber darüber nachgedacht was denn wohl der richtige roboter staubsauger für mich wäre weil es gibt ja nicht nur rumba sondern es gibt ja auch diverse andere hersteller unter anderem halt das teil von makita
da kommt nicht in frage weil es mir ein bisschen zu teuer und da ist mir vor allem auch ein bisschen zu hoch also so ein,
es ist ziemlich dick und fett der kann zwar 'ne menge einsammeln aber der geht dann wiederum nicht so gut unter,
niedrige dinge drunter etcetera und ich wollte eigentlich nur mal so in die runde fragen ob ihr den sozusagen von anderen modellen und herstellern,
irgendwie wisst die da noch in frage kommen es gibt ja mittlerweile sogar von schaue und irgendwie.
Wally.
Von volley gibt's auch ein.
Der perfekte staubsauger roboter.
Ja so volleyball natürlich ganz gut ne,
so was ist ja der bernd im chat ein roboter rock es fünf oder sechs robo rock habe ich zum beispiel noch überhaupt nicht gehört,
genau kann man ohne cloud betreiben ja das ist ja auch wieder das andere ding dass sie irgendwie anfangen damit maschine learning und pipapo.
Ja ja das glaubst du auch selber nicht mit der maschine learning.
Die lippen die lippen die räume.
Rheuma und laden es hoch irgendwie zum lernen damit sie ihre maschinen learning besser hinkriegen.
Übrigens 'ne kommerzielle variante von dem wifi bewegungsdrang der wird inzwischen für medizinische studien eingesetzt und die nehmen.
Der durch die wand durchgeht.
Ja der durch die wand durchgeht und die nehmen raum daten vorher zum meppen von der räumlichkeit,
und hatten durch zufall größere datensätze am rumliegen,
wieso wieso häuser aufgebaut sind,
da war glaube ich die vermutung dass die zum beispiel von so einem rumba komm oder generell von von staubsauger meetings.
Ja also mal ganz abgesehen von der von dieser rein überwachungs problematik,
frage ich mich halt was eigentlich am geilsten ist weil ich habe mit diesem robert schon mehrfach rum experimentiert und ein problem also ist ja auch erstaunlich wie viele haare überhaupt in seiner wohnung sind,
also man denkt ja okay hier und da sind mal so haare oder so aber das war so ein roma durch die wohnung laufen.
Als langjähriger mensch der ein bisschen mehr haare verliert.
Die letzte hier liegt hier rum.
Also ich hasse das halt wie die pest bei mir zuhause ist es ich sehe das immer wieder.
Wenn man es eingesaugt bekommt ist es ja auch alles in ordnung das problem ist so ein rumba also mit diese günstigen modelle die haben ja noch so 'ne bürste,
so so dreh bürste die neuen haben alle so gummi wählen da könnte es ein bisschen anders sein,
aber diese bürsten da schlingen sich dann die haare halt so richtig drum herum das heißt wenn das ding rein ist dann kannst du eigentlich erstmal mit einer schere kommen und die sozusagen der länge nach aufschneiden damit überhaupt eine chance hast diese ganzen haare.
Aber sie geben dir dieses ding sie mit dass du das so eine so ein sauber macht teil wo dann die klinge dran das,
ja das sollte eigentlich bei dem rumba dazugeben.
Vielleicht später dazu gelegt was auf jeden fall,
ist es an sich ein problem und man fragt sich halt so kann man das vielleicht anders lösen warum haben wir kein laser zum beispiel man könnte ja dann auch gleich stinkt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu sehr ne ja.
Haare anzünden ist nicht für empfehlen.
Nee.
Laser könnte man sich auch einfach so.
Da da steht's eigentlich schon aber ein guter nebeneffekt von robert saubern man wird zur ordnung erzogen genau man fängt davon dafür alle also man fängt an seinen boden sauber zu halten damit er sich frei bewegen kann.
Genau freiheit für die roboter,
und das ist ein interessanter nebeneffekt unfall man fängt an seine kabel besser zu verlegen und überhaupt,
so ja aber ich hätte jetzt gerne irgendwas tolles was mir zum beispiel diesen robers irgendwie so ein bisschen wundert und das scheint auch bei diesem roboter rock da zu sein die haben ja dann immer so diese diese dreh bürsten und davon haben die dann immer nur eine,
ich muss mich halt auch fragt warum eigentlich eine also ich meine guck mal auf die straße wenn da die lang fährt die haben auch zwei also schiebst du es immer von links und.
Ja weil sonst wäre ich ja auch die batterie zu schnell leer wäre.
Ach die batterie zu schnell wäre da kann sich da hinstellen laden und das wetter zehn minuten später wieder weiter der soll den scheiß staub aufsammeln und das ich guck den teil dann irgendwie zu ich meine es auch sehr kontemplativen also seinen eigenen roboter,
irgendwie aber hab ich halt gemacht.
Arbeite.
Und,
das ding hat einfach die ganze zeit gebracht das immer auf irgendwie auf so dreck zugefahren ist oder mit diesem einen wedel detail einfach auf die andere seite geschossen hat,
ich denke so fährt man vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken soll warum nicht halt mit so zwei wedeln das vorne dann irgendwie so rein kanalisieren und da so
philips macht das zum beispiel also diese philipp staubsauger roboter die im prinzip alle demselben prinzip folgendes sie also ein rundes eisen was durch die gegend eiert so aber die haben im prinzip genau dieses konzept deswegen habe ich da,
schon mit geliebäugelt aber ich bin ganz weit davon entfernt mich für irgendwas entschlossen zu haben und deswegen würde ich jetzt ganz gerne mal die community,
doch mit uns eure erfahrung zu teilen was soll es sein ja.
Bist du ein eva gänge.
Ich war da tatsächlich auf den letzten ifa ich finde.
Aber genau für sowas ist gut.
Wieso kann man da sein schmutz mitnehmen.
Hab ich mir tatsächlich so vorgestellt also es gibt auf jeden fall genug saugt roboter die da frei rumlaufen und dann kannst du so dein.
Früher früher ist der staubsauger vertreter zu dir nach hause gekommen und hat der dreck auf den auf den teppich gekämpft jetzt geht der tim seinen trecker.
Dreihundertfünfundsiebzig euro.
Kostenlosen ding rechts unten modell.
Der eckig macht sinn weil ecken sind halt meist.
Ja nur weil das gehäuse eckig es heißt nicht trotzdem dass er in der ecke sauber machen kann ne also.
Nee das stimmt aber nur weil sie rund sind auch nicht also das ist beides irgendwie so oder so die müssen ja immer um welche strategie haben wobei rund hat natürlich den vorteil dass er sich halt,
im normalfall,
mindestens immer um sich komplett selber drehen kann aber vielleicht habt ihr auch noch andere methoden dass die räder einfach sich drehen oder,
teil einfach wieder in die andere richtung fährt oder so
wäre ja auch möglich und die räder steuert und nicht einfach nur,
geradeaus und drehen hat als bewegung saß.
Da wird ja ein guter milo scheinbar empfohlen.
Ja was soll das was soll das helfen.
Wieder weg ne krapfen meinte dass er das rechts unten modell geklickt hätte.
Welches rechts und modell von was.
Von den saugt robotern.
Welche saubere.
Scheinbar die die auf dem markt verfügbar sind.
Miete saugt roboter milchmarkt sau großvater echt noch gar nicht gesehen viele sauge roboter sicher.
Er wird jetzt nicht äh aus spaß hier reingeschrieben,
ach so nein manuela stopp.
Quattro cleaning power.
Na der sieht da zumindest schon mal sehr aggressiv aus.
Der zwei bürsten time das brauchst wobei die philips gerade noch zwei würsten oder.
Ja die philips hatten auch zwei bürste.
Also ich äh korrigiere.
Auf dem bild dass auch ecken kann da steht.
Der bauch ist alle aber das jetzt relativ überzeugend aus.
Vielleicht haben sie deswegen nur eine bürste weil die eigentlich nur für die ecke da ist.
An dem man immer hängt.
Na wo sie nicht rankommen damit sie da dann doch in die ecke rankommen.
Hohem wissen schnell zu hause nachschaut verschlüsselt live-bild übertragen der frontkamera was ich kann beim staubsauger beim bürsten zuschauen.
Da kommt der einbrecher rein dann fährt erstmal der saugt roboter hin und sagt wie die.
Geil kannst du so hast du so horror movies drehen mit deinen hamstern ist der hamster irgendwie raus sondern festival hinterher.
Der wird sich oben auf den sauber daraufsetzen gibt's ja nicht so videos wo katzen genau.
Katzen machen das jahr dazu doofe okay mila,
viele unterstellt man ja in gewisser hinsicht ja na also mila alles gut.
Okay was kostet die bei bei philips war rechts unten war drei hundertneunundsiebzig was ist was will miele.
Wenn das miele ist kostet wahrscheinlich über den tausende oder würde mich nicht wundern.
Wir wollen preise sehen.
Schauen wir mal miele saugt.
Zum kauf berater.
Ich sehe schon die rücken gar keine preise raus auf jeden fall website.
Nein das ist das.
Das ist.
Ja das ist auch ein anderes nicht von miele da oben.
Sechs hundertfünfundzwanzig.
Miele x zwei home.
Sechs neunundsiebzig aber da ist auch gleiche noch so einen zusatz teil mit dabei was ist das dieses runde des andere runde ding ne.
Amazon alexa nein weiß ich nicht aber es sieht aus wie 'ne.
Wie alexa.
Ist das ja so ein.
Keine ahnung was das sein soll.
Ach so nee sie wollen glaube ich nur sagen dass es auch mit alexa funktioniert.
Alex.
Kann man auch so per siri steuern und weiter so robin mach mal bitte sauber.
Er ist düsseldorf kramer.
Und das ding will ich ja mal sehen die da wirklich mit mit features wie gerne ich glaub das und ich glaube ja immer noch dass die rente mäßig hin und her fahren.
Gegen den und herfahren spricht eigentlich.
Ja von mir aus auch ein bisschen algorithmus aber auf jeden fall nicht.
Die nicht was nicht also ich weiß ja nicht wofür sie ebenso.
Gar nicht benutzen die sag ich es ist gerade eis grad der hype was alles was irgendwie ein bisschen wo der algorithmus ein bisschen komplizierter als als addieren sagen sie sie benutzen ei,
ich glaube kein wort mehr
aber vielleicht bin ich auch ein bisschen pessimistisch geworden aber ich meine es ist wirklich so ein bisschen schlimm bei jedem scheiße ist gerade die irgendwas und so weiter und.
Auf jeden fall ein dieb clean.
Macht ja auch macht ja auch bei vielen durchaus sinn also man ob es dann sinnvoll zum einsatz gekommen ist und auch funktioniert es steht ja auch einen ganz anderen blatt aber durchaus,
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass es hier problemstellungen gibt die man damit ganz elegant gelöst bekommen aber dieses problem mit versuche jeden,
bereich eines zimmer das auch wirklich oft genug gesaugt zu haben das erfordert halt so ein mobbing wobei bei so einem,
ja sondern eher aus einem was weiß ich,
keine ahnung welches all welche art von anstoßen weiß daraufhin dass ich jetzt auf der katze fahrer oder das irgendwie was zerbrechlich es ist oder
dass ich eine vase um fahre oder so wobei das muss halt auch auf deine scheiß base einfach woanders hin.
Na hier hat er einen aus dem chat sein dass das making gepostet als bild wo sein seinen robert lena lang fährt und meinte das wäre der grundriss seiner wohnung aber ja.
Na warum auch nicht ich.
Scheint kann er sich in der gesamten wohnung so bewegen okay also making machen sie schon mal.
Ja dafür brauchst du jetzt wirklich keine maschine.
Ne würde ich auch behaupten aber meine hätte ich ja auch schon nicht so richtig geglaubt aber gut das kriegen sie.
Doch.
Aber da tauchen jetzt dinge auf die auch möbel sind wenn ich das richtig sehe oder was ist das das heißt er hat dann so eine radar oder wie weil der sieht ja hier sachen wo er nicht lang gefahren ist.
Hin oder stößt oder irgendwie komisch an und markiert das dann.
Ja vor allem da sind ja auch so räume scheinbar dahinter wohl nicht reinkam also das das sieht ja aus wie ein raum.
Na gut kann auch irgendwie ein.
Ne oder das ist eine vorherige.
Das da oben.
Letzte woche lang gefahren ist und beim nächsten mal kann man da nicht rein oder so.
Oder wurde ausgeschlossen.
Hier diese strahlen das weiß er für mich eher darauf hin dass es sich hier um sowas wie eine balkontür handelt dass er durchaus irgendwie,
tisch oder strahlen mäßig.
Spiegel sind auch nett für.
Ja sowas zum beispiel,
und dann kann man die krasse noch bearbeiten okay ist sehr interessant.
Und.
Aber das ist ganz rechts da.
Ja aber dann stimmt das sozusagen.
Hat der zwei balkone ist die frage ah.
Oder viele glastür das kann auch sein.
Die nicht nur rolli zu fall bringen sondern auch schon rum.
Und der rote bereich ist gesperrt da steht das katzenfutter aha okay das,
das heißt das ist nämlich ganz interessant wenn du das hast dann kannst du in das mobbing dinge ein zeichnen und sagen hier nicht,
wenn ihr da genauso so umstoßen kram pflanzen gedöns und so weiter oder sachen wo du einfach auch so in erinnerung an früher.
Einfach bei wem guck mal hier das ist robi und er will man den katzenfutter klauen da können sie sich das untereinander klar machen.
-
Ja oder du lässt einfach so ein bereich frei der einfach so dreckig ist wie es früher immer dreckig war einfach so um dich daran zu erinnern wie es früher war.
So kann es aus.
Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant.
Und die moderne alle schon auf dieser homepage homebase wo sie reinfahren um sich.
An hier und die show mitteilte die machen das tatsächlich mit lieder alter geil wisst das denn,
meinet wegen eines roboters habe ich mein sofa erhöht wenn ich wieder machen flaggen roboter kaufen.
Der andere hat sein bett erhöht war super macht jetzt auch unter dem bett sauber schlimm das heißt man muss erstmal seinem bett und seinen sofa ausmessen damit man weiß wie hoch der robby sein darf ja,
moderne zeiten sehr schön wenn die nächste sofas verkauft dann steht da höhen geeignet für folgt eine kliniken roboter.
Ikea liefert dann die kliniken roboter direkt mit zu dem bett.
Sie können sich das sofa unter sich auch gleich mal selbst sauber machen.
Alter ist das krass roboter hat hatte ich lieder da rotieren ernsthaft oben die laser und irgendwie die scheiße auszumessen.
Das ist ein tesla gar nichts.
Das ist ja irgendwie wie google maps video in der in der home,
und dann guckt er so durch die gegend.
Kannst du bestimmt voll toll.
Hat so ein bisschen was von polizeistreife wenn das ding da so rum blinkt aber.
Es gibt bestimmt auch schon so eine dinge die gleich so alarm zeugt mit drin haben.
Ja bloß bei schaue liter liter wirklich dein grundriss dann irgendwie sofort zur kpö hoch,
es ist doch alle den traut man doch nicht über den weg irgendwie den chinesen.
Direkt deinen social impact factor wird damit korreliert.
Okay na ja jetzt weiß ich immer noch nicht.
Was er dir holen sollst hol dir mal rechts unten immer immer volle pulle.
Lieder haben die meisten guten na gut,
ich weiß jetzt nicht also ich meine ehrlich gesagt außer bekloppter billig roma macht hier irgendwie,
aber so grundsätzlich ist gute strategie nichts schlechtes ich finde vor allem also ein modell ganz gutes behauptet in dieser philipp von sich mit seinen vier rädern das irgendwie in der lage ist auch so schwellen und sowas überschreiten weil das ja oft aus der tür schwellen wurde ja nicht rüberkommt und das dann mal blöd weil er muss quasi immer wieder
wie so 'ne dicke katze ob wir immer wieder den nächsten raum rein tragen damit irgendwie auch nochmal was passiert
und ja mal gucken ich erwarte eure vorschläge und dann gucke ich mal ob ich da genug shopping mich für unser modell zu entscheiden
irgendwas was mich nicht die ganze zeit ausspioniert und.
Schwierig.
Ja wahrscheinlich die dinge dann auch die die die dir die das fachpersonal der zukunft umso putzt und bewacht gleichzeitig und füttert die katze.
Als weiterführende literatur empfehle ich ja den film scheiße namen vergessen,
die mit mit mit dem und dem sänger von kiss wie heißt er,
äh los hier im chat schneller als ich sonst muss ich googeln warte wie heißt der jean simons und äh tom.
Band.
Genau auf deutsch dann noch spenden des todes oder unseren scheiß aber das ist auch schon so äh
putz roboter hills roboter aber die hält von dem bösewicht natürlich gespielt von jean simons von dem mit dem mit der längsten sommer der welt übrigens äh so so chips eingebaut haben die halt evil sind und dann,
aber es also voll der trash movie aber es ist schon wieder so geiler trash und schon wieder,
wird jetzt aktuell mit diesen saugt robotern dass es jetzt den zu gucken eigentlich schon wieder spaß machen könnte.
Nochmal vier dreißig drei gab 's ein talk zu gehacktem show roboter.
Äh was haben wir jetzt jetzt kommt sechsunddreißig also war das äh vorletztes jahr ja.
Ja erstmal leipzig sozusagen das habe ich glatt verpasst toll was auf diesem kongress immer alles stattfindet,
muss ich auch mal hingehen apropos veranstaltung kongress ist dieses jahr auch wurde angekündigt,
das ist jetzt sozusagen offiziell man darf man darf darüber reden kommt ja sehr überraschend ne aber der sechsunddreißig drei steht vor der tür und er wird überraschung überraschung wieder in leipzig stattfinden,
und der club träumt davon eine generischen kopie des letzten jahres zu machen.
Na ja um sich organisatorisch nicht zu übernehmen durch das camp wurde in diesem jahr so ein bisschen der software
war ja so schlecht gar nicht also bauen wir die planung im wesentlichen auf dem auf was wir letztes jahr hatten und dann gucken wir mal wo was verändern kann sogar so will man eigentlich immer rangehen aber eben sozusagen auch wirklich,
um möglichst wenig zusätzliche arbeit zu haben was er letztens bei rauskommt weil sie nicht ganz genau aber es wird auf jeden fall kongress dabei rauskommt,
es gibt jetzt ein käufer papers der läuft nicht mehr so lang,
sechsundzwanzigster oktober das sind jetzt noch drei wochen bis dahin müsstet ihr eure vorschläge für vorträge eingereicht haben also macht das mal besser wenn ihr einen vortrag haben wollt ansonsten,
geht halt der übliche ticket spaß los,
ich hoffe ihr kriegt so viele tickets wir haben wollt.
Es soll wieder ein geklappt.
Na gut beim kongress ist ja nur relativ entspannt.
Sag das den leuten die kein ticket.
Ja aber die die kein ticket bekommen haben ja gut,
ja aber,
es ist jetzt nicht so dass nach zehn minuten alles ausverkauft ist also wenn es losgeht dann schon was zu holen egal wir wissen nicht wie es laufen wird und es sind ja nun mal echt viele leute wir haben schon ganz schön probleme damit dass die,
da passende menge hin auch eine veranstaltung haben wir schon erwähnt und du wolltest auch dass wir das nochmal erwähnen kurz bevor es ist.
Die die.
Das vintage computing festival berlin vfb ist dieses wochenende.
Ach dieses.
Ja guck an ne gut dass das noch mal erwähnt haben das es hat da day ein gesunder.
Und zwar im techniken museum ne weil früher war das ja mal hier in mittel vor.
Genau da wo es jetzt schon länger ist das schon eine weile her ja das jetzt habe ich dritte mal technik museum.
Dritte mal schon okay dabei da war ich bisher noch nicht ich war schon ein paar mal.
Das das ist das ist eine sehr angemessene location dafür also auf jeden fall besser als als die alte definitiv,
ja da wird dann wieder viel alter mist rumstehen und nach bauprojekte und so weiter und wenn ihr am samstag oder sonntag zeit habe ich schon im kopf muss trainieren.
Aber wenn man die irgendwo abgibt könnte man ja in der zwischenzeit.
Aber am samstag muss doch nicht trainieren.
Nee am samstag äh will ich aber nichts machen,
ich brauche so ein bisschen die ruhe ja die ruhe vor dem sturm.
Mäßig katze auch haben.
Ne ich glaub nicht dass ich das dann noch dazu haben kann.
Egal dann halt ohne letty aber wir sind irgendwie bestimmt irgendwo da und hängen da rum und schauen uns um die alten scheiße,
du auch dennis oder oder hast du davon geredet jetzt hast du keine zeit und deswegen guckst gerade sein,
je nachdem wie es kommt das ist doch mal eine klare.
Wann ist schluss zeit.
Zeit.
Am samstag bis zwanzig dreißig ach nee das.
Ne da ist die party dann.
Also am samstag von zehn bis zwanzig uhr und abends gibt's dann wieder,
party da sollte man sich vielleicht auch mal was neues einfallen lassen und am sonntag geht's immerhin bis siebzehn uhr dreißig von zehn.
Aussteller aufbau am freitag.
Ja da kann man schon mal gucken was ist genau und irgendwie all diese ganzen sachen von denen noch nie was gehört habt alte computerspiele natürlich und computer all diese ganze kram und.
Ära der blinken,
ja das ist schon mal die trommel haben wir ja schon mehrfach getrocknet aber so alte computer angucken das auf jeden fall ganz cool ich war ja auch jetzt in cambridge und hat mir mal diesen selbstgebauten computer angeschaut.
Diesen diesen diesen hatten wo der typ alles mit.
Über die mehreren panele.
Genau der sogar mehrere panele verteilt ist und wo wirklich jeder einzelne zustand aber wirklich jeder einzelne zustand mit einer led ist,
und ich hab den typen aus selber getroffen der hatte sich ein bisschen zeit genommen und ein paar fragen beantwortet und ja es war ganz interessant ist mega nerd wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt,
aber das fand ich besonders interessant was noch geil weiß ich gar nicht so geahnt habe er ist nämlich eigentlich auch programmierer,
also er kommt so aus der ganzen software welt,
und das projekt hat er gestartet um wie sollte es anders sein mal das mit der hardware zu verstehen was er bisher halt noch nicht so verstanden hat grandioser ansatz natürlich.
Aber alles eigentlich ist das ja auch immer der weg so oder dass äh man immer mit dieser hardware zu tun hat aber man man will es halt mal richtig verstehen und und sehen weil der typ der hatte macht den interessiert das ja alles nicht der ist schon viel weiter vorne und er hatte sozusagen alles hinter sich
und ja.
Genau und ja deswegen hat er dieses projekt gestartet diesen mega,
prozessor wie das ding so schön heißt und ich hatte jetzt,
mir ist beim nach nachhinein weil ich etwas von mir selber enttäuscht hätte noch ein bisschen mehr fotos machen sollen als als ich letzten endes gemacht habe,
aber das teil ist genauso beeindruckend live wie man das schon erahnen t von den fotos wenn man da mal so auf dem weltmarkt guckt mega prozessor,
und paar sachen sind wirklich,
irre gut also ich habe jetzt zum beispiel paar ein paar sachen habe ich jetzt erst so richtig verstanden so zum beispiel wie,
hält ein register eigentlich sein speicher.
Wie meinst du hält.
Ja ist ein speicher naja der füttert einfach sich selber immer wieder mit dem input von von sich selber
gibt's dann immer solche multi plex schaltung wo immer so also diese ganze dieser bit verschiebe bahnhof den so so ein computer eigentlich ist dann kann man da sehr gut nachvollziehen
was hat das totale mega empowerment ist wirklich dieser schalter mit denen du den tag drehen kannst also kannst du das ding ja da irgendwie auf.
Schneller langsam machen.
So richtig mit uns leider immer langsamer langsamer langsamer der zeit dann auch die herz zahl an und dann hast du das ding so auf ein herz runter,
coaching coaching so alle dinge ändern sich und dann noch langsam alles irgendwie immer so fünf sekunden lang der zustand steht das ist schon immer so davor stehen kannst dann kannst du
was jetzt so das nächste sein könnte und dann begreifst überhaupt erst so wie er seine instruktionen fetsch und die dann irgendwie umsetzt und dann
ah jetzt muss irgendwie was addiert werden und dann siehst du schon so richtig die zahlen an rauschen ja irgendwie so oben im regisseur anliegen nächsten schritt wenn die dann irgendwie
abgespeichert und dann dann dann dann dann wird das irgendwie alles addiert und du kannst auch diesen addieren nachvollziehen,
klar wird ist dass das einfach so 'ne maschine unglaublich einfach ist auf der einen seite auf der anderen seite hat er diesen
diesen prozess aber auch schon ganz schön gepimpt also er hat schon diverse optimierung da drin um nicht zu viel,
zeit verluste zu haben na ja und ich,
hofft dass ich irgendwann nochmal so einen modus kommen wo ich vielleicht für das teil mal so ein bisschen coach schreibe weil es reizt einfach gerade insbesondere mit diesem geilen zweihundertsechsundfünfzig bald,
display was er da noch angeschlossen hat.
Also ein raum visualisiert.
Weil es nicht das rahmen x ist next also es ist memory aber es nicht teil der cdu,
also das eigentliche ding ist eine cdu so der bildschirm der speicher ist ja nicht teil der cdu das ist halt extern und er hat halt auf der einen seite hatte halt so 'n richtigen speichelstein extern angeschlossene wo so acht,
memory hat und dann hat er halt nochmal zweihundertsechsundfünfzig bei memory explizit als.
Als bildschirm gemacht also als bitte als bitte im im eigentlichen sinne,
chat kommt die frage mit kann man durchsetzen ja klar kann man also man kann so richtig da so ältere absetzen und siehe da wieder hinterhaupt abgearbeitet wird dann geht an diesen halt modus und dann hast du halt so 'n single step button und da kannst du richtig,
klick klick klick klick da stehen und das ganze ding irgendwie durch steppen also wer so ein bisschen schenkung hat und sich nicht irgendwie alles komplett von grund auf neue erklären lassen muss also wer,
zu meinen etwa weiß womit man es zu tun hat so das ist zumindest im vorfeld so macht das lohnt sich extrem dahin zu fahren man kommt da rein das gleich im ersten raum,
ist das steht das ding da rum,
alle alle register wo zahlen gespeichert werden es nochmal separat nochmal expedition mal display dran so dass man eben auch schnell zahlen erfassen kann also muss jetzt nicht permanent übersetzen sondern,
geht dann irgendwie auch so und daran kann man einfach eine menge lernen und wenn man,
wenn man es richtig gut vorbereitet sein will würde ich sagen vorher noch,
seite schauen dass man instruktionen setzt sich so ein bisschen an liest
so
der ist jetzt nicht besonders komplexer funktioniert im wesentlichen so wie man das so erwarten würde und ist auch relativ logisch aufgebaut ja dann,
kann man halt.
Tetris beim laufen zu schauen sozusagen und dann wirklich so im single step jedes einzelne bild wird gemalt ist schon echt cool,
wofür war eine schöne schöne ausflug.
Na wenn ich nach cambridge fahren will dann gibt's auf youtube von diesem band der baut auch diesen acht bitcoin futter ähnlich wie er nur dass er nicht an alles eine led dran hat glaube ich,
aber wo man halt alles selber zusammenbauen kann so oft bread boards und der erklärt wirklich bis ins detail so dass man es auch,
einigermaßen gut versteht also ich fand es sehr sehr gut gemacht das ist sozusagen das gleiche wenn man das da so ein ding selber bauen will aber kann ich euch jetzt schon vor waren weil ich hab 's auch mal angefangen mit einem kumpel
aber diese drähte alle zu verlegen also wir haben zwei so eine botschaft dann hat man keinen bock mehr ist es wirklich ganz schöner fummel kram also die chips da
zu stecken das alles nichts das ding aber die drehte so man muss wirklich gucken von wonach wo und wie schön da so lang legen und das
das dauert ewig also auch vor allem die dreht auf länger zu schneiden das ist so das problem,
weil der holt dir ein video mal schön fertig raus und es sieht immer so easy aus aber das ist echt nicht easy bei so einem draht musst immer beide enden ab isolieren wir haben da schon so 'ne pistole der so automatisch macht sondern,
klicker ding aber diese länge immer genau gucken dass es passt weil die drehte du willst ja nicht dass sie in der luft stehen also es ist kein einfaches projekt das kann ich mal sagen.
Aber man hat ja noch andere projekte unter anderem auch ein bild x v auto computer also quasi so,
selber bauen das jetzt nicht die ganze cdu bau sein und im zeit einfach die fertige cpu und basteln so speichern den ganzen kram dran das könnte ganz
und auch noch ein leonhardt der internet works habe ich jetzt nicht gehört aber wenn er irgendwie so guten tutorial ansatz hat,
platz das ist ja auch interessant weil ich mir mal anschauen,
wir sind durch oder.
Ja ne ich hatte eine sache noch gerne gewusst weil es twitter konnte mir auch nicht antworten follower power wie dich was aus dem clipboard an ans ende von meinem,
im auf.
Indem du an das ende des textes deine lehrer zeile machst doppelklick und reinfügen.
Wenn ich mich doppelklick mache jetzt bei dreizehn dann wählt ihr automatisch das letzte wort und ich will nicht das letzte wort ersetzen weil das ist nämlich weg möchte ich nicht wenn die kurzen dann kann man das mal machen dann füge ich das danach wieder ein aber eigentlich will ich
hinten ein oder gerade an den text wo ich bin da so,
in dem augenblick also hinten aber ich will ja eventuell auch weiter tippen danach,
ich will einfach nur mal so ein wort einfügen was aber eins weiß ich nicht abtippen wollte was ich von der webseite geklaut hat oder vielleicht,
bei mir also ich hab da irgendwie was an dieser neuen tastatur nicht verstanden ich kriege das nicht hin.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie hallo dennis in mein.
Einmal klicken.
Also ich gehe auf den.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal ein wort kopieren.
Kannst du nochmal die aufgabe kurz beschreiben.
Du hast ja ein wort dein kaiser blinkt ganz am ende und da will ich jetzt einfach das aus dem clip da rein peace.
Einmal draufklicken.
Der körper ist das.
Einmal aufs display an in der nähe von.
Na einmal drauf tippen.
Einmal nur ne zweimal.
Das war schon immer so doch immer einmal schon immer.
So dann hätten wir das auch für dich geklärt werden.
Das war schon immer so.
Aber ich kann habe ich habe ich immer zweimal getippt weil ich dachte das ist einmal okay dann ist der witz,
das zweimal tippen also das war wahrscheinlich früher auch einmal tippen ich habe immer zweimal gemacht weil zweimal keine bedeutung hatte hatten die gedacht okay ich will passen und dann kam das jetzt hat zweimal tipp aber eine bedeutung nämlich das letzte wort auswählen anscheinend oder überhaupt selection,
das gabs wohl vorher nicht und das macht er jetzt und deswegen habe ich es.
Na ja es ist schon es ist es ist ja ich bin sehr glücklich über diese änderung weil sie die logik die teilweise von schlechten programmieren ja auch schon fast gekillt wurde wieder zurückgeholt haben weil,
doppelklick ist ein wort triple klick es ein satz und quattro klick ist ein absatz,
das war schon früher beim immer so,
und teilweise durch dieses ganze jahr war gedöns und so weiter wo die dann irgendwie alle bei dem system entkommen sind und ihre eigenen körper kontrolle hatten
hast du dieses selections verhalten nicht mehr bis irgendwann keiner mehr irgendwas geschnallt hat wie das irgendwie eigentlich funktionieren soll für das sehr gut.
Einmal klicken man.
Das ist also gerade bei längeren texten ist es extrem.
Ja auf meck weiß ich das eigentlich mit einer und zwar klickt einfach mal mehr umso größer dann haben wir es auch ganz logisch.
Ja natürlich ist es total logisch und ist auch voll praktisch und jetzt haben sie halt eben ich weiß nicht genau wie sie gemacht haben aber die eigentliche änderungen eiweiß dreizehn ist ja,
dass du eben einfach irgendwohin tippen kannst und dann soll da der körper sein das funktioniert.
Einen bestimmten buchstaben ändern will also zurück scrollen,
das einmal tippen hat mir teilweise dann das wort selektiert und das mit dem vor und zurück schleiden wo jetzt eigentlich der körper hin soll das funktioniert für mich.
Ich muss jetzt hier auf die leertaste drücken und dann kann man durch den.
Aber war das nicht auch schon immer so.
Ja aber vorher gab es auch noch einen anderen weg nämlich den von früher ganz am anfang dieses mit dass das ganze tastatur verschwindet und man frei bewegen kann das ist.
Und du hattest eine kleine bildschirm lupe wurde im prinzip.
Genau die lupe die ist nämlich jetzt weg und ich habe das immer über diese lupe gemacht und.
Das stimmt die lupe vermisse ich eigentlich auch warum ist das jetzt eigentlich nicht da.
Weil manchmal weiß ich nämlich nicht wie das.
Ach so nee es gibt was es gibt noch was anderes und zwar kannst du du kannst es funktioniert eigentlich wie die lupe wenn du nämlich lange warte mal wie krieg ich das zuverlässig wenn du wenn du drauf drückst.
So weiter festhält.
Wird der körper so lang und dann kannst du den auch beliebig durch die gegend fahren.
Manchmal funktioniert das manchmal hat's bei mir nicht funktioniert aber gerade wenn du einen kurzen text hast dann,
ist halt im prinzip der daumen da und du weißt nicht bei welchem buchstaben er denn jetzt anhält also.
Ja du kannst aber den finger und dabei runterziehen und.
Er genau das das wusste ich halt nicht.
Aber dass der körper größer wird es eigentlich auch ganz nett aber man sieht eben nicht.
Ist es ja dann da drunter also du du schiebst den körper über dir.
Ah du meinst jetzt einen großen text ich hab ja hier so eine eine zeile.
Für eine zeile funktioniert das nur so begrenzt gut geht aber auch.
Ja aber es ist mir egal ich kann ja wenn ihr mehr,
dann macht er ja auch mehrere zeit aber die das eingabe feld ist erstmal nur eins oder fängt mit einem an also es ist halt.
Ging doch eben bei dir.
Ja ging jetzt hab ich es auch raus langsam tippen,
und dann bewegen ja ich finde es halt die leute noch gewöhnt sind alles mit diesem mit den blumen denkst zu machen und auch so tippen wie man das bei der lupe halt machen musste dann haben sie haben jetzt eine menge ändert wo mein,
wo ich nicht wusste wie sie's gemacht haben und jetzt ist klar einmal tippen hat alles ganz logisch.
Bei mir ist irgendwie die das wörterbuch ein bisschen eigenartig so ich habe diese vorschläge drin.
Weißt du was ich vermute weil die sagen ja auch die machen damit maschinen learning denen würde ich sogar zutrauen keine ahnung,
ich hab so das gefühl das alte system da was ich dein style gemerkt hat,
den haben sie gefeuert wir haben jetzt einen neuen eingestellt.
Auf.
Wer kennt das noch nicht und du musst dir wieder neu an lernen.
Ich habe das gefühl sie wollen so ein bisschen intelligenter sein so.
Ja aber vielleicht muss vielleicht fängt er bei null an gerade der musste ich erst kennenlernen also ich muss jetzt lernen wie dein.
Er möchte dich einfach ganz neu.
Ein neues system muss erstmal wissen wie du so drauf.
Frisch anfangen wie beim ersten mal.
Aber der john gruber von dem auch schon das getippt da da kommen sie hatte ja noch nie gesehen also.
Ja genau.
Schlimm und dachte so dann ihm liegen aber er hat mal auf,
nachgefragt und es werden ganz viele die da probleme mit hätten,
und ich finde auch erst deutlich mehr wörter die der mir setzt wo ich gerade gar nicht so doll falsch getippt habe also was hätte man früher nicht gemacht.
Aber aber ich habe ja jetzt auch ich weiß nicht ob ihr das auch schon gemacht hat diese neue zwei bereits auf dem keyboard ausprobiert ich weiß nicht.
Funktioniert super gut aber es ist zu langsam.
Ich weiß nicht wie man's bedient glaube ich.
Oh ich finde das also wenn das so bei android schon immer war.
Was ziemlich werden immer andere leute guckst dir das so benutzen die sind das also erkennt das ziemlich gut.
Dann ist das ein feature was ich sage mal zu unrecht ignoriert habe aber es ist ich finde es relativ schnell also insbesondere wenn du so.
Das ist schnell.
Längere worte hast und so weiter also schneller ist eigentlich nur noch sprach.
Aber ich tippe immer mit mit zwei daumen so und das ist nicht schneller als ich mir zwei daumen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen ich weiß noch nicht mal wie ich es bedienen richtig.
Doch es ist präziser finde ich weil du halt bei komplexen worten und da wiederum funktioniert das mit dem wetter,
relativ gut also es ist natürlich im deutschen immer schwierig bei den zusammengesetzten wort weil man denkt ja die ganze zeit irgendwas neues aus
roboter staubsauger roboter saurer saugt roboter lalala wir haben irgendwie alles fünfzig verschiedene varianten über das bauen können,
das muss halt jetzt erstmal rein aber ich habe relativ gute ergebnisse erzielt mit seiner.
Ich hab 's kurz getestet und das war auch erstaunlich gut hätte ich nicht gedacht ich glaube ein problem ist aber auch mein hirn,
kann so noch nicht tippen ich bin es gewöhnt einzeln diese buchstaben unbewusst raus zu ballern das ist so drin irgendwie und ich diese linien ziehen so dass sobald es ist ja ja ich muss mir sozusagen winkel oder richtung merken die ich das ziehen muss weil es ist ja auch nicht,
den buchstaben sondern von hier jetzt musst du schräg da hoch so das muss der merkt wenn du von a nach b will zum beispiel so weißt du was ich meine du musst ja so hoch.
Merken tastatur halt meine.
Ja aber das ist anders als tipp und dann muss ich mir jetzt die wörter nochmal anders merken beim eingeben ich weiß nicht wie ich das genau sagen.
Das ist ein anderes mary das muss man einmal neue lernen und man wird dann schneller.
Kann es sein dass man schnell wird aber ich hab ich hab das eine weile gemacht und dachte ich nee das ist mir jetzt auch zu zu nervig und zu langsam ich tipp wieder mit meinen mit meinen zwei zwei daumen so,
ich habe das ja auch so eine hand also ich weiß nicht wie viel zeichne ich oder zeichen oder wörter pro minute schaffe aber ich finde es ist relativ flott.
Ich habe auf meinem telefonieren handy dem nokia noch tee neun also wieder tenor es ist auch erstmal 'ne umstellung.
Und dein iphone kann nicht mehr telefonieren oder.
Doch ob ich ihr habt halt eine telefonnummer die ich an leute rausgebe wo ich weiß dass sie einen anrufen und dann hab ich das telefon was ich die ganze zeit an meinem körper trage.
Du keine anrufen darf.
Also.
Ja wo ich auch manchmal sprachnachrichten bekomme.
Hey du hast mir selber schon bei einer geschickt.
Unglaublich sprachnachrichten.
Ja
Ja hallo und ich bin dann gleich da ist wohl aufnehme rum.
Ja aber das so läuft man rum weil man so blöd ist das telefon zu bedienen man kann's nämlich auch ans ans ohr halten so als würde man telefonieren.
Nee kann man nicht so gut weil ich hab 's mir mal erklären lassen das sind der whatsapp sprachnachrichten und die müssen da den button solange festhalten und es sieht am oder es geht am ohr nicht so gut whatsapp ja.
Du hast denn genau und wo lag der fehler guck an wenn man das über thema macht funktioniert das.
Ich hatte einen rausschmeißen.
Wirst rausschmeißen.
Ein etwas werbespots.
Dann können wir den ja hinten anstellen musste dann den noch irgendwie einleiten und erklärte sich selber.
Kann man denn auch die box meiner kann ich kopfhörer abnehmen schon.
Na klar denn ist das geht doch alles aber du musst vorher noch tschüss sagen.
Danke.
So leute vielen dank für's zuhören das war's von uns früher heute bis bald tschüss.
Eine schwere erkältet aber ins krankenhaus musst du dafür nichts wenn die notaufnahme nicht nötig ist der ärztliche bereitschaft dienst hilft weiter sechs sieben die nummer mit dem.